Oh my
god, I, oh my god, I forgot to, okay, no, no, I'm moving
now.
I forgot to press connect.
I'm not gonna make it.
I'm not.
It's so fucking early.
I'm not gonna make it, Chad.
I'm sorry.
I'm so tired, guys.
for being late guys to my defense it is a nine it was a 9 a
.m tournament to my defense I had a very long day guys I was
doing the maid cafe stuff yesterday um okay I don't know how
to fuck min and I both also scheduled streams today too by
the way um but after yesterday I don't know we're going to
survive i i don't know how we're gonna survive because we we
underestimated how much work we were going to do because
that was just one block and it was really fun but it was
still a lot of work so we both underestimated it how much
work it's gonna be um it was really fun but the only problem
is is that today is a it's two session block so it's not
it's not one session it's two it's it's from oh my god dvr
is on okay my you can tell i didn't make the waiting room
all right i have now revoked your access to rewind so you
could tell when that's why i didn't even tweet the um i
didn't even tweet the waiting room because i fucking i was i
was sleeping i was already gone i was sleeping i your rights
have been revoked in the i didn't even boot up like rivals
yeah this is we were like why the fuck is this tournament at
nine in the fucking morning it's because it's an eu slash na
tournament um that i got invited to like i know i'm sorry
there's like i didn't give a lot of information about this
but also i i'm very tired right now no it's not happening
technically it's oh i missed the meaning too they're like um
we're gonna have a meaning an hour i'm there's no way
everyone was also there in uh in the meaning as well but i
they were just like we're gonna go over the rules of
everything So make sure you're there.
And make sure you're...
I did not make sure I was there, unfortunately.
I was still waking up.
There was no...
Unfortunately, there was no make sure you were there from my
hand.
No, I'm just...
I'm not used to being...
awake at this looking time but uh it's for like regular
people this is this is okay uh it's not it's not it's not
okay for me it's it does not feel okay for me right now and
what was i say okay so so um but yeah we have um we have two
sessions today and oh my god i you know i you know like this
tournament and i was like what's the times like because like
i have a the maid like i have an event on on saturday on on
is this saturday on is this saturday oh on saturday i'm
sorry i'm so messed up right now i was like what day is it
today i don't even remember anymore uh on saturday and
they're like oh it'll be at this time i was like oh i have
to to be gone by um by like at least five because I have to
at least five because I have to you know view the main cafe
stuff and they're like no you'll be fine the tournament
won't go that long I'm like oh that's that's good that
that's good that it won't and I'm thinking I'm like why the
fuck I was like I could do both like Joe for us fast turkey
why the fuck did you do this to me you could you could not
do both but it's too late we're in it or how the fuck did
you say you could do both like but it's too late it's okay
men is also streaming too like she decided to also do a
stream on top of the maid cafe so we should so we both we
both have like made bad decisions in life uh you know what's
great my manager was like make sure you should go make sure
you don't stream anything on that on on saturday because you
have two sessions you guys do i was like oh don't worry i'll
don't worry i'm not that stupid
little did i little did i no oh no i am that stupid i i was
like it's okay it's just a tournament it should be fine it
was not fine i'm not feeling fine right now
He's like, every time you overschedule, you get really
tired.
I'm like, nah, don't worry, I won't overschedule.
I, I, I was like, that's future Doki's problem if she
decides to overschedule it.
And then, and then now it has become present Doki's problem.
Every, every time, every fucking time I never learn.
I remember I was just like, two males just like, oh my gosh,
we're going to be doing two sessions tomorrow, i.e.
today.
I was like, we're like, we're going to be okay.
Oh my God.
Oh, it's fun.
It's just, it is a lot of energy for sure, but I, um, it's
been, it's been really fun because like, it's my first, maid
cafe collab um so i had a lot of fun like just like
interacting with all the dragoons and whiffs and also like
oh the photo thing is really cute because it's like a cheque
for this don't know what a cheque is like a polaroid photo
um was in maid cafes usually do like a polaroid photo with
the maid and stuff and then like draw on it and everything
um so they'd sim stimulate they
they simulated it in a way where like you could take a
picture with me or and men i mean you could choose like you
can do both as well well not in the same photo but like
we're in different booths but you can get both photos of us
um so like we're like on yeah so uh so like we'll be on the
side like in the photo and then you could like take a
picture you can technically like take a picture with us so
it's really it's really cute it's really cute i was like
doing different outfits and technically gets like a unique
outfit and pose and everything so um so like i brought dad a
lot too like some lucky dragoons got the gap dad gotcha so
he would show up in your photos um i am so fucking dead i am
so fucking dead i'm sorry to any team that dressed me today
i'm sorry i still have yet to boot up marvel rivals all
right don't worry guys okay give me a sec let me let me pull
this up right now okay um oh my god what is this document is
this uh oh that's the broad oh there's the schedule okay
they're at okay drafting starts in three minutes but like i
don't even start the team so it's fine all right where am i
what the fuck is this okay what is this list i'm on an off
support i did not know i was an off support player i there's
like a there's the list right now and i am categorized as
off support and i was like bro i didn't even know i'm i'm
not i'm an my role is in life i okay if i'm lagging because
i'm booting up rival um i realize the reason why my rivals
keep booting up on the fucking my chat monitor by the way oh
that is so front oh my god it's so loud give me a sec um my
my thing boots up on my third monitor because like my third
monitor is considered monitor one which is fucking weird i
don't know why um oh my god okay me a sec guys i am making
it put i don't know how to fix that i think you have to like
i think i have to like re-plug everything to have that fixed
but i don't know oh how do i change that how do i change
monitor to become not that monitor how to change
Oh, I can change it in display settings.
Just make it Windows.
Displays is...
Yeah, it is the order...
Yeah, it is the order your cables are plugged into GP.
I assume it's that because I couldn't find it.
I couldn't find it on the thingy.
So I was like, I don't know.
I don't know how to make my display one not display one no
more.
um yeah i have to swap the cables but it's so far it really
is so far
it's i i can't be i can't be bothered all right give me a
sec let me figure this out okay uh what are people oh my
gosh everyone's hanging out in the general chat but i am a
but i am very nervous so i shall not
but i am a introvert so i shall not hang out in the fucking
discord channel Wait, I am a loner.
This is Stokey's Morning Voice.
My Morning Voice was the voice that I used when I started
the stream.
That was my, I fucking chose the wrong event.
I should have been, they told me the time and I was like, I
can do that.
I'm thinking, what the fuck, Bastoki?
You're not the one waking up.
You're not the one waking up for this shit.
What the fuck do you mean I can do that?
I can't, I cannot, I cannot do that.
Okay, okay, let me grab the volume thing.
Oh my god, I'm not okay.
I'm not okay, okay.
Here you go.
Alright.
Oh, fuck.
Give me a second.
I'm gonna pull up the...
What was it?
Oh, yeah, there is a day two, by the way.
I don't know if I...
Oh, they're drafting tanks right now.
If I'm last pick, I will not be surprised.
I'm looking at the list of names.
I'm like, if I'm last pick, it's okay.
like maybe i'll be last pick on a cool ass team who knows
why the am i at the i'm at like the end of the list too i'm
at the end of the list for this that's that's crazy okay
it's fine let's you know what let's go oh fuck oh my god i
forgot okay give me a sec we gotta mute i please don't
my god i forgot about this how do i i have to mute it
because apparently oh my gosh okay our our vibes is my okay
okay the song okay let's hope the songs let's hope the
stream survives um i forgot about it no my my ad revenue oh
my god okay so um the reason why i had to mute the stream is
because um it's because this song in particular is yeah I
muted the stream because I just it just clicked in my head
uh that's why you don't fucking hear it like clicked in my
head like what the fuck I'm listening to um so um this song
is DMCAable apparently the rival song is DMCAable and that's
like um the all the rival vibes on twitch not just me but
other streamers um they can't also we that's why i should
never go to time square too like in game i could i'm not
banned from time square in new york city but like in in the
rivals because the the rival song is dmca able and they have
not fixed that uh apparently is copyrightable and like in on
some twitch some some streamers had their thank god uh my
only got muted so like there's nothing to worry about for
that um so let's see i'm trying to remember how to change
this it's i don't remember how to change this uh guys do you
guys remember how to fucking uh customize oh here a home
background okay there you go that's like all right let's
just put it on the married couple Yeah, no, I know you can
change it because I changed it to this because I was like,
oh, happy birthday Because I thought it was a really cute
fucking picture and And I found out the the rival song has
been is like it's been causing issues Uh, Brady, thank you
for the average venue.
They should set up a streamer DMCA mode Thank you.
Thank you.
It's like I just I think a lot of people just didn't realize
it rogue um I'm a can see quick match uh oh my god oh wait
sorry I practice range she's literally she's just a fighting
game character like that's all I can say um she seems really
strong and she has some good asses I'll be glad to use them
for you she's literally a fighting character look at that
I'm beating the shit there's a block and then and then hers
her kick and then I can fly oh never mind I can't fly and
then I just absorb yeah so I mean that's cool I think that's
the cool fire I like the you can upstairs you can tell it
tells you what you can gain so get stealth mode you can get
like this i didn't do like okay give me a sec i'll kick him
out though for us yeah and then pow pow pow yeah and then i
can absorb and then now i can shout oh bro i but yeah there
you go demonstration over That's all you need to know
anyway, so I don't need, okay, let's, I guess I'll buy it.
I mean, I have so many credits, I might as well spend it.
I will never use it, but maybe I'll use the Rock.
Okay, I will say the Thieves one is really cute.
I will say that as a Rocket Hater, as a Rocket Hater, I will
say the Thieves one is pretty cute.
It's a good skin.
can appreciate fine all right i'm so sad i really wanna i
really i like this i think it's funny the furry of the year
2025 save for lady loki bro okay what do you mean save
guys i think i've saved enough i
um yeah um chat yeah but you can see this right you can see
you can see this right there's some i i can see it yeah you
think i don't think i don't think that would be enough i
think you might need more
I decided to do a stretch that's not my cry of pain.
I was just stretching it could be honestly I think it's 50
50 but I'm gonna say it now I don't think it's lady Loki
guys I think it's hella I'm sorry I'm here to be the bear
I'm here to be realistic but that really looks like hella
guys that really really looks like hella Like, I can't deny
it.
No, I need Lady Loki.
Coltrane, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki, hope you have a good stream.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Of course, Coltrane.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Coltrane.
Yeah, happy birthday.
Oh my gosh, okay, but yeah, no, I feel, I don't know, it
feels, I feel, she really, okay, how do I access, how do I
access that picture, I know, like, it's in here, if anyone
knows, oh, there it is, okay, oh, I have to be level two,
God, okay, I guess we'll never know, so here, you can tell
from this alone, that's Lady Loki right there, how the fuck,
do I not, for free give it to me oh yeah i guess it's
because like i just booted this game all right why am i like
at the bottom of the list i don't like that
i'm like you're like i'm just like an outlier some like
they're like i don't know where to put it let's just put
your virus like i don't even have anyone like like there's
like these are all the support players, and I feel like I'm
like outcasted away in the fucking, in the fucking shadow
realm.
Like, what?
We can't like, what the fuck?
Why am I?
Why am I down there?
She can't sit with us.
She's not that she's not made of flesh.
It's not sorted.
There's no way this is sorted alphabetically.
My name starts with D, and there's Desley up there.
I'm, yeah, I'm on the fucking kids table right now.
I'm in the fucking kids table.
What the fuck?
Yeah, the new alphabet drops.
You think she's part of the team.
Oh, and they're like, Oh, wait, we were like, they had like,
it was like perfect symmetry.
And they're like, I think we're missing someone.
And they're like, oh, shit, wait, yeah.
We forgot Dinky Britain just added it in real quick.
So, yeah.
Because I don't know about, I should warm up too, but I'll
just do quick play.
I'm not fucking playing over a game.
It's sad.
We'll warm up and quick play.
Let's see if we can go.
Oh.
uh oh okay let's go i mean they they're they're choosing
supports last no mohat or what there is a chance i am last
pick i they are picking supports last um i don't even know
guys what the fuck is meant oh yeah i bought the i bought uh
i got this guys i think this is cute this is their cutest
outfit i like this outfit i hate her all like graphics
though i will say the one thing i'm not a fan of is just
like the the alt graphics are hit or miss they're so hit or
miss because it's so hard to see whenever someone's all
thing like because they're all different now like they're
all like there are all different colors and graphics and
like it's so hard it's like whatever the fuck alt is going
out now because everyone has their own fancy little alt
graphic yeah she's cute now she's pretty cute oh my god it's
a fucking It's okay, she's wearing bloomers, guys.
It's okay, it's not wrong.
She's wearing bloomers.
Okay, to be fair, I'm, like, thinking it's quick play.
Like, what the fuck are they gonna do to me?
They did a lot.
Okay, I would usually never do that, but I was like, it's
quick play.
Like, I don't care.
Bro, I was...
I thought it was quick play!
Okay!
I'm thinking, oh it's quick play, it should be fine.
Like, oh my god, I hit him one time, it's all that.
I did one hit.
There you go.
Look, see?
It's fine.
I just chuck it into the sky and then it hits someone
because it's so fucking fast.
Okay, I'll give it to myself because apparently I can't
trust people to heal me oh i don't know if i like that bell
child it's a bit annoying look it's a hit guarantee dude
that's that's the mess up part hello why is there a penny
behind oh my god what's i think i was lucky zeal
that's funny because lucky zeal is a spider-man one trick or
I don't know.
Mostly a Spider-Man player.
Oh my god, the first time it didn't hit anything.
The captain's part is like, I don't know.
I guess he count as a pro, I guess, if they're like, because
they're supposed to have, like, a limit on how many pros
people can have.
Yeah, the perfect hit.
Okay, it is quick then.
Yeah!
I'm ready, dance, everyone.
Yeah, I'm back in Luna jail.
Actually, no, I'm considering off support, so I can do this.
Oh, money, honey left.
Bye, money, honey.
All right, here we go.
It's fine.
I can leave a quick play whenever.
It's okay, I can heal myself.
If I can't trust no one, I can trust myself.
Bro, I'm not giving you my heals.
I'm not getting healed either, so...
Wow, look at that.
I hit somebody.
It's so fucking fast.
It better hit somebody.
Okay.
I don't know if I like the sound for this, though.
It's pretty annoying.
I will say the sound is very annoying.
It is absolutely...
What the fuck?
What the fuck is he doing there?
Oh, okay, cool.
Okay, cool.
Yeah, I'll turn it off.
I just wasn't sure what the sound sounded like until now.
Until now, I realize it's alright.
It's quick play.
I'm not losing much from this.
I wanted to check something out, but I forgot what it was.
It's alright.
Okay, it's a bit sad that I'm amazed, but it's okay.
It's it's okay.
It's quick play It is a bit sad
Yeah, it's okay.
I wanted to check something up.
I forgot what I wanted to check out Oh, yeah, I wanted to
show you guys my recap.
It's pretty funny.
I don't know how to access it but if i can find it i will
show you guys the recap because it's pretty silly
you're right i can't trust myself i keep sabotaging myself
no no my my rivals recap i don't know if i can check it i
don't know actually oh our spider-man left I don't know.
It's a little sad.
My quick play team is slowly leaving me.
Bro, it's quick play.
Like, what the fuck do you expect?
Like, quick play has the most random rank distribution.
This is why, like, during the VTuber rivals thing, every
other team was just, like, practicing via...
They were practicing via, like, quick play.
But, like, you get, like, bronze players in quick play
sometimes.
so so we went like actual we actually screamed against teams
because of it because i was just like yeah no yeah it's like
you like i would i would look at rank stats and stuff i'd be
like bro what the fuck i there would be like multiple bronze
silver players in quick play so like for the youtuber rivals
we organized scrims and stuff so we can actually have real
practice because playing against bronze players in a
tournament like if you're trying to practice for a
tournament is not not a not a good like practice in general
it's easier to form bad habits too okay i'm giving myself
the things oh god damn it there you go it's okay i'm healing
myself because I can't trust you guys.
Whoa.
It's okay.
I got the gambit out, though.
Oh.
She's taking everything.
Oh, he's dead.
No, he's so dead.
Oh, he's alive.
Yeah, I'll give you this.
Oh, hey.
The guy that came over to replace our other guy is a widow
player.
That's okay.
Like, I honestly, what can you expect?
Oh, and then the Spider-Man's gonna come in And she's gonna
be like He's gonna be like Whoa I don't remember the
Spider-Man I don't remember what he says I just know the
fuck Spider-Man Alright, I heal Oh, there he is Cool Steve
He's so cool there he is all right they're almost done
drafting though that's fine they're almost done drafting
guys it's okay yeah i am still ace our two dps players that
came in to replace the two that left is okay is
I'm on team three Who am I Who am I playing with?
I'm on Gail's team Okay What did it say?
What did it say?
Let's see I get This is Oh Rigsie and a rigsy
socialize time I know the worst part I know alright how do I
look at my my
what why did they say dokey what is it until dokey is here
what what
yes oh is it cuz they thought I wasn't here I'm literally
here oh is it cuz like I'm not live on Twitch and they're
like where the fuck is she like they're like where is she
she's not even live because I'm on fucking YouTube I'm
Because I was watching the stream.
We're going to bubble that to Tokyo.
See, I'm like, but I am here.
I,
but I am here, though.
Oh, I checked the events.
Okay, I'll show you guys.
It's pretty funny.
Where's the...
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
Where is it?
um we're so recap guys i need i want to show you on the on
the left oh here you go all right here you go watch this
okay i thought this was funny wait okay it's like how what
did i play oh luna oh that's cool luna and then what did i
oh and then and then what did i play here oh season what
Luna okay and then what I play here oh season 2 Luna okay
and then what do I play here oh season 3 Luna all right and
then oh we can't see sorry okay and then oh is it blacked
out oh you guys can't see it oh it is what the fuck wait
this doesn't show on stream that's crazy I didn't know that
this doesn't show up on okay anyway oh i even realized that
was a thing yeah it doesn't show you can't show it on stream
apparently anyway it's season two luna season three luna oh
it's funnier with the visuals season four luna and then
season five gambit it was like luna luna luna luna luna
gambit i did not will never take your Take your fucking
bids.
Let's see.
All right, let's see.
Do we go to our teams now?
Announcements.
Bracket is out.
What team am I on?
Oh, I'm on team Gail.
Um.
All right, I'm on team Gail.
Okay.
I go.
Give me a sec.
Let me go adjust my shit.
real quick let me i need to push to talk give me a keybind
okay where's my toggle to mute okay it's a five that's fine
all right toggle mute is five all right okay you guys don't
hear them talking yet because i also oh my god i forgot oh i
forgot to restart my discord because i didn't do Discord.
Sorry, right?
Admin.
Sorry, my thing is like freaking out now.
And then...
All right, here you go.
And then I go back in.
I know I'm such a professional.
Guys, please give, please, to my defense, it's very early.
all right i did it okay now i gotta do the discord thingy
the this the silly discord overlay okay voice uh i'm on i'm
on youtube i don't need to know that all right i'm muted
guys so it's okay i said that as a funny ha-ha to you All
right, let's adjust this real quick.
Oh.
Okay.
Thank you for the opportunity.
What the fuck?
Okay, so, oh, you guys didn't hear it.
Oh, sorry, I felt like I was talking.
Sorry, it seemed like I was talking to, like, the voices in
my head there, because I realized you guys couldn't hear it.
But they're like, you guys want to do a stream together?
And they're like, yeah.
I'm gonna I'm gonna start knocking and the other guy was
like I'm gonna knock you up and then one guy was like oh,
thank you Yeah, that sounds like I'm talking to my inner
demons right now.
It might as well be I might it feels like I'm talking to my
fucking inner demons
The voice is in my head All right, why do I get to see the
other team's shit?
too all right let me hydrate wait spark chief do you know
the animation cancel tech what with the old yeah yeah that's
the one yeah yeah all right oh yeah i'm not talking because
i am socially awkward i heard it was a bug but i don't know
if it is yeah it's intended future trust me okay that's a
dead fool thank you for the five gifted ships thank you
thank you you here dead foes and rap gonna be in rivals next
month they're loud okay sound guys it's time to do your
thing i'm not gonna just adjust the discord damn just gonna
adjust them individually just because um i don't want to up
these set i mean actually no i could never mind i can
technically adjust them here because um guys i just realized
so in scotland here they're doing like a thing where the
like there's a bunch of cars that drive by and beep their
horn for like some awareness thing so if you guys hear car
horns i apologize no worries no worries like they're so
annoying bro i don't care what the reason for oh yeah uh
hello i'm back i was pissing all right let's adjust this
we're just waiting for the sound team to adjust i'm not
talking because i'm scared um we have any idea what big
groups um so relatable what other tank is really good bro uh
team captain wolverine can come down okay team captain i've
brought down team captain they can go stratic guys i'm
fixing sound is there a mainstream yeah it's on twitch
you'll you'll know which is the mainstream when you see like
a lot of your accounts okay you want to play that's in the
map though yeah yeah
Scottish.
That's your Wolverine player.
Spark Spark as well.
Okay.
Spark or Gale?
Sound guy.
Okay.
Gale can come down.
Gale.
All right.
I brought Gale down a little too.
Yeah.
I am the only stream on YouTube.
I was just thinking of her point against Lucky's Yo team.
We just ban supports from them so zypy can't play the game
oh sure actually yes that's true yes i basically rank one
two three four and five yeah i am the mainstream on youtube
i am the only stream on youtube for this tournament i have
cornered the market in pro play right now they are just
banning supports anyways so yeah the market is all mine i
didn't saturate it on twitch We take those.
That's right.
I have the monopoly right now.
I have not spoken a word yet to my team.
I think the first word I'll speak in this team would be
like, what do I play?
I'd just be like, hey guys, what do I play?
That would be the only time I've, that would be the first
time i've spoken oh i'm so awkward i hate it i am so bad at
the speaking and socializing shit who would have thought
being stuck in the room with on your computer for like five
plus hours a day stunts your socialization who would have
thought that that was a thing
Farming anti-social points.
How's your day?
It's like asking someone, how's the weather?
It's like, I don't know.
I feel weird saying shit like that.
I'd be like, hey, how's the weather up there?
It's okay.
See, they're all talking to their stream, though.
They are all mute.
It's not me.
It's not just me, at least.
Everyone else is also just...
Just talking to their chats, guys.
It's okay.
Where even is like, this is what the teams are like.
I want to know what the full team is like.
But all I see is the goddamn schedule.
Oh, the full roster reveal graphics being aimed to be
released at 9CET.
What's 9CET, guys?
Where are my converters in chat?
What's 9CET 2?
PST
CET I think it's a European time Is that central?
Oh no Is CET central?
There's no way It's CET They said non-CET There's no way
They're releasing the fucking Can you accept me?
Never mind That's That post was made on December 11th Don't
accept it.
Don't accept it.
I was trying to.
It was going to be an error.
It said something went wrong.
Please try it.
Never mind.
I was reading the wrong post.
Oh, I found the team folder, team graphic.
I just wanted to see it.
I was just waiting for host.
Let's see.
Ruggsy Choo hasn't here yet.
What the fuck?
Wait, is everybody in the room?
Let me try to go directly to your stream.
Wait, everyone's in the fucking room.
except for me you think i think you're banned sorry man she
just says waiting for us wait they're just like we're only
missing wait did you join the group thing i don't know if
that affects you oh oh they're talking about the twitch
views oh okay they're they're talking about unless you're
talking about the room they're just talking about i don't
know no no they're talking about the twitch the twitch
sharing view thing guys they're talking about that they're
not talking about me not being in that room I think I think
guys it's okay life is like that does anyone know who's
making the lobbies I'm figuring that out right now see what
they say see there no one knows no one's made a lobby yet no
one's made a lobby yet we're fine
everything is fine
Guys, I don't even know what the new meta is.
The tournament is a day after the new meta comes out.
I think it's literally whoever has the best fucking...
I'm already in a collaboration.
It's like DPS or like, I don't know, like a train behind
you?
What was that?
I mean, it's a thing in Scotland that there's a bunch of
like trucks driving by and they're all spamming their car
horns in every street to like raise awareness.
all my scottish dragoons out there is that true well i
actually don't know it's just a thing they're doing a pissed
job at it if you don't know yeah like oh my god yeah guys
they're all like going about with like christmas lights on
the truck and then just like spam the car horn and every
single street that they go by that sounds fun yeah it's so
fun for everyone it says our match starts at 2 20 p.m bst so
an hour and 20 from now what no excuse me yeah so i guess we
have an hour and 20 minutes excuse me why does it start i
could have slept i could have had an hour yeah they said i
you guys are on later as explained previously you have two
matches on at a time to get full use of production on stream
those first as soon as the first two games are done then
we'll go straight into it we have to wait uh yeah that or
just watch the games i suppose yeah no i need to play i need
to warm up yeah yeah
bro i might just go play some rogue oh my god all right what
you guys gotta do okay take care i'll be back soon i guess i
warm up yes i could have been sleeping I, um, I could have,
I'm deafened.
I'm fucking playing rank.
I, I know.
Ow!
Bro, everyone deafened.
We're like, yes, we play rank.
Everyone fucking deafened themselves.
Oh my god.
Alright, time to lose Celestia too.
Let's go.
We're, I could boot up some, no, we're not gonna play random
Hades.
You know, I could.
put up some 80s right now grab get some runs in like okay do
we warm up do we do the logical thing and warm up or do some
runs in 80s that's why i'll do one run i'll do run one run
in 80s how about that i'll compromise one run in 80s okay i
remember what the sound settings for 80s i i could Bro,
this, I could have taken a nap.
I actually, I'm on YouTube.
Like, who added me?
Oh, I don't know who are you.
They're like, are you streaming?
And I wrote, I'm on YouTube.
So they actually are like, where are you on Twitch?
I'll be like, I didn't know streaming on...
streaming on twitch mandatory there we go all right i wrote
that i was like whoa was it mandatory i don't i only do that
for like sponsors like it was a rival sponsor all right 80s
2 all right let's adjust this is just the all right here you
go I'm going to close off fucking Rylos and then boot up
Hades real quick.
Our first, okay, for those who are confused why we're on
Hades right now, our first match doesn't start until an hour
shake my head.
We'll do some runs like this.
There we go.
Here.
Screw it.
I'm Hades.
Hades.
Hades thing right now.
I feel like it would be better.
Oh, well.
I can't really stop my stream and move over now.
I was like, oh, well, I can't really stop my stream and
move.
Move over.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
We're doing Hades.
The goddess of the hunt decided that the best use of her
talents...
Alright, wait.
Okay.
I feel weird talking to them, though.
Like, if they wanted everything to be on Twitch, also, it's
not even sponsored.
So that's why I was like, I'm not going to go on YouTube
because it's my main platform.
So I can keep the VOD on this channel.
It's not...
It's not mandatory, but they're like, oh, it'd be better.
Because they want to raise up.
The thing is, the thing they want to do for it is because
it's so they can add my view count into, like, the whole
Marvel Rivals category on Twitch.
I mean, it is smarter to do on Twitch just because, just
because I would get the, what is it called?
I would get the, the sub, if you subscribe, you get the Jeff
badge.
wise for me me on twitch as well so i could like uh utilize
the sub equals twitch chep twitch badge or whatever um and
um why not dual stream i just don't like separating the
audience i like everyone to being in the same area and i
just don't like having two chats on the stream because it's
very way too cluttered yeah i could just far i i technically
i could have farmed the drops but the reason why they want
me on twitch is because um it's all about stats and numbers
so like the more people streaming on Twitch or streaming on
Twitch, the more they can add into their calculations for
their numbers, like to give to rivals, be like, look, this
tournament got X amount of people watching it, so they could
include my numbers into the statistic as well, and also
boost up the rivals category.
It's why Marvel Rivals always ask me to stream on Twitch
whenever I'm doing sponsors, because they want the category
to have my numbers in there, so they can have the category
so that's like the whole reason why usually but when people
do that oh yeah they're gonna stream and move over now yeah
that's why I was like sorry I can't stop it but if we split
the chat we can fight each other guys you guys are already
fighting each other in the Dragoon lands trying to figure
out who is the who is the peak Dragoon for him you guys
don't a fight more that's like eight more categories because
it's not just twitch versus youtube chat it's uh like long
goons twitch normal dragon twitch chonky goon twitch iggoons
twitch versus like there's infighting and then there's like
and then there's like the platform fighting as well Oh,
hello.
Hi, Athena.
Oh, Artemis?
Sorry, you both named both starts with A.
Upmost importance right now.
Nice try, Sister Malinui, but I won't break that easily.
Not here.
If I don't talk to them, will it keep their dialogue?
Like, if I don't talk to them, do the next run?
Will it keep their dialogue or am I fucked?
the plans and movements of the nightmare bringing which and
the combat right shall end when racing game wins the vote
patria said they even super chat thank you thank you
i just need to know it'll be stored okay so i don't have to
talk to them right the dialogue will be stored right guys i
just need to know if i if i want to keep the dialogue if i
so we can yeah
because then I don't so then you guys can still have the
start this oh yeah the dialogue will be stored okay then
we'll just keep going we won't talk to them so that we can
oh I'll grab my frog too my frog is here all right let's go
do a full run I think I can do a full run I have time I got
time to literally do a full run okay let's go let's just go
and kill my grandpa real quick wait do I have
okay let's see sorry i got like pings and stuff so i gotta
check it up oh audio guy also audio guy you can talk in the
youtube chat because like tabbing in and out i sometimes i
don't see the notifications all right captain can come down
a little bit gal is still loud okay gal gal and captain i'll
push him down a little and then gal All right, here you go.
All right.
The rain's return.
Hello.
I shouldn't snouch.
I should get up.
Things like an awful big coincidence.
But then we got these things.
They happen all the time.
Oh, I forgot.
Yeah, but like I want to do a fast run.
And I don't want to...
I'd rather do a run like a regular new run.
I'd rather do a regular new run during the...
and Flick Scorch.
I don't know.
One or three.
A new regular new run on an actual Hades stream.
This is just me doing, like, a regular run.
One or three, guys.
No, because I need to get this done quick, guys.
As I ask.
Okay, I'm not going to ask you guys about which one to do,
because I actually have to do this quick.
Alright.
I realize I actually have to do this really quick, so...
I gotta exercise my free will here, which is gonna be hard.
I'm not used to that.
Having free will is a new concept to me.
I've relied on chat so much on my build, so I'm like, what
is free will?
Uh, we'll grab this.
Alright.
BAM!
Okay.
Pick some grass up real quick.
It burned.
All right.
It's okay, my frog is here, too.
He's just a little guy.
Rare Toki independent thought.
She's actually...
Oh, my.
She's gonna have independent thought, guys.
It's wild.
Oh, my God.
It's a new day.
Toki is finally gaining independence.
USA.
Alright, there you go.
Oh, nice.
It's okay.
Five damage is okay.
I'll get it back anyway.
I can't believe it.
Toki's making her own choices.
Oh, why are you always here?
In its veins.
But Kronos turned it into little coins.
All over the damn place now.
Lord Keron's going to take care of it soon.
She grew, yeah, she hit so dangerous.
To keep thinking for herself, that sounds so dangerous.
Never leave a dokey unattended.
Don't worry.
Any gold I get from you, Karon, gets from me.
I'll give.
Here's my limit?
I mean, sure.
I mean, gold is...
Oh, hey!
Spatter time.
I opened the door first
sorry I guess it's her spotter time no spotter time no I
opened it you're like yeah you opened it for her Doki like
like what the fuck that's actually bullshit i can't believe
it also why the fuck did the frog not take that like i
thought your whole job was that you take it for me enough
it's just all fire my entire build is just fire at this
point um oh my special also oh wait um it's just inflicted
scorch i guess that's hot that's like it's just it's oops
all fire Oh, I miss.
Yes, I just need something.
Okay, if I want to get the fire shit, the one thing I'm
missing right now is the...
Um...
Is the... What was it?
Okay.
Attack simply scorch.
Oh, let's just do more scorch.
Oh.
Oh, hey, I can fish.
Fishing time.
Within those waters, teams the strangest life.
Oh.
Yeah!
I got a bite.
I got a moper.
The fuck is a moper?
All right, I have enough money for this, though.
Let's gotta make sure I'm not missing any notifications or
anything.
All right, you guys can tell me if it's our team's turn to
fight, right?
You guys would tell me that.
All right, hammer time.
Oh, that's a lot of good shit, too.
Your specials are 25% faster.
Your special gains a power shot.
That DL is 50.
Oh, wait, I should get one, right?
Independent thought.
I don't need to ask you guys.
It mobs.
Yeah.
It's okay.
Independent thought Doki is taking control of the wheel now.
This is no longer a chat build.
This is a Doki build.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, that's bad.
It's just 8 damage.
Oh my god, it's no longer I'm just taking shit Frog, your
whole job is to take shit For me
Alright More attack, okay wait, maybe scorch No, attack
Yeah, more attack More damage equals more power More damage
equals they die fast I mean, yeah, we'll grab the prophecy
now.
We'll grab this too.
All in!
All right.
Watch this.
Boom!
They're just chilling.
They're just hanging out with their buddies.
Goodness.
That's right.
Oh shit, that's not right!
I got an overconfident in there.
Alright, more ash.
Thunder!
Yeah, this is my burn everything build.
I think it's working, guys.
Burning is one of the worst deaths of possible.
So I think it's working.
If they all just keep burning, they'll die eventually.
Right?
nice she is so smart guys thank you i know i was thinking
for myself yay arson what's the saying thank you for uh
welcome to tomato farm welcome welcome your special inflicts
blitz that's my right click after you take damage when you
use a random surrounding foe is struck by i'm always using
magic I do not have enough money.
It's okay.
I'm going to start.
This is a weird magic build that I'm doing.
I'm very surprised that independent thought Doki has leaned
towards magic.
Just keeping tabs on everyone, I guess.
All right.
I don't know how to feel about that.
I don't know how to feel that independent thought Doki is
using magic right now.
I'll do faster.
And we're off.
If Lepreidokie becomes a nerd.
Who are you?
Yeah, I brought my frog to the foot.
I never trust appearances entirely headmistress.
And no, neither do you.
This must be an exciting night for Freenos.
We are not here to entertain your woodland friends,
Malinois.
It truly is a Christmas miracle
Go ahead See me Oh my god, I thought you were supposed to
take damage for me What the fuck
Yeah All right, it's fine.
What the fuck I've not I've never seen this attack before
before.
Oh my god, I've missed everyone.
There you go.
Oh shit.
I was not expecting that.
Oh, not you.
Oh, there you are.
Oh my god.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, it's okay.
My frog.
What?
Okay.
You're just gonna.
You're Just gonna stand there?
Oh, that's cool.
Why don't I...
Alright.
They told me this was an auto attack, but I guess they were
wrong.
I literally...
I literally did that because I assumed that it was an auto
attack.
But I guess I was wrong.
I guess people are liars.
Who would have thought...
Okay, this should be how he dies.
Oh, I have to stand behind.
I was told it was an auto attack.
I cannot manage your wounds and neither show your enemies.
All right, nice.
Chat always.
One speaks lies, the other tells truth.
You gotta check who's the one guy.
Your job is to figure out who's the one guy.
Who is the one guy?
Alright.
Oh wait, what's this?
Money.
Alright.
We'll grab the stone now.
Uh, gain plus two now?
Mystery seeds.
Ensure that- okay, yeah, I want to ensure that- Oh, nice!
This was very important to show.
nice the air's thick all right down I'll go
all right don't worry it's fine the tiny men are dead can't
hurt me no more oh my god I thought the fucking I thought my
frog was the enemy what how I thought the I bought my frog
because it's like water enemies guys they're all water so I
thought he was also water
but I don't know if right click is like strong enough I feel
like my attack is like the best one there you go for five
see look at that we're so efficient right now oh wait is
this oh no that's not sealed do i have enough 120 i can buy
one thing maybe something's one 100 oh yeah see i knew it oh
wait all right nice uh we'll grab the moon i do not care to
see the glimmer of the golden coins that carron takes from
you why the fuck oh okay because it's carron which likewise
i can stand what if i just knock on him be like and then you
can just come up so i don't have to pay raises the last all
right we'll do fires a beam i feel like we could do this
night bloom i do enough damage for this pasadal demeter guys
wait free will free will uh pasadem for gamba i forgot
today's a oh okay i should not curse you free will free will
has betrayed me yet again This is why you should never think
for yourself, guys.
Thinking for yourself is a mistake.
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm losing track.
Which one's mine and which one's not mine?
Summon!
Oh my god, I don't know.
Is he... Is he... Is that the enemy?
me or my i cast out okay there you go
all right but silent
if it was so impossible how did it happen i have a
announcement thing please don't rogue being swapped up for a
tp plate at contest point in overtime is allowed oh okay
sorry i had to know there was a fucking at.
Knock foes.
When you sprint, your special hits a...
Like, a moose, press, and hood.
Or...
I mean, I've been using magic a lot.
Oh, yay!
I got two!
Two for one special!
That's crazy.
I'm actually going full on with magic.
Like, accidentally, too.
It's...
There you go.
Yeah.
You guys just get revived.
All right.
Let's see.
If the foe is near after your dash, you can do a blast, your
attacks and special do more damage to armor.
At the start of each encounter.
Is this like each room?
Okay, I'm not...
I'm so free will, but I want to know, is that like...
Oh, but I don't take damage that easily.
But the thing is, guys, I don't take damage like instantly.
I take damage over time because I start panicking.
Yeah, I think I'm going to do armor.
If it was near after you dash, you can cause a blast at you.
I feel like...
Fuck armor.
Oh, I'll just...
Let's unlock this just in case.
Yeah, see?
Look at that.
So efficient.
Whoa!
It's so very efficient.
Okay.
Not wrong, it's so very efficient, guys.
Oh, hey, narcissist.
Let's go talk to my boy narcissist.
So I was like, no way.
Instead I go, wait.
Into the post?
suitors hello i can tell you're having trouble moving on
maybe you ought to spend a little time down in the fields
clear your head put the pieces of your heart back together
and all that my team loses because i play hades it's not
because i played hades
i will say it's not because i played hades there is one who
repeats whatever i said to her warming up and not me doing
the 80s.
She really.
Only ever talked about herself.
I had to cut her off.
How dare she only talk about herself when you have
narcissists right in front of you.
So you do know Echo, the mountain nymph.
She's languishing in the fields even now.
Apparently because of you.
I can hardly get through to her.
Yeah, I'm warming up my APM, guys.
Oh, that's too bad.
tell her narcissists really wants what's best for her unless
that's me don't tell her that part though all right let's
see receive oh wait one random palm i feel like the palm
right oh but more magic uh random boom boom but then i could
have more magic though i'm gonna get more magic i'm doing a
magic build anyway i might as well
i'm already doing more i'm already like doing a magic build
so i should just fucking commit to this boom the hunt is on
oh hey sister her cousin i like how you came over here when
the fight is about to end and then take all the credit being
like look at how much stuff i did for you i'm like
I feel like the casting thing is not doing that much as much
as I thought it would oh my god I'm taking a lot of damage
right now where is she she's not gonna say hi hello have I
gifted her yet it's been a pleasure to have worked more
closely with you sister yeah are the miss this is hardly
worth the gift of impeccable precision though I wanted you
to have it traditions now are we well sure then i accept
your offering sister melena we and i've been offering for
you in kind oh so fine welcome to tomato farm welcome
welcome yay i got an adler she ripped it off of a deer
yippee about the fates that chronos somehow got to them
doesn't want to take any chances anymore did the fates
prophesize their own captivity yeah if they knew they were
going to get kidnapped why don't they just knock How can you
be so casual about this?
If the fates themselves couldn't stop Kronos, we won't have
an easy time.
This is the new Lunar Skin.
It's the new game mode.
In the 5.5 update, they added a new game mode.
It's now a roguelike.
All right.
Clothes in your cast may take critical damage.
A piercing arrow fires towards any clothes damaged by your
cast.
Oh, it's 50.
Wait, after you hit with your attack or special?
Wait, every attack or special?
Please support fire.
I think like every attack or special is pretty OP.
Okay.
I don't think we need to sacrifice anything.
Oh, hey, let's grab some money too.
We're a little bit broke.
Might as well.
Yeah, like, that's a lot of arrows.
Yeah.
Proof implant money.
Thank you, Tonator, for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Oh, hey.
Fishing time.
Let's fish.
What did I get?
What?
How did it escape?
I did it instantly.
Alright, your splash effects also inflict...
Oh, Froth.
I have no idea what that means.
all right let's go okay we are i don't even i think my build
sucks i think independent thought might be a mistake
wait kronos is sponsoring you i knew there was a reason to
hate you you know those people that are like i've hated this
person for so long but didn't really have when people
finally found a reason to cancel them they're like finally
my hate is being rewarded that's me right now
my hate has been rewarded i knew there was something wrong
with you i'm real i'm one of those finally i'm validated i
know Oh my god, okay, that's just a little off.
Whoa, fuck, okay, this is, oh my god, I'm getting hit by
everything.
I'm sorry, death defiance!
Oh, guys, independent fought is actually a mistake right
now.
I'm getting hit by everything.
Okay, there you go.
I don't know how I'm doing it.
Come on.
Open up.
Oh my god.
I...
Look, I'm trying to also...
Guys, okay.
To be fair, I'm also trying my best to make this a fast run.
And by fast run, I guess I've been dying as fast as I can.
Like...
I just didn't realize that, man, I'm trying to die.
That was an accident.
That was not intentional.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god.
Okay, death defiance.
I lost both death defiance.
This is the most...
Okay, I might have messed up in...
I definitely messed up in the nerd build.
Alright.
Alright, it's fine.
Okay, nerd build might not be it, guys.
Where is the other woman?
Oh, dude.
Are you fucking...
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Nerd build might not be the smartest thing I've done today.
I've literally lost two death defi- I've not ever lost two
death defiances before.
I forgot about my...
summons to I forgot that was a thing that existed okay I'm
sure any goods offered by Sharon cause I'm broke right now I
have five encounters to the fields yeah I forgot to use my
summons oh you can mine those rocks walk too late future
Doki will do it right surely she'll do it I trust future
Doki's plan.
Where am I supposed to go?
I think the issue with the scourge is that it definitely
does not fucking...
It does not stop people.
That's a little concerning.
Yeah, I thought it would stop, but it doesn't stop people.
I'm pretty sure I messed up that fucking build.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure this is not how the build is supposed
to go
All right Got wolf guy here.
He's going.
He's trying to find people.
He's sniffing them out.
Where are they boy?
Okay, he does not know where people are I was wrong.
He is very confused Hey, there's a plant though
Yeah I don't know you're doing damage Yeah, but it's not
really doing damage.
Oh, shit.
I forgot about the thing about magic build is that you're
very weak.
You're...
You have the damage, but you're very, very weak.
As per normal magic builds.
Alright, let's see.
What does it say?
Use Q for the binding or hold.
Oh, you're raised servants.
Okay, let's go.
that i should be able to get out i think yeah that's echo
right no it's uh it's just more bosses oh my god queen namia
returns oh my god okay i wish my frog does something oh
that's good i guess good i got i got i'm gonna do i got one
of your daughters that's right she fight for me now girl
Okay, nice.
It's okay, I can still burn.
That's right!
She fought for me now!
She hates it here!
She hates you!
Okay.
Oh, I could summon another one!
Oh, it's the same one.
It's the same one.
There you go.
So I'm this.
Yeah, do something, frog.
Yeah, plus 40.
I like how it does it automatically now.
Your strikes?
Oh, okay.
But you prom 50.
Hold cast to aim where the bottom circle appears.
Oh, wait, I like that.
That's my favorite one.
Oh, I'm going to do rushing.
I'm going to do this so I can chuck it somewhere.
Oh, and I get Echo, too.
Yeah!
All right, Echo, I talked to Narcissus.
I mean, I think he's sorry.
I think he's sorry.
Yeah, it's just you talk too much about yourself.
Like, think about others, Echo.
That he remembers you, and he didn't mean to hurt you.
Yeah, he just loves himself.
I think he just, are not enough for him.
Sorry to say.
Yeah, you got it, girl.
You got it.
There's just not enough space in his heart.
For more than him.
All spent.
With ones that restore.
Oh.
Double the level of.
Palms.
I feel like Palms are always the best one.
Dude.
I don't need death defiance.
Fuck it.
I don't need it.
This is the run.
I- more damage!
Uh...
Oh wait, lightning.
Hammer.
The famous last words.
Who needs death defies when I can just live?
Okay.
I still can't believe where our matches don't start.
One hour!
I still can't believe I had to wait.
Not an hour and a half.
I think that's the worst part.
The end half part.
I didn't expect the end half.
There you go.
Alright, I could summon another one.
Yeah, end half.
It's not just an hour.
It's the end half part.
Alright.
Let's clear it up.
Um, prop damage.
Let's do 100%.
Wait.
Mmm.
Oh yeah, 100%.
That was a tree anywhere?
Trees?
Oh here.
Let's grab the hammer.
This corruption.
Alright, there you go.
Oh shit, I didn't even see that guy.
There you go.
That's right.
I got the Medusa now.
Okay, it's fine.
Gotta regen them.
Oh my god, these guys weren't even part of the fight.
I just went in there and be like, you go and... You go die
too, I guess.
Nice.
Hammer time!
Uh, your attacks were 50%.
Oh, your attacks hit two times, but use Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Uh...
I've been using...
Okay.
What to use?
I feel like 50% faster is better, because I do have the
arrows.
Oh, I do use Enchana into your special.
What's my special?
I don't use special enough.
I'm gonna get faster.
Yeah, so I can put more arrows in.
into.
Where are the fucking trees?
Where are the trees?
I'm missing one more.
What the fuck is the last one?
Oh my god.
How am I supposed to complete this run before my game?
Oh.
This is not related.
Oh wait, is this related?
What's the end?
Your race take any damage.
You race her and steal.
Oh, first time they hit?
that oh I guess I'm not grabbing that all right my bad I'm
not grabbing that apparently did I do it no fuck that
particular statue and because I can't find my way out of
here
what the fuck where's the last one oh it's right here I hear
it.
I hear the glowing sound.
Oh my god.
Wait, I don't hear it.
I drifted.
Welcome to tomato fire.
Welcome, welcome.
Wait, I don't.
Oh, wait.
Here it is.
Okay, that was a problem.
Okay, it's right here.
There we go.
Oh, wait.
Raise!
That's right.
Start punching.
There we go.
That's right.
Keep punching.
Oh my god.
don't have any.
I don't have any more magic.
I don't understand.
How do I not have any more magic in my magic build?
It's okay.
I got more.
Uh, chopper hef.
Uh, fuck.
Okay.
Uh, I don't have a lot of money, technically.
So we will go with hef.
I don't have a lot of money.
I don't think broke right now.
Your flow is near.
You can blast whenever you enter a game thing.
Game 10.
Based on 20%.
I don't even have armor.
I'm just going to go with that.
Alright, dog time.
There is a chance I'll die.
There might be there is a possibility where I just fucking
die.
Okay, it's fine.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's okay.
He doesn't know.
What's the use?
Oh, what?
Okay.
Are you fucked?
Oh my god.
Okay, that was an accident.
Oh, my God!
Yeah, stop!
Stop!
Oh!
Okay, I don't know what I'm summoning.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay.
It's okay.
Oh, I am not okay.
that are summoning.
Oh my god, it is not okay.
It is not okay.
Oh my god.
Guys, free will might have been a mistake.
There is a possibility that I might have messed up by trying
to have free will.
Okay.
I'm just gonna be here.
Oh god.
I just gotta...
I gotta be very far away.
He's very slowly coming towards me and I'm scared.
Where is he going?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god.
Okay, wait, wait, wait!
Oh!
It was close!
Oh, that was close.
That was very close.
Alright.
We're fine.
He hit me.
I hit him.
I have...
Be sued.
I have 3 HP.
But we...
We're alive.
We made it.
3 HP and a goddamn dream.
I...
Ha ha ha ha.
I saw the minus 20 and I was like, I don't know.
And we're cutting a little too close right now.
What's this?
We're going to gain 20% or limited 30 HP.
Yeah, no.
All right.
Receive gain.
All right, let's grab this real quick.
Let's grab as much HP as possible.
Kronos awaits.
All right.
Kronos time.
Yeah, no.
I...
My build is not great.
I might have messed up.
I might have messed up on my build.
Definitely could be better.
Okay.
There you go.
Yeah, 100%.
I could have made a better build.
all right let's grab this out here there we go it's okay we
live we have survived we'll grab money too god i hate it i
hate that i i wish it wasn't a it wasn't a red color i it
always confuses me so much when it's red i don't know it
feels like like because like the enemies use is red too so
it's like it's like so confusing because the enemies are
also red so I'm like which one is my attack and which one is
yours I'm gonna grab this yoink
alright I'm full vision I just see red that's all I can see
I'm not encountered Sharon at like I wasn't out chaos at all
today that's crazy oh my god I fucking got killed by the
trap of anything I could die video.
Come on.
Oh god, not the goddamn fucking bad.
Alright, where's the other guy?
Oh wait, they're not even tired of this.
Alright, nice.
Alright, that's fine.
Where is my guy?
Where's my summons?
It's okay, I just summoned him again.
I wish I could summon more than once.
Like, more than one enemy?
If I just build it enough?
Where the fuck is the exit?
Hello?
Oh, it's over here.
I feel like it'd be cool.
I feel like...
I mean, it might be OP, but look at me.
I don't think I'm OP right now.
I...
Not this build.
If I had the right build, maybe.
This does not seem very...
OP right now.
Is that it?
No, there's that guy.
I'm fucking summon this guy.
Beat him up.
Beat up your brother.
That's right.
Oh my god.
You can't even hit your brother.
Just a few chambers left.
Alright.
Asylum.
Yeah, I'm not very healthy.
I think I just messed up on the...
I definitely messed up somehow.
I definitely messed up it somehow I don't know how
God damn God
just end up tanking everything God you're so tanky Okay
there you are I should be I armor broke him so it should be
fine All right, there you go.
How are you still?
Oh, my God.
You still have HP.
Jesus Christ.
Why much prefer silver?
Although it also took the wisdom of my noble brother Zeus,
who formed the pan.
Oh, no.
Your brother's stupid now.
Hmm.
Oh, it's a duo.
It's a duo.
Oh, yeah, because he was talking.
Fucking mad shit.
Yeah, he's like, bro, my brother is fucking dumb as fuck.
And then he's like, the fuck you said to me, bro.
Yay!
You're letting deals more damage.
Oh, yeah, let's go.
All right.
I wonder if I fucking get the froth thing correctly.
All right, auto this.
Nice.
Two Hades, two Hades facts.
Melanoi shares a voice actor with Luna Snow and Serber is
voiced by Devs Dogs.
Oh, that's cute.
I like that Yeah, thank you for the super chat Thank you,
thank you That's really cute Yeah I don't understand, it
said like Literally, it was like Oh, oh, dude You get to
have more armor and shit Like, I do not feel like I have
More armor break It feels very normal armor break Are you
fucking kidding me?
What hit me?
You?
Oh my god.
I don't.
What the fuck is going on?
Oh, it's you.
Oh my god.
Oh, thank god.
The frog tainted for me.
Oh.
Okay.
That's fine.
There we go.
Yeah, I know this This is not looking too well.
This is not looking too well for me right now.
It's fine.
All right, we got the summons.
The tanky summons.
All right.
21 HP.
At least let me get the Kronos.
That's all I want.
Okay.
I have a summon still.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
I have another.
Nice.
Okay, where is replenish?
Okay, yeah, we need that.
The death defiance.
All right, okay, guys, guys.
It's okay.
We have another death defiance now.
Everything's okay.
We have another death defiance.
Not all hope is lost.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I wish like, I wish it's a different color.
Like when you're minions, like you have a minion.
It's a different color because I'm like, it's a friend or
bro.
But all you see is a tiny ass heart.
The heart is so tiny.
I can't tell.
I have a thousand dollars though.
Yeah.
6 HP and a dream.
Okay.
Five.
A thousand.
Okay.
Hmm.
Why is there no HP?
It feels good to be working together with that one again.
You tell him I said.
Yeah, I could have just bought that.
Okay, while you have, you deal more at least eight, eight,
eight.
or eight i got five what i got i got five your first in each
oh that would have been nice not at end game that would have
been very nice yeah i'm buying armor and then i have enough
just enough for poseidon should i get uh wait no no free
will free will i will get i will get poseidon
are you serious Okay.
We'll just...
A bit too late.
I mean, I have so much magic.
Maybe that's good.
For 10 seconds.
10 seconds against...
You know what?
10 seconds against Grandpa might be enough.
Might be enough.
There's surrounding foes with powerful flash as they start
to strike, but you prime 30.
Yeah, we're at the, we're apparently the third match.
Don't, don't worry, we have time.
Um, yeah, but then like, this is over top.
You know what, this, we'll do that.
Okay, we have, we have a bit more armor now.
I think we're gonna die.
Unless I locked in.
You were never meant to be involved in this granddaughter.
You must have been a mere babe when first I arrived here.
Alas, too late to meet.
Yet even now, you are too young to understand.
I would have been imprisoned with the rest.
Yeah, you would have kept the baby in the jail.
In the baby jail.
young to understand the disappointment and dejection that
only family can provide but the more of us you meet the more
of us you know the sooner you shall learn i hear you
oh my god he's starting to suck he starts it off with a suck
i'm scared oh okay got your minions you twist my servant's
will that's right oh
Guys, you guys might not be it.
I just tanked it all.
Guys, guys, I don't think I'm locking it in.
For some reason, it does not feel like I'm locked in.
Oh, shit.
Okay, it's okay.
I've got him.
I gotta get rid of these, though.
Oh, shit.
It's okay.
I just got rid of these.
Okay.
Wait, they blocked it!
I still have one more death defiance!
Oh, God.
Oh, God, not these guys.
okay I'm gonna try and grab these guys okay oh yeah I got
the armored I got the armored bros oh my god that's my guy
that's what I'm saying I sometimes I don't know okay I gotta
get the clock minion okay one more depth defiance do I I
still have my two for the normal death defiance.
I can't tell.
Oh, God.
Oh, that was close.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Oh, I'm still five.
Wait, I got the clock.
No, that's not the clock.
I'm not.
I thought I got the clock guys I had I had hope what okay
wait I got the clock now I got the oh it's okay it's okay I
got the clock again oh shit
it's okay he'll live right yeah he does bro
oh we did it oh we did the magic build one tap would never
again never Doki will never again exercise free will.
It was a mistake.
Independent thought was a mistake.
Dude, you're going to crush it in the tournament now.
Yeah, yeah, guys.
I think I'm so warmed up.
I'm so fucking warmed up.
Let's go, free will.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
26 miss.
That's like the worst one yet.
Alright, let's grab this.
I have what I need for now.
The Hades 2, the next Hades 2 stream people are going to be
confused.
They're like, I feel like we missed one giant chunk of
dialogue.
Alright, let's go in.
To the abyss of the subconscious, I descend.
No!
Because they want to fucking watch every game i don't know
why
there's like there's too many teams to spectate every game i
literally if like it goes overtime i'm checking out i
literally told them i have to leave by four
come on where is she where is she don't get me hanging like
this yeah i said like i legitimately cannot commit and they
told me that it's fine you know that they that it won't go
over to have
yeah before pmp sc i told them 4 p.m psc i gotta go find
this guy garos may have gotten hold of it but that's in my
time while in your
I said I do that Alright I'll let them know I said my chat
told me That you guys are gonna go Past 4pm PSD But I told
The person I told them that I will only join if it doesn't
go Past that time
You did Where what happened How do you know it's the correct
location well for one thing it appears they have to get in a
sub because i cannot i legitimately can't i told them i have
other like priorities like i have other obligations
good and do not enter until everything's prepared but let's
go back a moment why do you trust us so much yeah and enter
but let's go back a moment oh that's that's spear someone
said in chat said like the last game is at 4 30 but i have
to leave at four
just ask father really nicely he's our dad just be like your
grandpa's gonna break up my my my suit my future sister told
me about this in a dream i don't i know that sounds crazy
but it's true i don't need its physical form only its
essence sent across our astral psychic gateway details
details sister i like unreasonable challenges and throws me
anyway so use some sort of oracle gathering up ancient
artifacts no you don't yeah but thank you the super chat
thank you thank you we'll change that future and i'm no
oracle i'm what you call a witch whoa burner brother claim
father spear and i have more to do myself i'll see you again
all right goodbye brother return to shadow now all right i
guess i should warm up with rivals now with my what still an
hour left i don't fucking know
well like some people i know like they have um they have
like subs or some shit for it because i told them i can't
commit a full day i legitimately told them that i was like
will it end before four and they're like yes and i was like
okay i can join like i need a note before i say anything
will it end before four okay legit like okay no this is okay
is this all right i'm gonna hey uh i'll i'll ask in general
um um where is it
Where the fuck did they ping me?
Question.
Okay.
They pinged me somewhere.
And I don't even remember where it was when they pinged me.
Okay.
Mentions.
Did they, like, delete the messages?
Like, where the fuck did they ping me earlier?
Mentions dokey bird.
Alright, where is this tracking?
Okay.
It's in the gen.
questions i'm being totally uh oh i looked at the schedule
too and it does say like the match well wait round two three
broadcasted match number five oh it's broadcasted match um
is this game is it is day one ending before wait is this two
days or one day like the schedule is so looks so broadcasted
match number three okay is that day two why is it red and
blue okay i assume okay that is day two round eight is day
two okay um day one ending before 4 p.m pst rmb uh the
schedule says there's some mat there's some matches going to
okay what's 6 30 going to um what time is this no it's at
three uh it starts at five start time uh wait i think the
lower oh no 6 30 p.m est that's That's 3.30.
That's 3.30.
I'm looking at this picture.
I assume.
God, this schedule looks so fucking confusing to me.
I'm like looking at this.
I'm like, I'm so confused.
All right.
We're going to look at this together.
We're figuring this out together, chat.
This is a group effort now.
I'll fucking decipher this.
Okay, so.
6.30 p.m.
EST.
That's 3.30 p.m.
That we should make it, right?
We should make it.
If it's 6.6.30.
Oh, it's best.
Oh, my gosh.
It's best to see.
Yeah.
So it's 3.30.
So.
I should make it.
I mean, at best I'll make it by 430.
I'll be like, my hard stop is 430.
I'll say that.
I'll be like, uh, um, I'll be like, uh, is anyone ending
before 430 p.m.
That's it.
It says, so match is going.
There's, I need to be sure.
Because,
um, because I have to leave exactly at 4 30.
oh oh is it just uh did you get this you have me yeah yeah
nice that was awkward i'd leave exactly because my fine key
is at three at five four i need to make sure because i'd
leave exactly at 4 30 for a contract obligation at an event
before four so I want to be sure that scared me I was like
whoa
um to end before four before four went to decide whether or
not I can whether or not I can I can participate so I want
to be sure um
pmpst all right there you go
all right all right this the schedule confuses me i think
they're almost done so i'm going to put rivals up now don't
worry i am equally as confused guys do not worry 14 okay 15
there you go i reset my sound thing that scared the shit out
of me because i I forgot my picking on I forgot my bind key
for this uh Marvel and actually type five because no one
like I rarely ever use the the number five for some fucking
reason and that's why it's on my bind key
all right I'm putting Rivals up Necro's laws can you just
pretend that Oshi bird won the tournament call it the day
I'm and I mean I'm one I want them around I want to run
So, Oma, thank you for the super chat.
I mean, if we don't win a game, at least we won.
At least we won a round with a magic build.
Guys, at least we won in a magic build.
Okay.
Let's see.
Um...
okay they said they'll find me a sub if it goes longer so i
can peace out like like i have to i literally the maid cafe
stuff has been in works for so long i said if it doesn't go
beyond that oh they're in lobby okay whoops um where are
they where the fuck they said they're in lobby i don't to
see it oh there you go uh okay invite me to lobby oh right
yeah but bp is uh let's go invite me to lobby i mean yes i
mean if they play if they proc gambit do you want to plan
like sue or what israelian play all right here we go she
plays gambit i'm not sure I think they have a they can they
can get it Loki if they're ready to ban one yeah we can just
ban Loki I feel like no yeah that's fine I know everyone
Loki bands good coaches here and then you you can play a
Luna or suit right yeah I can play out here I think Raylene
plays a lot of Adam I don't know if they'll play Adam but I
want to pee really bad that is something I do know yeah I
have no impact on strategy these guys are the pro players so
i know they're gonna insta buy so these guys are the pro
players i'll let them strategize i'm just here to vibe on
our team that's not meant to be wait slushy who's the
imposter needs to move yeah i mean i don't mind spectating
and having a five before it sounds
better wait duop is on 200 ms yeah he's oce we're just
getting five before us on ironically team captain knows how
it's like to plant the whole thing no i do that shit was
cancer bro are 200 ping this guy's playing in the past
literally like he'll be like shooting and it'll three like
four seconds after it's two seconds of the way guys
throughout london all of the all those guys are like so
happy is red now like oh my god the game feels amazing 200
is not a fun time yeah because they were just screaming like
all weekend against an a teams at like 200 all of them it
was horrible that is crazy from asia asia asia as soon as
you hit celestial 2 there was no one playing like at all
yeah that's what they were yep they just that's their
highest rank that's insane everyone just goes any after our
ears i'm not gonna say any that's that's okay you live like
next door to me or something you got like the same thing
yeah i'm actually your neighbor next door i knew it i knew
it all makes sense yeah that's why you never got noise
complaints because i'm also awake at that time oh i see
uh what's what are the server they're they're they're in the
he's in the he's in the past i'm in the future the most
region yeah yeah actually that's why we never got noise
complaints anymore guys like i don't know i care either way
yeah i don't think anything is gonna work for deep unless
you make it to see
you you can play i mean you see the pink i'm saying is i'm
liking the green i'm seeing on our team maybe we keep it
this way i don't like playing at you i mean i'll do it yeah
i don't like high ping on this game at all it sucks the game
stops working i swear literally no this is not the That guy
with a 250!
I swear it's worse!
Oh, that's good.
This is not the majority anymore.
For better.
Like 200 ping is slightly playable, 250.
That's like, the game won't even function, I swear.
Yeah, the 200 ping ain't on my team, so it's fine.
Holy shit.
Listen, if he my goals, just everyone shoot it.
He won't be able to react, I swear.
This is the majority.
We should keep this.
Like, sucks to be that guy, but, like, you know what you
were getting.
Like, it's the majority.
Okay, we have advantage.
Nice.
Yes, yes.
So what's your cope if we lose?
Then, what?
Yeah.
We just say they have the rank 1, 2, 3, 4, and 5 guys.
That's true.
Tournaments like these people always get so salty about
ping.
I hope I have nobody gets salty.
I like not tournament like these it's all tournaments.
Every tournament with a prize pool people will get salty.
Yeah they have one.
Yeah guys this team has ranked one, two, three, four and
five.
Which one is it?
It's one guy.
It's literally one guy.
i wish i wish too i always get like plus 30 ping on every
yeah yeah why don't we go to a region though because there's
not enough players there won't be enough players for a
tournament that's the thing for me they need it's better
really it's wait how is dallas better for you there's not
enough days in general i don't understand way it was for me
again but i guess it's playable oh i mean makes sense it's
because it's going like the opposite direction goes with the
Australia right yeah there is a prize pool yeah there is
it's like what is it 25k tournament so I mean I'll check it
it's actually no Virginia Bella oh he joined for fun I don't
really care much about the prize pool first prize is 12k
second but it's divided by six players by the way so I mean
it's still a lot of money I will say it's still a lot of
money first place is 6k second place is 6k of 12 my first
place is 12k second place is 6k um third place is 5k four
places three k and then fifth place is 1k plus 2500 blue
coins or blue code what left east codes really is called and
then six then eight is just 1k i mean if they go go
singapore yeah it's 2k for each okay we're doing all right
god i need a p I think I can no Any thoughts on what we want
to protect I will say
Specifically if you think It's where we guys want I'm first
talking Just play like any DPS so I think you guys protect
DPS Because they don't really specialize If you think about
it The more you hold The more locked in you are But like
don't hold it for too long Because that's not how's it How's
your How's your hella I can I can do a good hella Yeah It's
okay it's cough i can probably kill the spider-man off cd
yeah it's uh it's the p-buff okay also the hawk i think i
think i think meta right now is hella star i can i can use
the bathroom yeah that helps us with that it gives me it
gives me the uh advantage i'm assuming man also sound guy if
you're here you just oh yeah right just type in the youtube
oh what i already adjusted you said loki second i'll type in
the youtube chat for adjustments because i Actually, yeah, I
can protect Hella here.
Actually, what I'm thinking, we can just Hell No More,
Briggzy.
Yeah, you want to do that?
Yeah, I got it.
You can type it in the YouTube chat.
Also, Sound Guide, my Discord thing is 9.6, minus 9.6, type
that down for me.
Minus 9.6, because I will turn this down by me and remember
that for the Maid Cafe.
Minus 9.6.
Or you guys can remember it for me, too.
Oh, my God, I could pee right here.
do it okay captain america okay all right we're gonna go
full dive probably with spider-man maybe yeah i'm gonna use
the bathroom real quick i'll be right back okay yeah all
right
i actually think versus this we need to proc gambit okay
okay they've been loki wow what do you think i could be an
invis unless But did you say you wanted to play Gambit's
armor?
I mean, I can.
I think we should.
Okay, what do you think?
What do you want to ban?
I can just ban their Spider-Man.
Yeah, sure, sure.
Okay.
Yeah.
So...
Flark that guy.
They're going to play like hard dive, right?
With like cap.
Yeah.
Yeah, probably.
It's a Gambit protector.
Or nah.
Yeah, probably.
Yeah.
okay i mean they're not gonna ban gambit though that's the
thing i don't know it's up to you guys yeah i just know what
else i'd pick so i'll just i can do it it could be it could
it could have been no more to be honest true true i don't
think they're thinking that far ahead let's see
they're doing weird stuff yeah i'm not sure what they're
cooking yeah what are they what is cype cooking
wolverine okay that's all right Are they trying to make me
play Wolverine or are they playing it?
I'm confused.
No, lucky seal will play it Okay Made it back just in time
He plays Bucky.
Yeah, I forgot the bad face for this is very long guys It
doesn't matter whether I'm here or not guys.
It doesn't matter I'm just a he he ha ha ha content creator
It's okay Also, I brought everyone down a little bit I have
not played this season yet, so it doesn't matter.
Could be rockets if you wanted to.
I'm the he-haha content creator.
Poor villain.
I'm not judging.
So what do I play here?
Probably Sue, especially if they're going to play the wolf.
Either do wolf, maybe I go Bucky instead of Hella.
What do we think?
We want Hella or Bucky here.
start i have no opinion yeah i think the most broken
character is star in this meta wait yeah actually you're
right you're right you're right you're right i'll play i'm
way up a little i just think starlord all and gambit all is
just too good to not oh oh you mean that are they gonna play
it though oh no no they don't have a star oh my god we have
starlord i think that's what yeah probably i put spark chief
up a little bit i mean we should just iron them here i have
yeah i have no strong feelings one way or the other happy
birthday should i just see the ammo for a gamble probably uh
yeah we can well we'll see what the situation is yeah yeah
let's get it team let's get it
Is that an iron fist cap?
Yeah they're playing hard though.
Gambit?
Yeah, yeah.
It's kind played like Mars.
We just played them first and then we can walk.
Fist is going right.
Fist is going in.
It's so hard going.
I need to team up.
Look Fist, my team.
I mean, you're going.
Fist one.
He's low, he's low.
Brand one, he's low.
Can you guys walk now, walk now, walk now.
I'm going in.
Can you guys walk with me?
Three, two, one.
I'm walking rebellion.
Hey, I'm with you.
What cap?
Oh, cap on him.
Cap on you.
Bucky dies.
We can't keep going.
We can keep going.
Cap, cap, cap, cap.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Mark and cap.
I'm on Rogue right now.
Rogue half, Rogue half.
Three, two, one.
I'm pushing him.
Fist is going in.
I can steal.
Look up Rogue.
Three, two, one.
Rogue, Rogue, Rogue, Rogue.
Rogue, Rogue, Rogue.
First one.
Can we walk?
Don't have, don't have, don't have, don't have.
I'm using team up on Bucky.
Look at Gamba, look at Gamba.
Gamba 1, really close.
I can't kill.
Amon's first.
I'm on sparing.
Lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky.
Yeah, I'm looking at this, I'm looking at this.
Rook on.
There's a cap on point still.
I'm sorry, that we're good.
Cap low.
Cap 1.
Nice, good job, good job.
I'm out.
Okay, they have everything except for Gamba.
I can start with my ult.
We all walk hard.
the bitumen yeah yeah i'll go on the su i can like dive on
her probably with my e um i think i think we emmowed um
actually they don't have gamma yeah we can we get them out
the first or the capo yeah there you go i'm gonna go on the
right side when they start walking i'm gonna go three two
one i'm going on i'm gonna go i'm gonna go everyone i'll do
just have sus1 we gotta force their Yeah, if we force like a
sword after.
I need help on the right side if you can.
Watching you, watching you.
Barking cap, cap, cap, cap.
Hey, yeah.
You might have to use your arrow right here.
Yeah, yeah, I'm going right.
We're off the road.
Oh, I got hurt.
Can you touch captain?
Yeah, I'm on them one.
They capped, they capped.
No, they haven't.
Oh, they haven't.
They haven't.
They haven't capped.
Just keep laying on points.
I'm back off here.
I'm gonna go Hella.
You're still hot first though.
They have Gambit, Iron Fist.
Rogue.
I think...
Be really careful.
They're gonna go really, really fast with Gambit, okay?
Yeah, they have the Roku.
They're really slow here.
Really slow here.
Okay, take damage from me, but be really slow.
I'm clearing top low.
There's two people top low.
I'm gonna clear them.
You guys can walk, man.
Where are you going?
I'm going top low.
Just chill.
Do you guys take damage?
First one.
I cannot drop.
I can't drop.
First one.
Fist one.
I'm on Rogue.
We can win.
I need card.
Go, go.
Play main.
Play.
I'm going back lane.
Yeah, going back lane.
I'm on Rogue.
We can't go back lane anymore.
Chill main, chill main, chill main.
I'm still in rogue.
Rogue is half, rogue is half by yourself.
Bucky one, Bucky one.
Bucky one, Bucky one, Bucky one, Bucky one.
I'm outing this, I'm outing this.
I'm pulling them, I'm pulling them.
I'm pulling them.
I have all the three.
Rogue, rogue, rogue, rogue, rogue, rogue, rogue, rogue,
rogue, rogue, rogue.
Rogue one, rogue one.
I'm grabbing cap, cap, cap, cap is done.
Cheating supports.
Cap how?
Cap is one.
Oh, cap is one.
Oh.
Nice, good job.
Nice.
I saw a wall.
I might need heals.
Gambit, Fist, Bucky.
They have Iron Fist too.
I'm just gonna try to force Invisal soon, yeah.
OK, okay.
We should go earlier, I think, actually.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can we walk?
Can we walk a six with mine?
Yeah, I want to.
I'm going, I'm going.
Can we go?
I got the Ops.
I'm hiding, I'm hiding, I'm hiding, I'm hiding.
Two dead, two dead.
Nice.
I'm grabbing Fist.
Oh, Fist left.
Good grab, good grab.
They only use Fist.
Listen, they have Gambit before me, okay?
We can take damage for you.
Please.
Where are they going?
Main?
Let me hear.
I'm taking damage.
Look at Fist.
This is a touch, I think.
No block.
I'm looking Fist.
He's having a trade?
95.
I'm out.
I will match Gambit, okay?
I'm grabbing Rope.
Oh, good stuff.
I'm okay.
I have an armor fist, armor fist, armor fist.
Care, care, care, we cannot die.
We cannot die here.
Yeah, kill our team, kill our team.
Rogue inside of us.
Rogue inside.
I'm playing main.
Cap on me main.
Cap one, cap one.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Bucky one, Bucky one.
Bucky one, Bucky one, Bucky one.
I don't have shields.
I cleanse, I cleanse.
Look at Fizz.
Fizz said Fizz said.
Can we walk together?
Walk together.
I'm on Bucky, I'm on Bucky.
Bucky, I'm on Bucky.
i'm building with you you guys have a i'm playing in i'm
grabbing bucky bucky stop HP i'm on sewer right now bucky
low bucky low bucky low nice regs see that look at fist look
at fist now ring a fist nice ring ring a fist king first one
first one no boss i'm on team i'm watching roguest 100% she
dies i'm on rogu 1 i'm on nice nice nice guys we keep
talking about the movie rogu 1 ah yeah baby
guys the reason why i'm talking so much is because we have
so i don't need to talk i just need to exist they have fast
life yeah they do all the talking i get to be head empty if
we can just exist it's better yeah come face the end of all
that is yeah i'm just vibing yeah don't be scared because
every time i open i have like i'd be like this person no
that's all i gotta say true true do you do you like a combo
with um star spark uh i don't i can just vibe i think we
just go it does a lot of damage and i can see them all the
time okay i wish i could just do that every game but if you
feel like you want to do it i feel like you can i don't feel
like it's
KRTP maybe No, no, they need to touch Oh, yeah, you're right
Yeah, yeah, yeah We can walk at them a little bit If they
drop under, we can go faster Yeah, yeah, I dropped I'm gonna
walk, are you guys ready?
Yeah, yeah, yeah Alright, 3, 2, 1 I'm on them, I'm on them
I'm on them, I'm on them Oh my god, okay, you guys died It's
okay, it's okay, we can still fight I pulled them, I pulled
Rogue back.
Rogue's one.
We could chill, we could chill.
I vote, I vote.
Yeah.
I can combo with you, uh, Fara.
Okay, okay.
Can you give it all to him?
Yeah, yeah.
We can go through, we can go through.
Help our star, Apple star.
I'm dead here.
Cool.
I have, uh, Emma on me.
Emma low, Emma low.
I got you, I got you.
Can you put me, man?
Nice, we're good.
I have Invis, Star.
We used a lot that though.
I pulled her back.
Wait, Amos could die?
Can we hold up?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, okay.
They're all walking right, all walking right.
They have a lot of votes.
We should just like hold them close and then kite if we
need.
I feel like we can ammo to kite.
Yeah, we can.
Bucky one, Bucky one, Bucky one, Bucky one.
Oh, no cleanse.
I'm pulling them in.
Look at Brooke.
Nice, I guess.
I'm grabbing Emma.
Emma should though.
Ching, Ching, Ching, Ching.
He's running.
Pull her up.
I think we're dead now.
Don't get too green.
Emma's left?
Yeah, yeah.
I don't have support of that still.
Yeah, we can go with my ult.
Do they have any tank ults maybe?
Oh, for now.
Both?
Yeah, they're both.
They're both.
Okay, I'll just go and text them.
Okay.
I'm still 80 right now.
Wait, make them more kill, Captain.
I'll go when they come to Chelsea.
83.
I'm ulting in 3, 2, 1.
I'm going to kill you.
Me?
Oh, 94, 95.
I got it.
It's huge.
I have the back.
Me too.
I got the back.
Yeah, I'm cutting.
I got pulled.
I got pulled for it.
She's on me.
Yeah, I'm dead.
Let's go.
I'm gonna try and stall.
Yeah, I'll stall down as I can.
And he's dead, boy.
That was a bad.
They used a lot.
Yeah, they did.
Yeah, we have stall on the gambit.
They use double support, Starlord, Bucky and what else?
Emma.
They smash Emma.
Emma is...
So only Rogue?
Only Rogue, I think.
And let's listen, make my own, I think we...
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, nice.
Now you just get Rogo, get Rogo.
Don't get too excited.
Rogue, Rogue, Rogue.
One HP, one HP, one HP.
One HP, one HP.
You can die, you die.
That was good.
I'm grabbing their Gambit.
You can kill the Rogue.
I'm holding him.
What?
Gambit Antit.
Have HP.
That's 2-1-2.
I put someone back.
I don't know who.
M1, M1.
M1.
We still have Zarlow.
Excellent.
I still have Volt as well.
We need to poke up there.
They're portally.
Yeah, strange.
I'm just playing from out here.
They won't have Invis ult, so I'll just go for...
Yeah, I'll go on the suit really hard.
Okay, I'll go on main.
I'll go on main.
I'm going to in three, two, one.
I'm on suit.
I'll take one thing.
Oh, he fucking hits away.
Oh, he canceled it.
Yeah, that's what I'm here.
Just reset, reset, it's okay.
I'm back here.
I'll just go build up.
They're gonna be 50 there, Gambit.
Yeah, they'll have.
50 Gambit.
Wait, what will they have?
They have Gambit.
I couldn't see if I can cancel with mine.
I don't think I can.
I think both support.
I can use mine to bait and then you can ammo the kite if you
want.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna start going ready.
Just walk up three, two, one.
Okay.
Chill, chill, chill, chill, chill, chill, chill, chill,
chill, back, back, back, back, back.
We just live, we just live.
Yeah, we just live.
Look at Rogue inside us.
Rogue inside us.
I pulled her back.
I got you.
Big pull.
Styler one, styler one.
I'm walking on them.
Those are.
Styler one, styler one.
I'm on Invis.
Care I.
They will have I soon.
Yeah, easy.
I don't have...
I pushed your wish.
Missed, you missed.
Can you come in?
Can you walk?
I don't have all of them yet.
I don't have them here.
I'm moving.
I'm waiting.
Let me know when I can go back then.
I can go there.
Hello.
I'm on there, Sue.
He's grabbed.
He's grabbed three, two, one.
We can put three little combo with me.
Bucky is low.
Bucky one.
I can't get you.
Bucky's still low.
I have.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
Push, push, push.
Everyone should walk.
Color Bucky.
Bucky.
Bucky Bucky.
Bucky Bucky Bucky.
I pulled her back.
Nice.
Got it.
Just gambit.
Left side.
Yeah.
Someone didn't die.
They have no TP.
Solid and gambit.
Nice.
Nice guy.
Hey, we did it.
Yippee!
See you guys when I don't have to think I put...
See guys?
Hades was a good one.
warm-up I told you my Hades warm-up popping off as I can go
I knew we could just play Hades and everything will be fine
yeah I spent all my free will in the Hades so I don't have
to think anymore yeah You know it.
Don't have to think anymore.
Spent it all on Hades.
I just listen.
I'm just listening.
Isn't that great?
I love free will.
Yeah.
Doki Wonder Players has 200 ping.
Yeah, well, they have rank 1 to 5 on their team.
It's one person, but it still counts.
It's...
That guy is practically four of his teammates.
He's a support player, but it still counts.
Yeah, with my default, the King of Akon, yeah.
Yeah, they have all of top five in there.
Default Andy.
What the fuck?
Sydney, let's all just go to OCE.
Three bro, he actually lives next to the he actually lives
next to the fucking OCE servers.
Yeah.
Bro, at least he got look, he got three pinged though.
Everyone is banging in the past.
At least he got three pinged.
He lives inside.
He literally like is it's like in the office.
Yeah.
Are we going?
Yeah, we're going to middle earth.
Guys, we're going to the middle earth.
Hello?
Hello.
Hear me out.
How good is Waki Zio in Spider-Man?
How good is he on Spider-Man?
I just know it's all he plays, so I think we keep him on
Bucky.
Yeah, that is all he plays.
I'm not going to lie.
Yeah.
Okay.
I want to say something top.
I was like, I mean, it's all he plays and he's also Celestio
3.
Is that something for me to say?
Yeah.
Okay, but also, guys, it is all he plays, but he is also in
Celestio 3 with his one trick.
I don't have a good one.
I'm not going to lie.
I do see him win off his one trick a lot more, but I don't
know.
I said it.
Get up to you guys.
I don't mind.
Are we in Wakanda?
I think we're in Wakanda.
Yeah, especially on this map too.
I think you keep him on it.
He wants to.
I don't know why they chose this map.
It's just so like pork heavy.
Yeah, this is bad for them.
I don't know why they picked it.
Maybe they're swapping up their strategy.
Maybe Dweep is picking up roots.
There you go.
He is good though.
He is good on his one trick.
But he is also in Celestio.
right now it's just not spider-man meta right now the only
the issue is that it's not spider-man meta no fear that's
why he wants the eu so he's not climbing because of it i'm
gonna go on jordan maybe you see frankfurt again bro he gets
more ping why the fuck does the guy want frankfurt
the 200 ping guy was just like it was just like hey can i
see eu i'm like bro you have more ping in eu why the do you
want to stay cool it's worse for you bro you know geography
i'm not not that creative by the way he just wants more he
just wants to make it harder he likes the challenge guys he
was like 200 ping was not big enough of a challenge
he's trying to hit a high score oh the sound guys everything
balanced now for audio i prefer pepsi i can't lie i think
pepsi clears really that's a hot take he needs the thrill of
a real like he wants to predict everything he's like he's
he's like this thing is too good make get worse the best
pepsi i had was in the philippines because they had a
fucking pepsi factory next to where i was staying and the
street was called pepsi mexican coke is still the best he
did the stuff back for my birthday meal with the family and
he'll complete my day if i can get happy birthday from my
ocean of course rax happy birthday to you no yeah i live in
georgia i've been there many times their coke that you get
at the very end is like the best you'll ever
for the super chat thank you thank you give me that sound
i really appreciate it and it's it's wild it is super good
though but i know i think till the next match everyone can
be brought down a bit oh you want me to bring them down now
sound yet yeah it's just cane sugar over high fructose corn
syrup just much better flavor profile I believe those lines.
Is it sound guy?
Is it like, wait, did we say R yet?
Teams are?
Oh, they asked us if we're ready.
Yeah, we're ready.
Oh.
Yeah, they're like, yeah, team, like.
Yeah.
I'm ready.
Come on, move it alive!
I have to go to a maid cafe!
Move this alive!
Gotta go.
go i
think i'm like more socially awkward for this team is
because i literally the the only two people i've talked to
really was rigsy i mean i've had teams i've been teamed with
gail a couple of times like maybe like one one other time
but like everyone else is like super new you want to just
keep it on their level yeah yeah yeah so like this is a lot
more socially awkward because it's It's like poor people who
I don't really know.
And even then, I'd never really talked to Risky.
We just interacted via text to each other.
So, so I'm just like, for me, I'm like, I don't know what to
say.
So we are giving them Spirements.
Who's going to be our second Ben, we think?
We got to get rid of either Loki or Gambit.
No.
Whatever, when they don't save, yeah.
Yeah, that's a little bit, okay.
bring them down though yeah i brought them down i think uh
if we are playing star lord um i'd probably rather ban i
brought him down loki keep the yeah gambit for the alt
combos okay yeah yeah loki ban is good if i can play celok
yeah oh good point just vibe and flow yeah i think it's just
staying I like that.
Fan Loki products lie.
Bye.
I was just too good.
They were target bad in me, guys.
This game should be like fucking easy.
I was just so good.
No.
And they were afraid of me.
Ew, this is disgusting.
Oh, I like this.
It's gonna be nasty.
So you're probably either on pocket or living here.
It just depends on what they're playing.
You feel like you can live.
And you know.
Oh, I'm on Venom Oh, they protect the rocket The Spider-Man
Maybe I could see them doing it Down I don't even know what
it's doing To be fair I already overwrote that memory Oh,
hey What the Oh, I was like, what the fuck?
I look how they added him Just see like This one was coming
Okay They're gonna play Gambit rocket probably And just I'll
bring him down Play that little dive oh um oh they've missed
the true if invis is banned and we have starboard silo baby
gambit do you want to respect it do we respect it they man
gamut yeah probably sure he's just here he's just chilling
right i mean they might also ironically what i was thinking
they might do ultron as well maybe yeah eventually there's
double support ultron which is not as yeah but what What do
you want to play, Joki?
I mean, I can play whatever.
Oh, we're still in ping.
I just realized.
We're in a nice though.
Defense.
What goes with?
What?
What's the hero cap?
I know Luna's like your guy, so.
I'll play Luna.
Okay.
Like the moon.
I'll shine in darkness.
I think I think I actually Phoenix here.
Because it would be on a rocket.
So I could put less effort.
So I could try.
gonna do is maybe rocket luna or or shark luna shark
honestly i would i would have played rockets so i could not
work as hard oh yeah you do forget about the team up don't
forget you have the team up with me too oh yeah that wall
doesn't have hp by the way it's it's blatantly broken like
if you wanted to go star yeah it's just the timer oh wait
that's insane yeah Don't forget, you can snowflake yourself
now.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
Yeah, they're on cap.
They're cap rope.
Cap rope rockets.
Adam.
They have iron fist.
Yeah, iron fist.
Adam, yeah.
They're going top right.
Wait, what?
Oh, there's somewhere.
Yeah.
Find of you.
Spider-Man is behind us now.
Yeah, they're going top left.
I think you just got to play in garage with me.
Wait, look at their fist.
Look at their fist.
Oh, they're fat.
I'm on them.
Oh, yeah.
Caps low.
He played inside.
I'm mucking this cup.
They may.
He's pretty low.
Caps have.
Caps push.
They link.
Oh, I can't see her.
One HP.
Done.
Kill the rogue.
Oh, and he hears.
Spider-Man behind.
On your backline.
I can't grab one.
Oh, well.
I'm dead.
I'm also might be dead.
Caps one.
Oh, I'm dead.
Uh, I TP?
Yeah.
Yeah, I can go support.
I'll be banned.
Oh, maybe Rixie goes somewhere.
Spider-Man might try and cancel me, so I'm going to put it
fast.
I would go.
I can touch three, two, one.
I'm dead.
Can we help her?
Kappa, right?
Kappa is half.
I have HP.
Oh, he grabbed me.
I'm going, Kappa.
Kappa is done.
Kappa can die.
You can die.
I have Spider-Man on me.
I might be dead, though.
Kappa's like, can I break the bunker?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I got it.
I'm done.
I got the Spider-Man.
I'm trying to loot.
I think maybe you play Bucky.
Okay.
I TP now.
What do you think?
Yeah?
Yeah, Bucky is insane.
Oh, there's a permanent attack going.
Okay, Spider-Man's here left.
Oh, they use Rocket, Red.
They have Spider-Man.
Yeah, they have two people top left.
Yeah, they have two people right now.
They're on me.
They're on me, they're on me.
They took my ult charge.
Yeah, you get Rose.
Wait, I'm gonna meditate for you guys.
I pulled a rogue cat.
Let's grab my ult.
I'm gonna rogue with you.
I have to reload.
Rogue one, rogue one.
I'm gonna use it for you.
put on a show stay linked i don't have a yet spiderman on me
where are you i got you she's off i need help too trying oh
my god there's a heart diving i'm gonna backline they're
hard diving almost back almost back almost back almost back
can we touch can we touch really important i have a yeah
yeah it's gonna be one touching point i'm touching i'm
touching I got this, I got this.
Can I break?
Rogue is deep.
I'm trying to break.
Yeah, I'm shooting him too.
They broke my beacon.
I shot it.
I'm on rogue.
Rogue and die.
Don't see knife for the kill.
Yeah, yeah, point, point, point.
I froze captain.
Captain, captain.
I got one.
Adam is far right.
I'm going Adam.
Adam might rest.
Yeah, he rest.
He has to reload.
Bro, go, go, go, go.
I'm getting, wait, come to me.
I have link.
Three, two, one.
I'm linking.
Oh.
Put them in.
Cap one, Cap one.
I have iron fist on me.
Iron fist low.
Iron fist one.
He's dead.
He gets res.
Oh, rogue.
Rogue one.
Oh, no.
Iron fist can die.
I'm in really low.
I'm in dead.
Fist to stop.
Yeah, I'm on fist.
Fist, I'm on fist.
Fist, I'm on block.
He's one.
He's one, he's one.
Adam, Adam.
Cap, Cap, Cap.
Nice.
Good job.
I just steal the Adam look at it.
That was really good.
Yeah.
Nice.
Take damage for our Luna.
What do they have?
They have Spider-Man alone, right?
Yeah, they do.
Yeah, Spider-Man, Broke, I think.
Capped.
Yeah, maybe Capped.
Listen, we really got to build our support ult here.
Yeah, I'm trying to take damage.
They don't have a lot of poke, though.
You want to go early with Sai?
I think we need a force before they get to point.
Oh, yeah, I can do it.
I bet it's still.
Okay, I'm going.
I'm on Roke.
Roke can die, maybe.
They still block.
Yeah, yeah.
One, two, one.
We don't have the logo.
Carry the rogo.
Go Spidey, Spidey, Spidey.
Huge.
Can you break?
They didn't push, they didn't push, they didn't push.
Three, two, one.
I'm looking for this.
Fizz is all.
Oh my gosh.
I'm dead.
That's fine.
That's 90 on mine.
I have a Spider-Man on me.
I'm on.
Cap has all.
Cap is gonna ult soon.
Yeah, I vote.
I vote.
I'm holding on the corner.
Don't let them break.
Look at face.
Look at this.
He's looking for breakage.
Miles broke.
I'm gonna look to grab him soon.
He's grabbed.
Look at him.
I'm frozen.
He's one.
They're resing.
Yeah, we can't kill him.
I'm with you.
I'm meditating on the plan.
I'm chilling.
Roken die.
I need help.
I still need help though.
I'm on top.
him he's one stay fine stay fine stay fine spider-man i'm
here oh i got you oh thank you thank you oh my bad thank you
thank you spider-man behind so here i did not need that the
road can just hover in the air that's crazy yeah she like
flies like they have rocket i think it's like waiting from
the land it's crazy she's sick rocket close road
Rockets, Rockets, Rockets, Rockets.
Captain, Captain behind us, Captain and Iron Fist.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I can mark, I can mark this.
I'm looking for this.
Spremon, DPS, DPS, DPS, DPS.
I'm one of one of them.
I might be dead here.
Oh, we have nothing for that, yeah.
I don't know where to go.
Oh, maybe I can TPS, hold on.
Calling.
Really good stall, really good stall.
I got to protect me from Spider-Man.
We'll try.
He's top.
They're coming here.
I can touch.
We can touch them.
We're 90 on our ult too.
95, 96.
I got it.
I'm killing you.
You can get out.
You can get out anyone.
Yeah, I'm going to.
Okay.
I cannot.
That's for free.
I can look at Rope.
Robe is out.
One.
I'm dead here though.
You get Rope.
I'm grabbing everyone.
Cap.
Look out.
Look.
Face up luck, face up luck.
Miss one, face one.
Big damage, big damage.
Spider-Man 1-2.
Face not luck still.
Spider-Man though?
Spider-Man's back.
Oh.
Guys, roll roll, roll, roll, roll.
Spider-Man's still- Oh, he's getting healed.
59, 99.
Nice.
Good job, guys.
The current score is...
Uh, jab.
Time to switch things up.
Including which side?
See, everything is fine.
Everything is fine.
Top notch team to win this one.
everything is fine look it took me a little to warm up on
the freezes but i got it down okay it took me a little while
but i figured it out i figured out out the freezes and i i
hit those after that i could also bring up the i mean it's a
lot less stressful because i'm literally playing
the person that's been playing hades why am i being targeted
i wasn't even more i was playing yeah team captain would
think not be insane into what they're playing you think just
ground them for five seconds that's true careful for the
spider-man pull yeah have you got the spider-man if you get
the spider-man too it's that guaranteed i feel like but it's
up to you i could throw it this way right gotta be proud
take jump whoever It's most vulnerable to Spider-Man Paul.
Me.
I'll be taking that.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
There should be another.
Hold on.
Oh.
So, baby, any time now.
Oh, okay.
There it is.
There you go.
It's coming.
Spider-Man.
I'll get me.
You got that?
Hello.
No.
That is crazy.
He might come back.
He's gonna go back.
Yeah, he's gonna go back.
Yeah, he's around us.
Yeah, just wait guys Is he looking for Doki again?
It's okay.
I can run past it You got that.
Yeah, he's here.
He's here.
He's looking I'm like he'll try to jump up.
I'm gonna go take an angle.
I'll take Fight my non-Doki right now.
Yeah, I have self-snowplay He's so low.
Look at rogue.
He's low.
He's one.
He's that he's that he's that he's that Bucky, Bucky, Bucky,
Bucky, Bucky.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're up two, up two.
I have Res down still, too.
Yeah, I'm on Bucky.
Three, two, one.
I'm on Backline.
There's a Bucky to the right here.
I have a lot on me.
Can you help me?
Watch Spider-Man pull.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm dead.
Oh, you don't get right.
I lived.
I lived, I lived, I lived.
I froze something.
I'm trying to chill.
We don't have anything.
Yeah, I could go with you, Riggs.
Yeah, let's go.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, I didn't see you.
You can't do it.
We won this.
Come walkie, walkie, walkie.
No, I quit.
Oh.
No supports.
Yeah.
Okay, we need to reset.
Yeah, we have to create.
They use both vaults though.
They have both support.
They have, uh, they have Spiderman.
I have vault here.
I can look first.
Spiderman is looking for a hook again.
Yeah, I can just put a hook together.
They don't have support.
We can just bungle in.
Okay, okay.
Me first.
I'm gonna grab the Emma so she can't ult, okay?
Oh, we gotta wait.
Wait, they might push...
They might push like early.
I'm coming back on Venom, you see by first.
Okay, okay.
Are we here?
Almost, almost, almost, almost.
Can we walk?
Oh, we're going, we're going.
Three, two, one.
I got the Emma, I got the Emma, Emma, Emma.
I'm looking for Bongo.
I'm on Bongo for him.
Nice!
Oh, I have a Spider-Man on me.
Emma has to hold.
Look, Emma, look at him.
Spider-Man low?
Spider-Man half?
Iron Fist dies, Iron Fist.
Roll, roll, roll, roll.
He gets Mega.
Listen, Spider-Man right side here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll see you.
I think he got out.
Nice.
They have Spider-Man all...
We have Freeze, Bucky, Phoenix, so...
50 bills apart.
Yeah, we have a little stuns for it.
We have a little stuns for it.
We're good.
I have to play inside against this guy.
That's okay.
We can just play on point.
Look at their comp.
They have to like go into us.
We're fine.
I'll just follow up with whatever Kepon does.
There's Spider-Man's coming.
He missed.
Watch pull up the map.
Yeah, he's trying.
I'm walking under Emma.
Backline.
3, 2, 1.
I'm on backline.
I'm on Backline.
I'm on.
I'm on backline.
Nice.
Getting rogue here?
Oh, grab.
I'm on backline with you.
I'm on backline.
Oh my god, nuclear.
Nuclear.
They have both support.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We should go really early with Rogue.
Yeah, yeah, I can.
Yeah, yeah.
Only way we went.
Like 70 to old.
I can build for the die.
I'm hiding and looking.
Alright.
I'm going on Luna and Rocket.
Three, two, one.
I have a Spider-Man on you.
I need help.
I need a lot of help.
Oh, I need a lot of help too.
Yeah.
They ulted though.
Just give it.
It's all good.
I mean, we got... No, I'm friends.
Is that it?
Yeah, we did.
Yeah.
They don't know.
They have Bucky...
Bucky Rogue Luna.
They use Spider?
Or do they have...
They have it.
They used it.
They used it last fight.
Oh, there you go.
Yeah, there you go.
We're just gonna bait Luna.
Let's take a quick fight and bait Luna.
Then we can live and then we can go with our Bucky and
Phoenix combo.
Yeah.
Don't be afraid to die, by the way, Doki.
I have Bongo for you.
Most fight.
Or not Bongo.
Sorry, guys.
We're still down on...
He's dealing with Spider behind us, guys.
Yeah, yeah.
I lived.
Okay, we can walk.
I'm gonna go on the Emma ready.
Three, two, one.
I have Diamond.
Oh, I spotted one.
I'm heading back one right now.
Okay, I'm coming with.
Emma behind.
I'm pulling in.
No Diamond.
I'm a Luna.
Usually every two is killing me.
They did.
I have a Rock and then.
I have a rogue.
We did have a rogue behind us.
A first Luna.
They busted.
They... Rookin dead.
Rookin died.
Rookin die.
Rookin, whoa.
Rocket then.
I have one on, one on, on, one on.
One on.
Rock has us.
Nice.
There's five points.
Kill points.
Yeah, I'm on one.
I'm on.
Back one, back one.
Spider, spider.
He has spider over touch.
They're TPing.
Play left side with me, Doki.
Inside.
I'll go to the right side.
They have Spider-Man a lot.
Okay.
I got the ammo.
He's gonna go on us.
I'm playing a corner.
Head one.
Oh, fuck it.
One, change the one.
Where?
Oh, I'm dead here.
Are you killed two?
I killed two?
He's just a little to me.
Yeah.
I'm on one, I'm on one.
Spider-Man's on Earth.
Rocky right now.
Rocky one on me.
Yeah.
I'm done.
Should I TP?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, yeah.
Oh, I'm just gonna run over.
It's a strange on point.
I'm running over.
Keeping, keeping, keeping.
I'm coming.
I'm through, I'm through.
All right.
I'm here, I'm here.
It's not your only appointment.
Angela have?
Good.
Spider-Man?
Everyone?
Spider-Man 1?
Yeah!
There you go!
Let's go!
Good job!
So you guys, this is why I didn't want to play Luna.
I knew.
I was just like, I knew what was going to happen to me.
I was just like, I'm going to play Rocket right now.
how does the intermission between this and the next game um
good question yeah i don't want to wait another hour and a
half right now yeah no i'm with you on that let's
investigate bro i have three people beating my the shit out
of me like i was not having it I literally had Amphys,
Spider-Man, Captain America, fucking beating my ass off.
I had no health insurance.
There was no health insurance in this.
Yeah.
The two solo alts, too.
I got all the solo alts in so many times.
I was not happy.
a good time that's i was like i don't really want to play
luna i i guess i don't know i don't know how the scheduling
works did we even get broadcasted or not no uh yeah we
didn't get broadcasted um we didn't get what was the point
if we weren't broadcasted oh my god okay the winner of ours
starts at 5 p.m oh yeah it's the holy two hours Okay, what
is the point of making us wait if we're not broadcasted?
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah, I agree with you on that one.
Just fucking run it.
Yeah.
If we're not being on stream, just run it.
You should just feel the face.
Moxie.
Oh, we know.
If you think about it, if we don't lose, we get to go early.
They're still in game.
Oh, they're still in game.
Oh, wow.
they're on map three yeah they're they're one to one yeah oh
wow pretty even team then oh they did the they have a cheeky
spawn hold map disgusting 650 ping i know i thought it would
be broadcasted if i'm waiting this long if i'm waiting this
long you might be broadcasted i could have taken I could
have woken up at 11 p.m.
I, sorry, not 11 a.m.
I could have woken up at 11 a.m.
Guys, I, bro, some of the, bro, I'm watching one of the
players, one of the players that's like, that's like
streaming this, they're on Diablo.
They're like, gotta wait an hour.
They're on fucking Diablo.
They're, It's not even playing the game!
And that's an actual rival's play!
Oh!
It's okay.
I'm calm.
I will say it would be nice if scheduling was.
if we're not if we're not gonna be on stream it would be
very nice if we could just run the games it would be very
nice you know a lot of a lot of you know it's all about
learning they're gonna learn for next tournament they'll
learn next tournament it's
okay uh i'm just gonna i'm gonna grab water it's okay we'll
grab water you know what i'll give you guys entertainment
because like we don't have to be in this i'm gonna go
fucking hydrate
leave all right don't worry and i got the tutu on too i go
get water i'll be right back
Got my I have to reheat my chicken nuggies too.
That's right My chicken nuggies.
I haven't had chicken nuggies in a long ass time You know
what I really want?
I want to try the Burger King and Spongebob meal I really
want to try it looks really good All right, thank you for
the super chat.
Thank you for it.
Thank you super chat.
Thank you.
This is for very yeah it's venom's time to shine I would go
to time square if if I didn't get the MCA I would definitely
go yeah I wish I have an air fryer microwave chicken nuggets
is not it I think it's NA only big bug big guy big guy
SpongeBob big pass okay it's so fucking stupid like everyone
was like roasting what's your name was it ice spice i don't
remember her name i don't keep up with rap um about like the
how bad the saw was and now like after the saw like it isn't
i will say it is very catchy lyric it's not a lyrical
masterpiece but it is very catchy uh it's like everywhere on
my fucking um It's like everywhere on, like, shorts right
now.
Everyone's doing the goddamn dance because of the beat.
The beat is good.
It's just lyrics-wise.
It's very unfortunate.
Big guy.
Bun bra pants.
And it's a lyrical masterpiece.
Fuck you, me.
People shit on them despite being popular.
Yes, but with Nickelback, at least...
the suns okay you can't say that listen to a nickelback song
and then this listen to a big guy big guy sponge pop pants
okay you cannot say that if you look at the lyrics between
the two you cannot make that comparison that's actually
crazy i swear to god if i have to wait two hours i fucking
gun I'm not I am not having it if I have to wait two hours
sorry any air fire fun thank you the super chat well thank
you thank you like I'm supposed to play five matches this is
not looking like it's gonna be bad we're like we're
technically like two one hour behind we are one hour behind
schedule right now
that is not looking he's not looking good we find one
game.
One game and one Hades run.
Attack and do it another run.
We're gonna miss out on content.
Yes, I started at 9 in the morning.
It's now 12.15 and I played one game.
I don't
there's no way.
No, I No, I was like, what?
What do you mean?
I have to wait.
There's no way.
I refuse to believe that that is the schedule.
I refuse to believe that.
Because the thing is, look, I am...
I've seen a lot of graphics, so I don't know which ones...
This is supposed to be the schedule.
I know damn well we did not start at, like...
What's the tab?
Our match number one did not start at 10 a.m.
Oh, why is it an EST?
I don't know how to read EST.
I'm from a PSD.
I don't know.
I don't know if I like Venom groaning and all that shit in
my ear.
There's supposed to be the actuals.
schedule it's like plus or minus three out like no I know
it's minus three hours but counting backwards sucks I don't
know it's not guys I might be stupid but I know I know I
have to convert PSD to ESD I'm just saying it sucks that I
always have to subtract it every time
this does not look correct you're an hour behind and and I
still have I've not had my second match yet.
It's just inconvenient.
I would play a game, but I'm eating chicken nuggets right
now.
I don't know if I can play a rival's match, because I don't
know when my match is supposed to start.
Bump, bump, bump, bump.
Yeah, my chicken nuggets.
That's nuggy sauce.
I don't know.
I haven't had chicken nuggets in so long, so I can't tell.
No, I'm fucking leaving.
I said I'm leaving at 4.30 back.
Like, I was like, I didn't...
I can't commit.
You told me...
I asked them, and they told me that, don't worry, it would
end way before my 4 p.m.
I said 4 p.m.
I'm being generous right now by pushing it to 4.30.
But I was like, they were like, don't worry, it'll end way
before 4.
And I was like, yeah, okay, if you promise me that, I'll
sign, I'll participate.
I said, it's not flexible.
I said PSD, I was like, if it was ESD, there is no way they
can commit to ESD.
Literally, I think they have an hour left if it was ESD,
that's worse.
If I said I have to leave at 4 p.m.
EST, That is a lot worse than PSD
Because I'm out by in an hour Yeah No, they'll find me a sub
I said I really can't do it Like I legitimately cannot push
this Like I have a contract obligation I didn't sign no
contract for this tournament Like
I didn't sign a contract track here.
I signed a contract for the maid cafe, though.
That's crazy.
We're already almost on match three.
Alternate.
The alternate universe, Joki, might be on match three by
now.
I'm on the other side of the coin.
Patrick, I said, leave a super chat.
Thank you.
Me, when I lie.
VTuber, I'll support a choir.
Yeah, I am...
I'm just muted.
Nobody's talking.
They're all talking to their chat.
But everybody's just talking to their own chat.
I don't know.
I'm just awkward right now.
And it's because I had a lot of social interaction.
Oh, yeah.
The last couple of days.
So that's why I'm like super awkward.
Talking to people.
Takes more effort for me.
Bump, bump, bump, bump.
Bump,
bump, bump, bump, bump.
I don't know which team is, like, the strongest team right
now.
I feel like some teams deserve to have three pros.
The battery's not working right now.
I mean, I had a lot of interactions yesterday.
I think, like, you know, 30-plus people were there at the
mid-cap phase.
And, you know, I talked to a lot of people
back-to-back-to-back.
And also, like, that was what it meant, too.
Yeah, but it's hard to gauge.
Because, okay, look, it's very hard to gauge.
I'll tell you why.
some teams have two pro players who are tank and DPS or even
deep to double DPS so it's very hard to gauge whether or not
but like what team would is like a very strong team
there's like um okay zeal's team he had a tank and a support
but his tank is also on 200 ping so like like you know not
the greatest um the other pro is spark cheap he's the off
tank player from fly quest
mmhmm so like I don't know yellow isn't considered pro he's
a content creator technically a content creator but it must
be nice to be on hush of like I want to stream on YouTube
because I wanted to keep the VOD because I always forget to
upload VODs like I don't know I'm sorry guys I will remember
one day I'm gonna hand the VOD channel over to my staff team
and then they can handle the VOD channel but like I'm just
all over the place right now so I just wanted to keep the
VODs so that's why I streamed here
I like having tournament stuff on the main channel
No, I don't.
Nidoki's vlog channels are still exciting.
Oh, yeah.
Um.
I made a tweet.
Because apparently, okay, it was rumors.
Because the director came in and was like, oh, yeah, they
deleted it.
Ha, ha, they deleted a tweet.
So, um, I can't believe the guy deleted his tweet.
So the guy, some guy made a tweet being like, um, rumors
saying that it'll take the new star wars game the star wars
old republic like 2030 earliest release date and direct and
i over tweeted it i was like this is our new silk song you
know every year we'll be like is silk song gonna be
announced yet i was gonna be like this is our new silk song
he's like that's what we need we need a new silk song um
you'd be like yeah gta is our silk song like it's not the
same it's not the same because we all know gta would take
fucking forever and still only have six games like like
everyone everyone everyone expects expects it already like
no one no one is like oh ha ha when will they announce GTA
but everyone is just like it's just expected but um yeah GTA
6 has another one in the most anticipated a game they just
want to collect that collect the free free award it's like
their collect go yeah so we need another silk song to keep
it hype you know but that's why there is nothing to look
forward to in the game awards like some people like what
about blood boy oh guys come on i'm once i want something
realistic here
guys we're talking about something realistic like
so so I was like we need it and then like I was like yay
that's right because they're like oh and then the director
the Mass Effect director guy was like guys don't worry um it
will not release before it will not release um after 2030
guys don't worry and then I was like that's what they all
said about Silk Song, too.
They're like, I was like, you can't promise us that.
You just started development.
They said that about Silk Song as well.
Like, quote, retweet me when they delay it again.
If they actually delay Star Wars, the old Republic quote
retweet me and be like, she knew something.
Like,
Yeah, I was like, there's no way you can promise us that.
There's no way you can just start development and then
promise us that it will release, like, before something.
Like, there's no fucking way.
There's no way you would have the schedule down by now.
You just started development.
Yeah.
It's so unrealistic.
Especially when you want a good game.
That's why I'm like, I'm like, you know.
That's why I'm like, what's the word?
Doubting?
Like, what's the other word for doubting?
Um.
What's the word?
Skeptical.
I'm like skeptical about it.
No, I'm skeptical because there's no way you can figure out
the schedule.
When you just started development this year.
Like, how long did they take you to develop Mass Effect?
Okay, how long?
How long?
Especially with Disney!
How long did Mass Effect go in the...
Go in...
Yeah, I'm like, bro, you're working with a Disney IP.
That shit is not gonna fucking...
took about three and okay mass effect one took about three
and a half years to develop i mean i guess 2020 mass effect
one though mass effect one took three years i feel like it
doesn't have as much okay mass effect okay that's building
off the foundation
It was a BioWare Magic thing.
I would say 4 to 5.
I definitely think 4 to 5.
Especially Whatever the scope they are.
Yeah.
Alright.
Here.
Here's something else.
How long has Wolverine been in development?
I think that's a better gauge.
When did they start developing it?
all right my that's a better fit marvel's wolverine game has
been in development since 2020 it's almost 2026
now it's a baby in development since 2020 and it's and we
just got the gameplay trailer
like 21 that's like two years ago dude oh my poor sweet
summer child i think covid took a lot more than your taste
buds did just go like take your fucking brain side like
there was like recent development covid like this with your
fucking memory too we need more people in this stream
together we're getting mugged by all the other teams i can't
join true i'm on youtube i can't yeah i can't request doki
with heart curry but she's on youtube yeah i'm on youtube
right now
sorry guys i can't do so much i can't even yeah i can't even
request you guys are too cool
Yeah, I tried accepting you in Rigsay.
It just does not work.
I don't know what's going on there.
It knows you're European.
I don't know.
No, no.
Wait, it's okay.
We're mocking them on YouTube.
It's okay, since I'm the only one on YouTube.
Hell yeah.
I've cornered the market.
Yeah, it's because of the all the captains i've cornered it
on twitch yeah i've cornered it on youtube yeah they took
all the people with the highest views and what's wrong with
being european i would be in it too with all of us but it's
like yeah they just make it harder because they're like wait
a minute why is this why is there one european guy trying to
join in on the na watch party yeah love that song that's
nothing to do with the other comment but that song was i
didn't know just reminded me of that that song i joined from
what's it called legally blood yes that's the only song i
know the only reason why i know that song was because of the
team fortress to animation i'll show it to you guys i don't
know um is he gay or european team fortress to
Bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump,
bump,
bump.
All right, here you go.
This is the only reason I love this animation.
I'm going to make sure it doesn't play on the stream.
Every friend is in, but I'm not going to let me in.
Nightly swear in shame, my face is gay.
Totally gay.
One clip's at the break.
Sorry for the moment.
I'm out.
but not gay.
No, say no way.
I'm in the room.
And where's perfume?
Is Zelda Maddie finally gay?
No, he's just his socks.
What are we seeing?
Is he gay?
Or European?
I love this.
I love this artist, too.
I remember I used to follow this artist on Team Fortress
too.
Or European.
The letter T.
The gay or European.
Well, hey, don't look at me.
Do your sports.
Gay or Euro.
Voila.
Sure, it'll be weeks.
Yeah, it does have a lot of animations and parodies.
There's another one.
Oh my god.
Does anyone remember?
Okay, this is like old webpages.
comic shit.
From Sunday smirk on every iron murk.
I'm a hetero hetero jerk.
I say no way.
Sorry, it's such a good sign.
listen to it.
Madigalie, Madigalie, Madigalie, gay.
I'm truly gay.
I'm officially gay, gay, Damn it.
See, gay are European?
I think his chest is waxed.
Great lark Be as a squirt We don't miss them, Sonic
Huh Alright, for those who Want to listen to it
Okay, are you around?
The movie and the musical Is both really good I'm not
talking much because I'm listening to Peak right now
Yeah, but that requires a cat You lying bastard.
That's it.
I hope it'll be for you no more.
It will
His man is gay and European.
Whoa
Oh my god, you can be both
Oh, I'm straight you went yesterday.
Whoa He's gay!
He's gay, European!
He's gay!
Oh my god!
Give people gay and European!
There's a- I don't know we will get our game!
I've been waiting just as long as you guys I'm listening to
gay or European.
That's how long I've been waiting for.
Oh, there is definitely gay.
Does anyone remember that rabbit comic back, like the web
comic days, where it's like these rabbit killers?
I don't remember it because they did an Anna, what's called?
with the internet is for poor aim.
Does anyone remember that?
I don't remember the comic series, the web comic series.
I don't know everyone was obsessed with it back in the day.
They're like little, they are, they're shaped like little
rabbits, but they're like killer rabbits.
And one was like, one was blue.
One was a blue rabbit.
That's all I could remember about it.
That was, that's like around the time with the Team Fortress
2.
Is he gay or European?
I wish I could remember, like, what that series was called.
Let's see.
I know where to find it, because it was on DeviantArt.
The Entrant...
God, DeviantArt is just all AI now.
It's really all AI.
I guess I can't...
Oh, my gosh.
Don't have it anymore.
I wish I could remember what it was called.
No, it was, like, this indie shit.
It was, like, this...
artists that made like this web comic series about these
little rabbit like characters and they were like like killer
rabbits I guess I thought I could vaguely remember and I
remember one was like a blue rat one was a blue rabbit with
like metal hands and uh and um and uh it was like and they
did they did an animatic of the internet for porn and that's
how I could that's the only thing I era i've never i watched
happy tree friends once because it was like it's at like
school and then the the boys like pulled it up on the the
school pc's like let's watch happy tree friends now so
confused was it perky rabbit no it was definitely not perky
rabbits killer rabbits i don't even know if they're called
killer rabbits i'm pretty sure it was like some fucking
original species like
I was forced, yeah, I was forced to see it.
And yeah, I think it, I think they had a Newgrounds thing.
I won't be surprised.
No, it was like some indie shit.
This wasn't like an actual mainstream.
It feels like, it feels like something on Newgrounds.
I don't know, I remember seeing it on Thieve in there, not
Newgrounds, though.
Bump, bump, bump, bump, bump.
But, like, I don't think their names are rabbit-related.
I just remember them being, like, rabbit-shaped.
That's all I could remember.
I don't know.
Maybe they deleted everything.
I'm pretty sure they must have deleted everything.
I don't think it's raging rabbits.
It does not sound familiar.
Curly, welcome to a tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Yeah, I remember this song.
I think it's very iconic.
Do you know they added 6-7 in Fortnite?
By the way, I have a Fortnite code.
I should put a Fortnite and buy it.
Whoa, okay, what if I...
You know, fuck it.
I'm waiting anyway.
Like, I'm fucking waiting.
I...
Oh, my God.
I swear if I could only play two games.
I swear to God I Let me Who mentioned it?
Whose fault was it?
Alright Let's boot up Fortnite guys Okay, how long?
I'm waiting to see how long it'll take me to install
Fortnite Oh, not install, sorry, update Fortnite You know I
would never install Fortnite I would never install Fortnite
They go there to the shop.
Oh, God.
It's like three.
Oh, my God.
It's not up there for a day.
Oh, yes.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry to disappoint.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I can.
Is it fucked up if I boot up Overwatch?
I am not sponsored, but I feel like it is like a bit frowned
upon if I boot up Overwatch in the Marvel Rivals tournament.
I might not be like idea.
I don't think they would like that.
Do not, do not boot it up.
I just, because I wanted, guys, you know exactly what emote
I wanted to buy.
I would make, I would not make a purchase.
Um, I have not made a purchase on the, um, on the Overwatch,
uh, Overwatch game in a very long time but there is one
thing i would buy
there is one thing i would buy oh is it a challenge god damn
it's not worth it i would just pay for it i would just pay
for it's not worth it and see it's
i'm so sad it's still 15 i don't want to play i don't want
to warm up with this all right the new bracket is out is it
though okay we're fighting against team melio's team
wait is it a one-day tournament now
wait i'm so confused oh no oh wait i'm so oh my god my
thought my discord crashed wait is this a one-day tournament
now that they fucking i should have been in the meeting i i
should i should have been in the meeting i'm so confused
guys oh my god my discord is like freaking out okay so the
reason why i'm like is this a one day tournament is because
i'm literally i'm i'm so confused i am so
like what is what is this also my oh my god everything's so
i need i can't i can't update fortnite everything is like so
slow right now for me like look at this i am very confused
guys
like so like why are there finals why why are oh man if we
lost we could have just chilled we can i could have been let
go earlier
I'm so confused it's not what the finals are to okay so if
we make it to the finals okay that's good if we make it to
the okay so maybe we just played two games like wait but
what what is the schedule then like should have sabotaged
turkey you messed up
yeah but like so which are we as round oh my god do we just
play one game and that's it no okay we do that and we if we
win that then we go we're out we're done like it's day two
I am so no I'm confused it's okay I will understand I'm but
like what does this mean with this okay so this is what's
confusing me then what the fuck does this mean don't worry
no worry it's gonna show up soon sorry my fort I'm
downloading fortnight right now so it's upgrading I'm
updating fortnight right now so things are taking a while to
load so let then what the fuck does this mean me this
fucking thing mean one two three four okay one one two three
four five I guess like if you count this this is five but
then this goes to i'm so confused i what the fuck does this
mean like okay it means rocket is the best support okay i'll
go ask i'm not gonna ask the team because i think my team
will also start getting confused so i'll be like question I
am Is the tournament Still two days If so What round What
round If so what round Does the two What round goes into the
second game Round
I guess that's why That's why they're not just ripping it
Goes into the second okay there you go
there you go i think i spelled tournament wrong i did i'm so
i'm like i'm confused i because like is round five
considered day two or like because it was round five
considered day two then i played a three matches i mean i
played three matches regardless Because then I'll go to
losers here and then go to set and then I'll either get not
only guy Okay, there is a there's there's hope that I don't
make it to day two
I'm not waiting two more hours, I'm not waiting two hours on
day two guys I I'm not waiting two hours on day two
all right round five okay we'll figure it out i asked my
questions in the little silly the little silly quote i'm the
only one asking questions that worries me that i don't know
if it's like everyone just has their shit together or
they're all just like wait and see let god let let god guide
us like i don't know if i'm maybe apparently i'm the only
that just doesn't know what the fuck is going on or my team
or like everyone else is just that confident like yeah but
even though i missed the meeting i was asking my team i was
like why why are we waiting two hours wait we're not
broadcast and they're like oh apparently we're not broadcast
i was like what the fuck so i waited for no fucking reason
so i'm like you would you would think that my team says
they've been in the meeting they know what the fuck is also
doesn't know what the fuck is going on because they're like,
well, it seems like we're waiting another two hours.
And I'm like, what do you mean we're waiting another two
hours?
No, I know at least two people were in that meeting because
I looked in the VC during that time.
I looked at the VC and I saw two people were there.
At least two people were there.
Wait, other people are playing their game now why aren't we
playing our game what did we play our game i just saw i just
saw a new team ripping a new lobby like excuse me they just
ripped a new lobby like they only had to wait okay they only
had to wait 30 minutes and got in not even they had to they
waited 20 minutes into a new lobby.
What the fuck do you mean they waited 20 minutes?
How long have I been here?
How can I wait 20 minutes?
Excuse me.
This is discrimination.
All right.
Let's give me a sec.
Let me go through real quick all right is she okay i'm just
saying how come they get to wait 20 minutes and i had to
wait i had to wait more than that i i'm trapped in the
fucking boy i've been waiting i've had one game guys we've
been on 11 12 we've been wait a minute i've been live i've
been live for almost four hours and i played one game and
did one 80s run like i am almost about to boot up fortnite
right now like if i'm frozen oh my god cronos has frozen me
oh yeah no i something crashed oh there we go sorry it's
just fortnite updating it's just if i'm if i'm like frozen
it's because cronos it's me they got her what do you mean
they got it they got me it's okay everything will be fine
they just got her no you don't understand i waited three
hours like you don't understand i waited three hours normal
it's not even just a three and a half hours yes
and i haven't oh my god i'm like downward spiraling and i
have a double block later
i don't know we got they're not even we better be on the
broadcast i swear to god we better be broadcast after that I
swear to thank you, God.
The fact, I think, like, it was fine.
I was like, oh, it's fine.
They're just broadcasting every game.
And I find out my game wasn't even broadcasted.
I think that was the worst part when I found that out.
I was like, what do you mean?
You mean I waited an hour and a half just to find out I
wasn't even on the channel?
Like,
it's not like we're waiting for the other team or nothing we
were both waiting
you're on the broadcast on round if we can make it we're
still dark i'm i really hate to break it to you but we are
still on round one we're we're heading to round two like
like unless unless you mean that unless you mean game is
categorized as round four i hope that's what you mean
because because my we are still technically this is our that
would be our second game
no oh my god it's okay everything will be okay all right
guys we We almost got Fortnite.
Oh, we almost got the Fortnite out.
It's okay, guys.
Fortnite's about to start.
About to start.
I read the rules.
I don't know if my Fortnite audio would be fine, though.
We'll see.
We'll see now if Fortnite will be fine.
Save us Fortnite.
Don't worry, Fortnite is booting up, guys.
We're jumping in Fortnite.
I can't, because I'm worried.
I boot up a game in Rivals, and then they're like, where are
you?
And I'm coming for the rig game.
I don't want to be like, because if I leave, I get the
penalty, and I can't get into a fucking custom match.
So it's easier for me to just play Fortnite, or play other
games.
my game is i literally don't know when my game starts we are
giving zero instructions all right let's see oh i need to
fix the the screen for this you can hear the The sick ass
jams though But no no no no no no no no No no no no no Yeah
I don't know If my videos Guys I think my Yeah we're not
getting ad revenue anyway We're definitely not getting ad
revenue now
We're for sure not getting ad revenue now Oh hey Nice close
Um, oh, cool, I got Lego blocks.
Yay!
Alright, it's time for the reason why I'm here.
Oh, wait, Playboy Cardi is in Fortnite now?
Wait.
On this.
Oh, that fuck is going.
Go, March, Crumpit!
What's...
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
let me fix the graphics let me fix this like that's what
we're here for all right let me fix this real quick okay i
need to fix my settings there we go i'm giving the people i
eat me i'm people what i want i'm giving i don't worry guys
i'm giving the the people what they want people i people
guys it's me okay all right keep changes why must we suffer
like this i am people all right it's shopping time do i have
oh wait i cut give me a sec i gotta get some b bucks i'm
gonna put in 30 this is an investment guys all right also
use my epic cash rewards i'm literally like investing in
myself i'm investing right now just you wait my fortnite
account is gonna be so expensive all right by the way okay
guys guys before i guys remember to use my creator code
dokeybird right here see applied it's like right over here
okay it's you go support a creator Alright, where is it?
Oh, wait.
There's Wednesday now.
What's this?
Oh, is that the Wednesday dance?
I don't think that's...
That's not as cool.
What the fuck is this?
There we go.
Doot, doot.
I just want to get people to uninstall.
I think, like, that's, like, the biggest VM you can do right
now.
Because everyone was like, what the fuck do I do when
someone six sevens me like do i just like like find where he
lives and and change his life forever like
it was this all
right this is my limit thanks to keep yeah do i like you
just uninstall on the spot that's why i buy it because i
feel like it's the it's the best like it's the best like
what do i do just kill my in Minecraft when someone six
sevens me like I just I feel like that's why I had to get it
oh look I'm sorry I I bought the skibby toilet before I
before Michael Bay fucking um did a hostile takeover I did
it before I wasn't aware what the fuck is these guys they're
just random Oh my god, wait, Air Jordans.
Well, I can have a chicken follow me.
Okay, but guys, I can have Air...
Okay, this looks sick, though.
Okay, wait, try it on.
Oh my god, Mark, you look...
You look great.
Bro, I mean, like, I feel like everyone needs Air Jordan.
Oh my god, I can't have Saitama.
Oh, I don't like that he's a hologram, though.
I guess because they're like, oh, he's not the real Saitama.
Because then he would have killed everybody.
Okay.
Oh, there's Scooby-Doo.
I think it's weird that Scooby-Doo is like, I don't know.
He's just a man.
What's this?
Wait, that's not the...
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
Okay, that's good.
I don't know.
Or the mystery van.
What's this?
Whoa!
Okay, I feel like I gotta get the run.
I'm grabbing.
I'm grabbing the run.
That's good.
He's six, seven, then run away.
Oh my god.
Wait, I should buy this.
I could have the actual mystery van car.
Do I have enough money?
I'm buying the car.
I don't have a car yet, guys.
I bought a virtual car over a real car.
This, guys, it's an investment, guys.
You don't understand.
I have, I did, I did use it, see?
I bought a virtual car over a fucking real-ass car.
All right.
Oh my god, we already have Crocs.
though it doesn't matter oh my god but then i can have
jiblets on my car oh my god adidas okay oh no it's not as
good i mean okay what what is the marble tint like i think
my normal cracks has been the jiblets the jiblets blend too
much i feel like it blends too much all right we should be
good all right shopping done my little pet okay i gotta look
at my what i'm okay so with my all right i gotta try it out
with mr beast okay mr beast it is red crocs okay i gotta try
this out what is uh okay
okay okay okay who else okay wait uh no wait wait wait wait
It's the little things in life, guys.
It really have a go log off IRL.
It's the little things in life, guys, that bring me joy.
It really is.
Oh, my God.
Now I just got it.
Now the goal is to have to kill one person so I can do this
on them.
Wait, what would be the worst one?
What would be the worst one to use?
I hated Goku.
You think Goku would be the worst one to get 6-7 on?
Or Ninja.
It could be Ninja.
I think it's...
It's either Ninja or Mr. Beast.
Alright, let's see what we can grab.
We just need to grab one kill.
Let's grab...
Let's get into a duo.
Maybe, like, my buddy.
My buddy can help me or Trium maybe maybe I'll get two
people that know how to play All right Maybe I'll get two
people that know how to play video games Mr. Beast is the
worst one really is mr.
Beast worse than ninja.
Okay mr.
Yes, all right mr.
Beast With his crocs too
He's already practically almost there I could gandem style
them after and then after that
We got it.
We got the perfect comp.
Oh, dude.
So let's ask the real thing for a farming I'm getting ready
Mr, please, please give us the rivals match.
It's not my fault They made me wait so lie that i am on
fortnite is it really my fault we know who to blame here i
wouldn't have been led to the i would not have been led to
fortnite if i didn't wait four hours in total it
is the consequences of the organization
being punished though why did you punish us
look he has oh they don't I don't know if that's a try hard
skin I got that okay dynastic badge 94 does not seem like
does not seem like a real person that's what I'm worried
about dynastic Bad cat does not seem like a real cat.
I'm scared.
You does not seem real.
What gave it away?
Maybe he was just born in 94.
Maybe.
There's still hope.
Don't worry.
I'm on my Shenron.
Mr. Beast is here.
To give you a Tesla.
Make sure you're subscribe to him he's coming over oh my god
i'm taking forever to fly down though very slowly it's
getting there all right wait what
okay wait
get over here get over here
it was worth it it was worth it guys you don't understand i
had to
it was 100 worth it all right i did the thing i wanted to do
they practically had nothing look most likely they were bots
okay guys bots so like it's just fine it's not a crime
technically not a crime if you think about it to not commit
no crime there oh god we got money
what is this oh
got corinne too whoa what what shot me Oh, wait, it's
Saitama.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
There we go.
Yeah, I don't think that guy was real either.
Let's grab this over here.
Yay!
Guys, you know what's even worse?
You know they're gonna add that emote, guys.
You know they're gonna add it.
Bravo's all about adding the memes, they're gonna add it
guys just a matter of time you can be in denial all you want
but it's gonna happen
it's just a matter of time
oh i accidentally am muted and discord whoops they must be
like what the is she talking about
yeah but i have to use five I didn't even realize.
Yeah, I accidentally unmuted myself because I have to press
5.
I gotta wait, give me a sec.
I gotta unbind this shit until the game starts.
Okay, keybinds.
There we go.
Hello, dry baller.
Don't worry, Mr. Beast is coming here.
Now the whole chat that knows I'm playing Fortnite.
all right that's fine I was just literally here for one
thing and one thing only
oh get over here no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
no no no I don't care if it's a bot yes I don't care
now they know Oh, you're crying.
God, him.
Bot or real?
No one can escape.
There you go.
Alright.
We're fine.
See, my bot is still alive.
The crocodile is watching me now.
What the fuck do I want micro?
Okay, I don't know if I need, I don't know.
I'm really bad with a sniper in general.
A cord.
I don't know what to do with cord.
I'm full HP so you can take all that.
Here.
I'm a nice person.
I gave him a full shield.
Because I know... What are you doing?
There's nothing here.
The fucking...
Bro, take your goddamn potion.
I don't think he realized this is no build.
You...
think he knows this is no big or maybe he's just no you're
not even real oh my god let me grab this though we are you
real i don't how did he why did he do that i mean why did he
do that he's not even real i don't understand i thought He
wasn't real.
And they almost killed me.
You saw you use an emote.
Wait, what's this?
What is Gold Rush?
What does that even mean?
What abilities do I have?
When I have Gold Rush on.
Wait a minute, this is a marble.
Yeah, I know, right?
Harvesting.
Oh, harvesting gives...
Oh, that's why.
That's why he was harvesting.
I see now.
Oh!
I'm rich!
Let's go.
Okay, now it's gone.
That ever makes sense now.
I was so confused.
Oh.
J-will.
Hello, dry baller.
Oh, these guys are real.
No, these guys are fucking real.
Okay, I'm fucking rowing hog around.
There we go.
All right.
Oh, hey.
Katana.
Yeah, you like my flick there?
That's fucking right.
Wait, is he spectating?
I just...
In case the man is...
That guy was real, but he was pretty bad.
He was real and bad.
All right, let's go pick him up.
Thanks for the gold, buddy.
There we go.
I mean, we could res him.
It's fine.
I'll res my bot.
It's just a...
Oh, my God.
I'm not resing him, guys.
I'm going to a Zorim.
Fuck that shit.
That guy's not even a real person.
Like, he doesn't need it.
This is not how I remember where I was looking.
Yeah, it's crazy.
Rivals got a new update.
Mr. Beast, they added Mr. Beast.
Mr. Beast, I mean, his soul is already sold.
But, like, I guess he sold a portion of his soul to Disney
as well.
So now, now we get Mr. Beast in rival Rivals.
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah, they added a battle royale in Rivals.
What the fuck was that?
You guys heard that, right?
for Mr. Fantastic.
Yeah, this is...
They added a new skin for...
They have, like, content creator collabs now in Rivals.
And they added...
So, you know, you can change your Mr. Fantastic skin and put
it on Mr. Beast.
That's wild.
Rivals truly is beautiful.
Yeah, you can play Ninja Star Lord.
Mr. Beast, that's Mr. Fantastic.
Alright, let's Rizzer.
Let's Rizzer.
You know, if you help me, it'd be faster.
You know, you help me right here.
Speed as Blade.
There we go.
Welcome back, Dynasty Badge.
I don't like that.
What the fuck did it do to me?
Why am I marked?
What the fuck is that?
They marked me.
They put something on me.
What did they put on me?
Guys, what the fuck did they put on me?
Oh, do I have a bounty?
Oh, it expired.
Oh, I guess the guy died.
I think the guy that got my bounty fucking just collapsed, I
guess.
Spider-pig, spider-pig does whatever spider-pig does.
Uh, no, he can't.
He can see.
It's just a pig.
Watch out.
What?
Where are those shots, anyway?
I don't even think I can hit that.
Oh.
Yeah, never mind.
Run.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
I'm marked.
Oh, my God.
He's marking me and I'm...
He's...
Oh, my God.
We marked each other.
What the fuck?
Why you have a bounty on me, bitch?
Okay, now the bounty god.
Okay, he got a car, too.
I'm, like, a little worried right now.
Okay, I hope my guy...
Okay, he's got him.
There we go.
Okay, he, like, ran...
Oh!
Like...
What's the goal here?
Oh, my God.
I should...
No!
I wanted...
I should have just accepted him.
I should have...
I should have just done it.
I was like, what the fuck is he doing?
No, no.
They were not bots.
I got out of car.
I had a car.
Don't worry.
I got the real key.
Whatever his name is.
Where's my Scooby-Doo running?
anyway.
Oh, I have more emotes now.
Oh, they gave me more slots.
That's nice.
Yeah, I have more slots now.
They are.
Wait, I gotta put... Where's the Scooby-Doo run?
Proversal.
Is that the Scooby-Doo run?
Oh, there we go.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
That's so stupid.
Woo, woo, woo!
I'm trying to figure out where is it.
Alright.
My guy...
Oh, my guy dropped off already.
Any update?
I think I would be told if...
If it's my turn yet.
Nobody said anything in Discord.
Oh, Ra-Ra-Ra-Ra-Gy.
We're gonna have to give...
20 Tesla.
today today we have locked we have locked the Scooby-Doo
gang into a closet you think they can get their way out of
the closet before the fire comes in and kills them let's
find out the first person out of the closet gets a Tesla oh
god I'm dead aha oh my god no I'm still dead no don't don't
six seven me bro you're okay okay it's okay i didn't get
emoted on it's okay if i get emoted if i get six seven on we
uninstall we we we like we we leave we uninstall
all right that's fine everybody has is that a playboy card
everyone has wait am i in duos now i thought i selected
trios man trios seems more chill somebody okay guys the
thing is they not only they also have to buy the emo too
okay they gotta buy the emo Oh, hey.
We have Vanoss now.
Yeah, you dare use my own spells against me?
Wee.
Alright.
My guy died.
How?
Wait, he's dead.
Where's his body?
Wait a minute.
Wait.
What?
Where?
Where is this body?
Bro, why did he left?
Is it cause I'm Mr. Beast?
Why did he leave?
Oh god, there's like a whole team there.
He saw Mr. Beast and left.
I missed the Simpsons map, though, by the way.
I think the Simpsons map was so fun.
He knows what foul sins you're about to commit.
I didn't commit them yet.
I still had time before I do crime.
Does anyone know where to play from now?
It was like, what?
I think we're waiting for this last game to be over.
Okay, last game.
Thank you.
All right.
Yeah, but if he died on spawn, I- What the fuck?
How did he die?
Even get to his body!
I'm just...
I'm trash, I guess.
Wait, you can hide in here?
Wait, that's broken as hell.
I think the worst part is for EU players, too.
Yeah.
For EU players, they gotta fucking stay up for so long.
Guys, I might as well just go die, I guess.
Like, what the fuck do I do?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, what is this game?
What the fuck is this game?
Yeah, I know it's crazy.
Not really a fan of the organization style of this.
I would have just, like, if you're not being broadcast, just
fucking...
Just play all the...
Play the games all at once.
Like, stream them all at once.
Like, there's no point.
That's why I'm, like, surprised.
I'm surprised like we did that.
But what is this?
Portabunker.
Oh, Portabunker is good, though.
But I'm gonna this so I can...
I'm going for the fight right now.
Like, I'm going for the fight.
All I have is shotguns, but I'm going for it.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, wait.
This is a bot versus bot fight.
This is it.
This is my time to shine.
5v bot
Don't worry
Don't worry I have to I know he's our bot But you don't
understand This was very important to me
Don't worry
I know like He's not real He's not real But he's real to me
He's real now Where the Fuck Where are they?
Where's the last one?
Is it finally time?
I feel like people are just fucking falling asleep while we
wait.
Wait, do we play now?
I got invited to a lobby, so yeah.
Oh god.
Oh no, please.
I'm six, seven.
This made him real.
He's real now.
Don't worry.
okay there we go wait where's your teammate where's your
teammate where's your bot teammate oh I'm so sad how the
fuck am I gonna do my thing you shoot me wait wait wait you
that means you have a teammate wait oh oh guys I wouldn't
Don't do it.
Okay, that's good timing.
I had to run the swap games anyway.
I had to go.
I had to swap.
It's okay.
I didn't get emoted on.
I was gonna do it too.
I was trying to.
I was trying to do it.
You got what you did.
I was about to pull it.
I knew I was gonna die.
That's why I stood there because I was trying to e-mote.
Oh, I got drove by Batman and Eminem.
I did.
I used to bathroom now, too.
Oh, I had to...
I played in four hours.
This will be my second game.
In four hours.
Holy fuck.
all right give me a sec my my rivals is on my other monitor
right now
insane i know it's actually pretty crazy
i'm just trying to like chill too
all right all right i gotta use the bathroom don't worry i
got you guys while i'm in the bathroom Thank you.
Oh, we're back.
Hello.
I think we're missing Doki only.
Doki, but I am right here.
Cool.
I am back.
All right.
Let's see.
Okay, I'm back.
Let me do this.
I just got back just in time.
All right.
Uh, let me get the key button up.
You guys enjoy the fun show.
The fun little show.
Practically for free.
Usually Venom doesn't do it for free.
But he always me.
But he and I go way back.
So, you know.
He and I go way back guys.
Alright, their team is incredibly stacked.
What the fuck?
This team is very stacked.
Wait a minute.
They were waiting for me?
Oh.
They were?
I just got back.
Were they?
What are they asking?
No one is talking.
talking.
I can't just be like, hey guys, nobody's talking.
Oh, okay, they're just checking in.
Well, I'm here.
Also, that chicken nuggets did not sit well with me.
I think that I think I remember why I haven't had chicken
nuggets in a long time.
I'm already in here.
I don't think I have to say hi if I'm already in.
It was not okay.
I think they have the most stacked team in general.
I mean, they also have a Spider-Man one trick, too.
What the fuck?
Yeah, they were bad Nuggies.
Those were some bad Nuggies.
They literally have...
Let's see.
They have Guru.
This is not...
That's not Tim the Tabman.
That's Guru.
They have Guru, Crimson, Melio.
Their pros are...
Well, their pros are Melio and Crimson.
But...
really good spider-man um and drew is a really good tank
player kg is a really good support player and jimbo is also
a good support player too their team is pretty good like on
paper yeah i would say day would be is a better spider-man
than zeal due to like i've seen him like in high you though
all the time well not now but like spider-man's not in the
meta to be fair spider-man isn't meta i will say
no it's weird if i just said hi guys it'd be weird it's
about social cues guys no i don't even know if it's the last
game of the day let me look i did make my message and no
Okay, round six onwards is...
Alright, which is round six?
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
Day two is round...
Okay, day two is round six.
So...
Ha ha.
I didn't say it!
We are on round four.
We're on round four.
It's not Tim.
It's Guru.
That's not Tim.
Tim gave Guru like a hundred subs to put him so that he
would look like he's on top 500.
I mean, that's smart.
That's free advertising for him and Guru.
That's free money for him.
But it says Tim.
Guys, I know identity theft is a serious problem.
It is a very big problem.
Yeah.
People just do that?
Lie on the internet?
I know, right?
That's fucked up.
I will say their DPS lineup is stronger than our DPS lineup
because they literally have a pro player.
Melly's a really good DPS player.
I mean, they know I'm here.
I'm literally in the lobby.
I'm in the lobby.
Where else can I be?
Oh,
yeah, bro.
That's true.
I do have Ryan Goslin.
Are we waiting on something?
Or?
Yeah.
They're in lobby.
Are we waiting on the broadcast?
I think it's the broadcast.
Maybe they're just yapping, you know?
doing commentary okay no they're having a break all right
see i said something guys what are we thinking of fans for
this team by the way oh they're definitely listening so yeah
is is he behind your door i mean milia is pretty good at
everything and they is like a flex kind of i think i think
he's yeah i think he won he doesn't even he doesn't even
care about spider-man i feel like i don't know if you
watched yeah yeah i think maybe yeah rockets good too like
maybe hella rocket my social interaction yeah first ban
hella in my opinion i don't have to worry about bats i'm
just sure and then ban rocket doesn't doesn't don't they
play daredevil don't think so i don't think they'll play
daredevil didn't really play it i don't know the because the
other team didn't bat it i think yeah i don't think this
team plays daredevil um okay okay yeah hella rocket ban and
like really it's anything for the third that we'd want okay
we'll figure it out his group but that does go yeah they do
protect they do protect groups to be fair yeah i think i
think the rocket is more important personally yeah yeah
everyone good luck yeah yeah if we go inside my pocket you
players and do my first fan hell or rocket first then uh i
think we can get hell if you want yeah all right oh did oh
the side face team lost oh i feel so bad for side face team
yeah but they they feel so bad for side face they were the
ones banning their double wasn't he wait wasn't he in the
boker bash and all right and he was on i'm falling asleep
man it was on the booger bash right did he make it the day
two they did not play in their double at all there was a
game where they didn't even ban it on both teams and neither
team played it oh yeah yeah no i meant like the last the
last booger bash oh no they got third place okay yeah he got
out and loki quick that's it feels bad yeah no they're out
melee was best at like scale site-based team is pulled out
yeah i think we can we can just do the hella the hella ben
that's unfortunate i don't want to stop on that cough drop i
don't remember kent took on candy right now i was like i was
like okay to be fair they did ban spiderman every single map
so i don't know if he even wants to play that uh yeah but
they're full out now yeah we should lucky them their weight
is over this is like one of the better spider-man maps uh if
we do get the opportunity to bennett that one map with like
the full wait who won versus who won it's so annoying uh
people always get put off the side there um necros versus j3
who lost necros or j3 oh i know what to do i see who's still
streaming necros i mean we could we could take the gamble if
you want necros is oh wait are you playing in there spidey
first and then hello oh they are they're rocket second
they're playing now Or we can just secure the hella and then
get Spidey last a bit.
Oh, wait, J3.
No, we can just do the hella.
All right.
Yeah, I'm just thinking out loud.
Yeah.
If they lost, they're out.
They're out out.
This also is a very good hella map.
So.
Oh, no, J3.
Yeah, I'm going to say that doesn't make sense because I
literally see him streaming.
No, J3.
Yeah, J3 is in rank now.
He's in rank.
Oh, for most.
i feel bad for mocha you can stall out phoenix maybe i feel
bad for mocha because mocha i think since we're banning
hello you can probably just play starlord mocha didn't have
good luck with the boker bash as well because like they lost
every game to be honest phoenix lucky and star lord just
play those that's like a very sad outcome whatever you guys
want to do yeah
gail yeah you're going to broadcast uh what's that you're
going to broadcast for an interview oh it's interview tab uh
hold on wait like interview so you want me to to broadcast
like uh they're gonna drive you i'm just informing you but
you're going to go both their pros are two support players
so that's like a huge fucking gambler like the supports can
you know there's so much a support player can do they're the
only team with two support players as their picks too i
don't know if you guys realize this but fucking rogue box
headshots with her fist it's like everyone has their friend
doing yeah yeah just popping in here quickly as gail yeah by
any chance just want to prep the prep you for an interview
if that's how it is yeah sure sure i'm just gonna move you
down to the channel ready for the interview all right after
moxie you're going up with milia all right as a pre-game I
appreciate it.
Sorry for interrupting.
Yeah, we have to wait for the interview now.
That was so much nicer.
The other guy came in and said, okay, you're doing an
interview.
This guy was nice.
The last guy's Greek.
Give him a break.
Oh, damn.
European dragons, is this true?
I mean, one one sounded British, and I guess the other one's
Greek.
Oh man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, what time is it for you right now?
Team Captain.
Do you like Roguelite games?
I highly recommend Mortalson.
The file boss has only been killed.
That's never finishing that game.
Oh, wow.
For me, it's almost 10, man.
It's about...
It's okay, man.
It's like two more hours at most, I think.
It's okay.
You can do it.
Wow.
It's doing nothing for so long, makes it pass.
When's the schedule for tomorrow?
Do you guys know when we start?
Yeah, it's on the Excel file.
I don't know if you opened it.
But it says the first match of tomorrow starts at 1215 ESD.
I don't know what that is in the EU for you guys.
I'll check.
I think tomorrow is losers bucket now.
Yeah, tomorrow is losers and grand finals.
Oh.
yeah so it's five and then until 350 esd so what's that like
four hours six hours ahead yeah yeah yeah that's fine yeah
so like nine nine fifty it's the latest game so it's
probably gonna start even earlier because these games seem
to go by fast i'll put it it's just how long we have to wait
this for a game of these yeah i mean this one was scheduled
for for five but i swear we've been waiting since like 4 30
if not earlier yeah yeah oh it's been much much longer yeah
much longer since the game started like since the game
finished the one before us oh maybe not maybe just 4 30.
yeah i think i think it's 4 30 or something like that i was
watching it
I'm gonna see what Gail says.
He's a PR guy.
He's free.
Gail is in.
Nice.
Is there a delay on the broadcast or no?
Very little.
No delay.
That's very little.
Oh, no delay.
Zero delay.
I think there's zero delay.
Phil what I've seen.
He's close to zero.
Sorry, I did this to Sue.
associate guys but I'm just I had to disassociate this has
been almost five hours I I was not in the vtuber tournament
this the tournament was five hours but I I swear I felt I
I'm pretty sure I played like seven games already at the
five hour mark I was on game number seven it's the five hour
mark for this tournament and I'm on game number two right
now I'm fucking losing it right now I'm fucking losing it
This tournament could have been an email.
What?
Oh.
It'll be fine.
It's just, I think, like, I hope it would be fine if, like,
after this tournament, I'm piecing out.
But I still, my day doesn't end.
after this tournament.
I thought I could take a nap.
I thought I could take a nap after this tournament.
Oh my god, there is no nap time.
No, I'm not good.
I just realized I don't even get a nap time.
I go straight.
I go straight to the maid cafe.
Countdown.
No naps will last.
I thought I could have nap time in between the third event.
It's okay.
Since it's okay, it's okay.
Eventually, if I keep telling myself it's okay, it will
eventually be okay.
Oh.
What kind of asking for, Ellie?
ready oh yeah oh thank god i'm ready i just got down with
the interview all right let's get it guys okay we're locked
up we are too locked i was done reviewing oh it went well
went very well he showed the perfect dominance that's right
that's right i ordered him to swap the joke you feel it's
for the rest of this we gotta make sure we make it happen no
losing my god damn coffee mug yes i believe so okay you're
right you're so right guys okay ambit first spin i'm
considering that gotcha before the cafe please consider
thank you for this oh uh maybe by the time you wake up from
your snap i'd be on my third game are we going to be on one
of your back first was it star but by that time we'll have
our third game that's fair but yeah i think you just do star
lord or phoenix yeah i think so either i like the phoenix i
like the phoenix a lot low key yeah because like i don't
think the star lord is like that valuable if they're That's
being generous.
That's mostly what I play it for.
There is another game after this.
There is...
Do you guys want to ban it?
Rockets or Groot?
What would you rather ban?
I think Groot.
I think Groot also.
Yeah.
That's so exciting to think you'd have a third game in about
three hours.
Honestly, take a nap after this, wake up in four hours, and
then do your third game.
I don't have four hours.
Yeah, we get rid of Groot.
I have two hours left.
Let's talk about it.
You could do Loki.
They already protected so you can play Loki and Aura.
I literally have two hours left at this tournament.
I'm done with that.
Said Loki?
It's because like, I don't know.
They just wanted every match to be streamed, but it wasn't
even...
They just wanted every match to not go simultaneously so
that people will have to all focus their attention on one
stream while the matches are going on.
Sounds good.
I don't mind.
That's fine.
But then my match wasn't streamed.
That was the worst part.
For the numbers.
Interesting.
That is very interesting.
Alright, Rocket it is.
they're protected in this but banged angela oh okay that's
gonna be i don't know yeah i don't know i was not expecting
that one no i go in this here what do i play yeah probably
yeah we do both play it i guess but karen still plays it too
i don't know i saw this guru yeah that's a crazy man thank
you okay i like star i also think i'm not the coach here i
exist as a person hawkeye can be good on this map too if you
wanted to just start yeah i was thinking i was trying to
yeah i'm thinking my hawkeye it up yeah just think of the
spider into hawkeye yeah think of the the fact that you got
to play spider-man here probably don't worry yeah maybe
bucky could also be a good option to stop it see i saw me
mute on you this is the spider-man map i was talking about
by the way i'm a sad character like don't worry at the
monopoly on the youtube stream of the rivals
sure i'm sorry if i'm complaining a lot about the tournament
but this is like i'm sorry but Let's fuck with me.
We can start left side.
I had a limit.
We shouldn't go to point committed.
It's already gone.
They're dipping.
Yeah.
We can break the walls.
I'm gonna push in three, two, one.
Rogue is right here.
Rogue is stability.
Spider-Man's going in soon.
Turn.
I'm grabbing the rogue in three, two, one.
Grab and grope.
In this one.
Rogue one.
Rooks are one Rooks are one.
Rooks are one.
I'm on their strange one.
You're Spider-Man on us.
Strangest one.
I'm gonna drop him.
Drop him play under with me.
I'm on Envis.
I'm with you.
You're good.
Nice job.
Nice.
Good job.
Any care.
Okay, I got you.
I'm on Mega.
Can you stop?
Can we push her together?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'm on it.
I'm with you, Rigsie.
Be proud of what you did here.
I'm behind her side.
I'm opening up this map.
Yeah, babe.
Shield to kill her.
Oh, he's one.
I don't think we chased them.
Last time.
I'm sorry.
They're playing full dive.
He's going to flank with Phoenix stun.
Yeah, yeah.
So check this out.
Screw the left side.
The Spider-Man's going to come from there too, maybe.
Okay, I'll just play further back with you guys.
Yeah.
Yeah, they're probably all going.
They're probably all going.
I'm going to meet them.
I have both.
I'm going under, okay?
I grabbed there's two.
Can we look soon?
Penum is coming over to us.
Rogue one.
I pulled their rogue again.
Invis one.
I don't know.
The road.
Rogue one, Rogue one on me.
Spider-Man looking for full fight time.
Caradocchi!
That's okay.
I pulled him back.
Spider-Low, Spider-Low, Spider-Low.
Spider dead, Spider-Dead.
I'm looking for Venom 1.
If you can help me.
Venom 1, Venom 1.
Where are you?
Oh.
I think I went to Spare Chief.
I'm okay.
You can show.
There's someone above us.
Yeah, it's Phoenix.
I'm grabbing the road.
I've gotten in this area.
I need help Benovic.
That's it.
We're good.
I need help main.
I'm trying.
I got you.
Thank you.
I'm walking point.
I'm looking for Rollins over.
I'm gonna just walk them.
There's two after this.
Three, two, one.
Okay.
My health's over.
Care Venom all here.
Care Venom damage.
I'm tired.
I got it.
I'm bad.
Good job.
Good one.
One, one, one, one.
We don't have support.
I'm grabbing Luna.
Can we kill Luna?
Our freezer?
Yeah.
they have sue spider-man yeah they're outside and they're on
cap house yeah they have the rogue old as well i think we go
early with our uh hawk eye old maybe i think we have to yeah
yeah just set on point i think we can wait for them to come
point oh okay we walk they're going under two of them under
two of them under they're just waiting the side yeah yeah oh
it's the sue it's the sue cap can die i don't know i don't
know i'm marking i'm on sue i'm on sue i'm on sue right now
i'm gonna grab sue right grab sue yeah he's looking for
spider-man on On me, on me, on me.
I need help Mane if you can.
I'm there on point.
I'm only a sprite.
We can reset.
You guys can catch back.
Just reset.
Trying to help you.
That was three ults for them.
Can I help you?
Stop them.
You can get out.
I need care though.
Got one.
Don't go too fast.
We're two coming back.
The Starboard is above us.
Starboard has all.
Yeah, I see, I see it.
Can we come back top?
Come back top.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, come back top.
We can fight on.
I'm gonna try and copy Luna if I can.
Yeah, they have Starlight.
By these left, by these left.
I'm grabbing a Rouge.
I don't, I can't get it.
I copy, I copy.
I grab their, grab their cab.
I'm on the one.
Thank you.
I'm pulling them in, I'm pulling them in.
I'm gonna off this.
I pulled out Spider-Man.
Watch Spider-Man.
Spider-Man doesn't have.
He doesn't have used.
Yeah.
I'm not gonna point.
Star's left side.
Star's left.
Cap is off on point.
Yeah, I'm helping you on point.
Cap's on us.
I have, Cap's on, Cap and Spider-Man on us.
I need help.
He's one in fire one drop, I drop.
I need help one point two.
Any help?
I need one.
We dropped, we dropped, yeah.
When we do then, Spyder went.
We can still win.
It's not over.
Yeah, we have Hucket holster.
I think you guys have played a clear, played a clear,
they're diving, then we can go.
I have all here.
Back up, back up, Captain!
Back up, Captain, back up!
Holding.
Yeah, we can walk on point.
Do you have or so?
Yeah, okay, okay.
Just wait it out.
Spider be in, spider be in.
Go to the spider be in.
Go to the spider.
I'm going to try and find you.
The other dudes.
Can we walk?
Yeah, we can walk.
We can walk.
We can die.
Rock and die.
I have to.
I have to die there.
I'm a spider.
Spider one.
I pulled him.
I pulled cap.
Cap's gonna have hopefully soon.
We need to go cap.
Yeah, I'm looking.
I'm looking.
He's one in one.
Cap one.
Starlord load.
We can hit him.
He's like a fly.
I pulled him.
Starlord behind one HP.
He's still one.
Nice.
Good stuff.
They use Spider at the end.
They're gonna have cap star Luna, cap star Luna.
Okay, I can go cap in my ult maybe.
Okay.
I think I need to...
I need to copy Luna here.
I mean, team captain can combo to kill the supports.
Yeah, Luna.
You can play...
Yeah, you can play it safe, Arra.
We have... we have Mago too, for pure.
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't use our ult every time, don't worry.
It's okay.
It don't happen to have any superpowers.
Why is everyone diving?
I'm glad you're safe.
I just want to nod at the couple.
So I'm just gonna use my open grabbing.
It's just dive, dive, dive.
Yeah, I like that.
They don't have TP.
We could also TP on top of them if we really wanted to.
Nah, I think we played safe.
I think we played safe.
I think we played safe, to be honest.
It would be, it would be girl who could be, but yeah.
I can go through mid.
I'll look for Spidey if I see.
Mm-hmm.
Watch pull from right side.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
Path left.
Oh, he's right side.
He has right side.
He's in the door.
Yeah, he's looking.
I was going behind with all.
I need to play behind.
They don't have Luna anymore.
Honus now.
Honus.
Oh, I am.
We can walk.
Walk the point.
I pulled Luna.
Oh, it's Mantis.
Yeah.
Nice.
I'm looking Cap.
I am looking Cap.
Cap is on Cap.
Cap's old.
I'm strong.
Don't have him.
I'm shooting Star Wars.
I have two people on me.
I'm watching you.
I'm in one second.
You can he play under with me?
Yeah, I'm right.
He's in there.
I'm gonna go.
He's one.
I can still die.
That's Mensis hold.
Oh, you're that under.
Oh, sorry.
I want to kill this side.
I think I'm going to use...
Hmm.
I can't get volleyed from him.
The other couple.
Yeah, my bad.
I regret so on.
It's just tragic.
I won't.
They're gonna have Spider-Man.
Mantis only?
No, they're gonna have Spider-Man.
No, they use Mantis.
They have Sue.
Yeah, they use them.
Okay, okay.
Sue Cap.
They have Sue Cap.
Close Spider.
Okay, okay.
Unless they use...
Yeah, we can go left.
Yeah, that's okay.
Yeah.
Let's go left.
Care them going early.
We need to make our suit.
Come with you guys.
I'm staying with you.
Maybe buddy stun.
Care them.
Care them going early, Doki.
I'll grab their cap.
Nancy.
Oh.
I think we just got wiped there.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's okay.
They're just gonna stuff like that every time.
We have to be ready.
Let our tanks walk and take space.
And bait them, I think.
A poultry showing.
I think we walk left again.
Okay, okay.
Starr's playing really early.
Starr's one.
Oh, well here.
I'm trying to catch.
I got the Starr Lord.
He's half HP right now.
Yeah.
I'm pulling this.
We have Sue if we need.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm pulling Capp.
Sargon behind.
Rogue is bottom left.
I'm walking on Capp.
Spider-Man and Starr Lord on us.
Yeah, I'm with you.
Capp is going back.
Capp's on us now too.
Fire one, fire one.
I'm watching.
You're good.
We're a trade over trade You want versus trade over here
Mantis I'm grabbing cap three two one.
Star main star main.
I demo star lord on top of us.
Star lord.
I need the bell p1 Charlotte one I'm my old I'll do Oh my
god Mantis low mantis low.
I'm on mantis.
Mantis down Robe one row one row glow row glow.
I have a spider-man army I'm a spider, spider one.
Nice.
Spider-Man is up.
Invis.
And there's one point.
Run, there's one.
Good job.
They have Mantis.
I think we gotta do something funky here.
Yeah, you guys have to try to dive with me.
Can you live, Doki?
I'm...
Let's try to find their backline and then just dive them.
Yeah, I can go.
okay i'm looking i'm looking ready three two one mantis
mantis one i grabbed the rogue look at rogue look at rogue
look at rogue inside of us guys guys have hp have hp that's
a robo yeah i think i have another spidey i think we need to
keep stuffing and just save our cooldowns for the spidey
yeah yeah yeah okay they're gonna have cap up here soon DPS
lets we can combo with our Phoenix roll.
We break all the caps that have HP.
Watch Spider-Man pull off map.
I'm looking for grab main.
Okay, okay, okay.
I backed you.
That's a map.
We back, we back.
I'm gonna die.
No, no, I cannot.
I've solid after this.
I don't think we live.
I'm gonna die at a point.
Do we get TP or no?
I don't think we have time.
Do you think so?
Oh my gosh.
Maybe we do.
Spider-Man may hook me though.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm getting hooked.
I'm going back to bubble you.
Oh, wow.
Fuck you.
No worries.
It's all good.
I think with this...
I don't know.
It's like...
Obviously, they're playing.
It's like hard.
Fuck our backline.
But you just go Bucky.
You want it to?
Yeah.
I'll try it.
I actually don't know.
Okay, I'm going to go captain America.
I kind of want to do what they're doing and just play to
like not really have a backline, right?
Like...
Let's do this.
Sparman's going to play for Othma and Pooks like 24-17.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
We just play together.
It's way harder for them, I think.
Yeah.
We're not allowed to go triple, right?
No, you can't.
Oh, no triple support.
They actually add triple support.
What the fuck counters that?
Yeah.
This is just a normal Tuesday.
I'll make my ult faster.
They have Spadio, right?
I'll try to set my guard.
They're going close.
I land.
I'm really close to my ult.
I'm grabbing.
Oh, well.
Look at Rogue.
Rogue is Spadio.
Rogue is one.
My ult's over in three.
Play out of it.
I don't have all.
Yeah, you just have the chip.
I don't have a lot yet.
88.
I go black one after all.
Yeah, yeah.
We should touch point.
We can.
I can touch after you.
I can't see you.
Cap is low.
I got out.
I need care.
This one.
Rogue one.
We're even.
Playing our main.
Playing our main dokey.
I ammo.
One killer one.
I should save that.
Hey, where is Swigoo?
They have the rogue, they have Spider-Man, they have Mantis.
Okay, I'll hold this way.
Yeah.
I'll look to grab Spidey if I see him.
Yeah, they're all top left.
Okay.
I'm dead.
I'm pod, I'm pod, I'm pod, I'm pod, I'm pod, I'm pod.
oh grabbing cap cap is half Wait i can't walk i can't walk
there's a spider-man on me in our spawn and i can't go
anywhere How do you want to try one we can win we can play
slow we don't support sure now Okay star i'm on the
backliner now i'm looking rogues i'm back can die rogues can
die rogues can die rogues can die rogues can die Spider-man
on your i'm watching you do a game I'm okay.
We're good.
Spider one.
Oh, wow.
I have a...
No.
We're down the boat.
Just chill.
No, it's not.
We don't have DPS.
Spons.
They're gonna push into us.
They could kite.
Their spawns are coming back.
Yeah, I got...
I got...
I got grappled.
Sponeman, top right.
I'm playing the Mantis.
Mantis have.
Rogue is low.
We're done one still.
Just wait.
She's almost back.
I'm back.
We're here.
Rogue is going in soon.
I'm grabbing Rogue.
I copy it.
Push, push, push, push, push.
I want you guys.
I'm playing on it.
Back one, back one, back one, back one.
Back one, back one.
With you, with you.
Mantis one, Mantis one.
Three, two, one.
Mantis one.
Mantis the one still.
Clear point, clear point, clear point.
Mantis still low.
And this.
I'm trying to save it for Starlorn.
Yeah I'm trying, I'm trying.
Do you need cap?
Do you have Starlorn on?
Cap is one.
Followed Love.
Look in Rogue.
Look at him.
Rogue is one.
Rogue is one still.
Rogue one.
Still have Starlorn on it.
Getting the craziest pocket.
Nice.
I'm not like you.
Who do they have?
Star, Spider...
I don't know, yeah.
We're gonna try to force...
Mantis, Star, Spider, Mantis, I think?
I think we have to go with Cap, no?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cap first?
Okay.
Yeah, we should go first and try.
They're going top.
They're going top, we should go soon.
Spider, go after the kill.
I'm ready, I'm ready.
Yeah, they're bottom.
I have Mantis.
I'm top, I'm top, I'm top.
Hello?
I'm ready, I'm ready, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
I'm using, I'm using.
Oh my god.
I got there's two under Mantis.
I'm under Mantis right now.
Mantis assault.
This is 95.
I'm ulting after this and I can't.
Menthus 1, Menthus 1, Menthus 1, Menthus 1.
Oh, I couldn't.
He took my ult.
He took my ult charge.
We're TPing.
We're TPing back.
I can't.
He's one.
Rogue one.
Rogue is still one.
Rogue is solo.
We have to jump.
Nice.
I'm through him.
Cap is one too.
Cap is one.
Their supports are coming back.
Your first you're personal.
Okay.
We can trap your first Xin.
Um, yeah, they use zoom, they use.
They have mantas.
They have mantas and gz Sue.
That's what they have.
I need to not die.
Annual close to close captain to.
I think they're trying to kill their other support.
Okay.
I'm in missing ends.
Look at Sue.
Yeah, yeah.
They're all looking.
Right now, right.
No, see.
She's on.
She's spitting.
Animal.
I'm happy, sir.
Oh shit.
We can win, we can win.
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on.
We have one support.
One, one, one.
They're jumping me.
Both supports that.
I'm going back.
Oh, I can't swap.
It's okay, can win, can win, can win, can win, can win.
If we play for touches, we have two people coming back.
Done?
No.
I'm sorry.
think they have a support or i thought we would just kill
them it's okay it's okay it's okay worries that's close what
do you guys think though do you want to let the spider-man
or no uh we could yeah i hate that i'm down to ban it
honestly had 21 finals kind of crazy that's not fun i don't
even know what to do i think i'm not gonna lie he was doing
nothing until they went mantis i think the mantis is just
enabling their dive more right i mean yeah yeah probably
just can't do triple the only way to count is just get rid
of the get rid of the spider-man and doesn't matter if they
play mantis focus both of us both the loki and me i agree
okay they have to be like hyper focused i have to heal and
also be the thing is i have to play in front of our it's
just it's just my fault we would have won that map if i
copied the correct thing i just wanted to try and win the
fight there because i didn't think they had a suo it's just
my bad it's okay oh perfecto maybe deadpool i need to be
down or die it's just my bad maybe in maybe deadpool would
be yeah i waited three hours for this i waited three hours
to play against dive
i'm not talking much because i don't need a talk i literally
just have to exist yeah they know now that the spider-man's
valuable so they're probably gonna protect it first yeah the
dps copy was intelligent doing that but i actually saved it
wrong wrong alt uh who did they protect last time it was alt
tracking just protected invis first the alt tracking yep
which is good for us i think yeah like i had to up there
yeah they're protecting spider-man
second you see we got in midtown we just own these guys in
midtown they want to stay they love sponholding so i don't
know if you want to go sponhold map but it's up to you we
can do it back to if you want you can only play through
support yeah yeah Yeah, I don't think Spinal will be too
good.
Yeah, I think we do Midtown.
Everyone agree?
Yeah, I'm done.
I think we are better on Midtown.
Oh, I'm good.
All right.
No, they're pressuring me too much, bro.
Yeah, yeah, he will just come with me.
I was watching their other map where they were spawn
holding.
They were spawn holding with, like, Penny, Rocket, Moon
Knight.
If they do that, I think we just play Torch Ultron.
Yeah.
Could.
Do you think I was playing Ultron?
I would be playing this.
i have to be super hyper focused too because like well we
can't trip i have to do back and forth really hard we can
play it's like i have to look in the front for my tank and i
can look behind my loki i can punish oh it's really hard
doing the the back and forth i think i think it's first span
spidey like loki has to be behind me the loki is behind me
and and then i play in front of my loki you can probably
leave hella open if you want so i don't know if you're
comfortable with I'm fine with leaving it open honestly And
if he's gonna play midnight I can just ban that too Honestly
No I don't want to ban midnight I have to be constantly
aware of the back I feel like we can We could not ban rocket
if you want But the moment I turn around Like my front line
guys I just ban something else Do you want to change
anything up?
I think Why do we have to Why did we play it Both Spider-Man
players Back to back Protect how this is yeah i don't know i
think we probably just ban that guy's rocket i think there's
supports for like yeah they can't play hila no more as well
i feel like if you if you proc fucking or they proc hila you
can proc no more they can't play it yeah real true
interesting okay yeah i think cal no more is actually cheat
code to being this team too yeah yeah i can pop up i can
hang up
and then i have to fucking and then they can my ult too
which sucks because i got my ult forced out like twice too
i was so surprised we didn't find spider-man because like
day spider-man is scarier than uh it's scarier than zeal's
spider-man i'm so out of it i'm so out of it right now
Oh, no, my God.
We're at the five-hour mark.
I, like, lose my...
Like, I lose my...
The momentum, too.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Okay, defense first.
I'm disassociating for a bit.
Oh, I should have played Hades.
in between yes if I played Hades in between maybe there was
a chance that was much which one do we want that was where I
fucked up I don't know it doesn't really matter for us to be
honest like I feel like we can do like anything we want
you're just a Loki again or a tank or a DPS I know no more
maybe I like Loki.
I think if anything, it would just be like one of your other
DPSs that you would like to have open and maybe like, I
don't know if a tank is even good to be honest, I don't even
think they would ban tanks, but yeah.
Probably just DPS or Loki.
Are we defense first?
Yeah, we are.
Yeah.
We've been rocket second, I think, again.
Isn't good insane at this point?
Phoenix, I'm banning Rocket.
Or, yeah, Groot is good.
It's Rocket or Groot?
What do you think?
No, no.
Ban Groot.
I actually like the option for us to play in Rocket as well.
Okay.
Sorry.
I can protect Amore here.
Yeah.
Okay.
I think you do.
And then if they want to ban Hella no more, they have to ban
their own Hella.
Sure.
And then for third ban...
Quite a lot we can do.
Oh, said we want our rocket open.
I could just ban...
Okay, the protective midnight.
I figured.
I'm partial to a penny, Ben, if we want.
I'm down for that.
I'm also down.
I'm actually...
Penny is actually really good.
Yeah, I'm down.
Probably rogue.
So it's going to hit the rogue.
Yeah, yeah, that's true.
I'll ban penny, though.
Okay, nice.
They had to ban their own hullo.
nice good oh my god are we ready okay they're gonna play
some form of like half dive with side are we ready yeah are
we are we here i think i start over again oh i am not a good
punisher and see what happens just not entirely good into
midnight but
on rocket yeah they're gonna play cap sigh dive with rocket
um stars open as well if you want the star team up don't go
into the light dokey i think we do this dokey you might have
to play invids a lot okay they're gonna try and like fuck
you oh yeah cool 30 seconds before you attack get ready
So this is going to be me and Doki probably getting fuck
simulator and my DPS popping off simulator, okay?
Sounds good.
Yay.
Alright, here we go.
Oh!
Why is this the better?
I fucking leave, I leave, I leave, I leave.
Oh, fuck!
It's okay.
Rogus okay
I'm gonna go man ready He's grabbed he's grabbed look at him
look at him three two one.
We need a fight close then Yeah, I'm walking I'm walking on
Hawkeye Hawkeye low Hawkeye low Rogus pull then There's a oh
Rogus trolling Rogus trolling fight together fight together
I can book them up three two one Hawkeye low That's diamond.
I can hold the point.
Don't be afraid here, don't be afraid.
Yeah, I'm calling point.
I'm holding point.
We need to brawl them.
I'm grabbing someone.
Look up Rogue on me.
Rogue on me!
Rogue is out, Rogue is out.
Rogue is out.
Ninety on my own.
Okay, okay, I'll...
I will, like, inside one of the rooms, okay?
Okay, okay.
I can bet you three, two, one.
I'm pulling Kauffman.
One, one, one, one.
Let me try this one.
We're not even going to hold it.
Can we break it?
Can we break that?
I need fuel.
I got grabbed.
I'm res.
You get res.
We're even, so.
Yeah, we're even.
I'm grabbing someone.
I'm grabbing Hawkeye.
Look at their ammo.
I got damage.
I don't have shoes anymore.
We have better.
Okay, okay.
We're pushing him.
I'm pushing him.
I'm under Sue.
Sue's having spades.
Two one, two one, two one.
Two one, two one.
Look at that one.
There's that.
There's the TKs are behind us.
He was blind.
I got pulled.
I got my neckline.
They're okay.
I thought.
Yeah, the DPS was behind us.
I'm living.
And I can legit live.
We kill road friends.
Oh, I'm on HP.
I'm on HP.
Just chill, chill, chill.
They're gonna bash.
We can walk my own.
It's okay.
They put it in the water.
I died.
I'm behind.
Oh hell.
I got a kill.
We have punish roll.
Besides one, she lives.
We could probably just wait for a rock at all here.
They have Moon Knight or again.
Yes, but I'm in a bad spot, okay?
Okay.
Are you...
Yeah, I can touch maybe.
Yeah, I can touch.
I can touch.
I'll be touched.
3, 2, 1.
I'm touching.
Look at the rogue.
The rogue is in.
I'm trying to help her punish her right now.
Anika, Anika.
Where are you?
I want the pillar.
I want to see you.
I want Munda in.
Ruh, Munda, Munda won a point.
I have to reload.
I'm dead here.
I'm dead.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Touch, touch, touch.
I'm TP, I'm TP.
She's half, she's half, she's half.
She's low, she's low, she's low.
I'm sorry.
She's full HP now.
I'm done.
Lead, back in spawn.
I'm almost back.
I'm through, I'm through, I'm through.
I'm done, I'm done.
I got siloed.
Siloed can die.
Oh, I got hit by that.
Siloed one.
Dead.
I think we need to try and kill them on this more.
She's just taking angles.
Yeah, I agree.
You guys are already probably dash on that.
Do it now.
Okay.
They use both tank.
Sigh.
They're gonna have Moon Knight and both support, I think.
Okay, I can probably even my ult.
We can go fast off of that, maybe.
If they go fast, we can just sky with our spoo.
We can push them back.
and I can stop right.
Sai is on the left.
I'm going to walk main.
I'm walking main.
Three, two, one.
I got the room.
Come out.
I'm trying to.
I'm all three.
We have better.
I'm backing.
I'm going point.
They're all turning back for me.
Yeah, we're trying to.
I'm just going to die point.
Yeah, just like, I'll die point too.
Don't be afraid to lag.
their old as soon as they use something like that.
Um...
I don't know if they use that.
You just have to go first.
They use, uh...
Sue and Monet.
They'll have a lot.
I can walk with our, uh...
I'm using my own.
Three, two, one.
Matus, Matus.
She's running, wait, wait, wait, one!
I'm touching, I'm touching, I'm touching.
I should be fair.
I can walk up for this.
Go rogue, go rogue.
One.
I'm one.
I'm one too.
Help me with the backline.
I don't have shield.
I don't have bubble.
Stay on, stay on, stay on.
I'm good.
I'm a MLA.
Emma dies.
Nice.
Good job.
Nice, nice.
Okay, that was Sai Moon Knight.
They have both handcuffs.
They use Rope.
Okay, okay.
I'm a Moon Knight and...
I'll use my GoPro ammo.
Someone behind.
It's the silot, I think.
Siler, siler, yeah.
Yeah, she's here.
She's over there.
Bottom right.
I can come with you, girl.
She peeks.
Hey, I'm gonna wait here on this corner when they push.
Yeah, we need to stop them.
Yeah, hold them close.
Help captain.
I'm gonna grab the rogue.
Hey, Babelby, Babel.
I'm pulling him in.
Are you guys chilling?
No, I need, I need, I need.
Okay.
Okay, I hope corner.
I'm living, I'm living.
Try it out.
I hope corner, I hope corner.
It's about their kite.
They're done.
Okay, i'm 87.
We can walk a little bit.
Just poke them.
Pop them.
Yeah, back up.
Back up.
98.
Trying to pull them.
Rographers.
Ro eve.
I'm still Rogue.
I still Rogue.
She's dead.
You get rez.
That's okay.
I'm on school.
I'm on the suit.
We killed them.
Mantis.
Mantis, mream, Mantis.
I'm camping.o.
I'm dead.
I'm trying to live.
Okay.
Oh, I got out of that.
I don't know if I can see.
I'm low HP.
I'm really low.
I'm leaving.
Can you TP back maybe, team captain?
Yeah, I can try.
I'm touching.
I'm dead.
Moonet flying?
Oh, what?
I'm going to see Moonet here.
If I can get it off, I'm with you on the head.
Oh, Moonet's low.
I'm on HP.
I'm on the diamond point.
Yeah, TP.
We're TPing.
Stay on, stay on, stay on, stay on, stay on.
No, no, no.
Someone has to jump.
Just go back, go back.
my bad do you want me to match the mantis just try it i
think it'd be good yes yeah just damage respawners and talk
yeah yo let's just talk about our dives whenever you can go
rick see true i'll just push with you okay we can just go
front line when you push back when oh just let me know when
you're ready they have three tanks right now we should go
i'm looking i'm looking i'm looking strange stop yeah
everyone can you go can you walk can you walk three two one
i'm stealing someone I can counter I can counter all he's on
me Nice, thank you.
I can't help you possible.
Yeah, I can't I can't he's trying to help her Trying to live
Really close to my heart looking strange strange this old
thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, strange.
Strange.
Yeah, yeah, strange stuff right.
Walk up walk up.
Yes, yes I hear you.
I'm clearing him.
I can go back whenever you're ready Go back, go back, go
back, go back.
I'm gonna see what's the one, two, one, two, one.
I got it but I might die from it.
Yeah, I'm dead from it.
We still point, we still point.
We got point, we got point still.
Yeah.
I'm gonna fight.
We have Mago.
We can get maybe Scylla here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh, they use Monnet at the end.
Yeah.
Trinity's holding gold.
I'm gonna smack this though.
Okay, I'm gonna go backline.
Are you ready?
Only two.
Three, two, one.
I'm on backline.
Yeah, I'm with you.
Don't see nine, don't see nine, don't see nine, don't see
nine.
Okay, I'm on it now.
I've got up.
Living, living, living.
I got their strength.
Oh, there's Roke.
He met me.
I'm walking, I'm walking, I'm walking, I'm walking.
I'm walking, I'm walking.
I'm only him.
I'm only him, I'm only him.
Right side of the park for you.
I'm back, I'm back.
Strange dies on point.
Strange one, strange one.
I'm living.
He's one.
Yeah, yeah.
He does.
ADM out.
We need to go Sue.
Can we go Sue?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
She's one.
I'm on Rogue.
Rogue, Rogue, Rogue, Rogue, Rogue.
Rogue, Rogue, Rogue, Rogue.
I held back one or I held back one or.
He was just...
Ah.
I can absorb after.
Three, two, one.
I got Rogue.
How do you explain this, guys?
I'm locking back.
I'm locking back in three.
I got two.
Rogue one.
What one?
CURME.
CURME main.
CURME main, main, main.
Look at MMI, MMI, MMI.
MMI, MMI, MMI.
They have no supports.
Start, start, start.
He's gone.
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, if we're going to play this comp, we just need to talk
about our dives like a lot more and we'll just win
automatically.
They have like such a weak back-line to avoid our hits.
Yeah, I think so too.
Yeah.
If you guys can tell me when you're able to go, even if it's
like not on the supports, just fighting their DPS, I can
just immediately go on backline or frontline and then you
guys have an easier time 1v1ing and we would just win i
think yeah i think we just need to play faster than they are
because they just take the space and then they're like
that's what the moonlight wants we can just play first yeah
i agree we got this let's go yeah yeah yeah i think our
offense would be good i'm gonna ask to play racket next game
i'm legit just playing to larry res your guys just dives and
give you balls i don't think i can survive another so far
that I know you guys like my balls okay okay I don't think
I'm gonna die I meant to it's not strong enough okay they
might they might play three tanks here if they're on Three
tanks, we can just surround them and go back.
Yeah, you can go three tanks.
Four, three, two, one, come.
Come!
What they can do.
I'm gonna go under.
Yeah, I'm gonna go under.
Let me know what you guys see.
I see MMA.
The triple tank, yeah.
I can go backland.
They're bottom left, just let me know.
They have bucky as well.
I'm ready.
Are you ready?
I'll go.
Yeah, yeah, I'm gonna end it.
They're on me, they're on me.
I have everybody on me.
I'm living, I'm living.
I'm dead.
I'm done.
Wait, Rogue half HP.
Watch.
I'm getting MF sword.
I miss.
MS have HP.
MF can go.
I can go backline again whenever you're with me.
Bucky no hurt.
Yeah, yeah.
Bucky.
I'm ready whenever.
Let me know, Rixie.
Okay, I'm going.
Three, two, one.
I'm on Bucky.
Bucky one, Bucky one, Bucky one, Bucky one, one.
I'm on HP.
I can see you there.
It's fine, yeah.
I'm out, I'm out, I'm out.
Okay, I'm living.
Roke can die, Roke.
Roke can go.
I pulled him back a little.
I'm going again, ready?
I'm done.
I'm back here.
Three, two, one.
You have.
I'm chilling.
I'm getting Magmobo.
Okay.
I have one now.
They're gonna have support.
Oh my god.
You guys.
Just wait, just wait, just wait.
We should go with Bongo.
We can kill through maybe.
I need help.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh.
Can't help you guys.
I'm gonna hold like all their backline, okay?
Yeah, I'm setting up to go backline.
You guys go?
Ready, ready?
Yeah, going now.
Yeah Push.
Three, two, one.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Rogue is stunned on the right hand.
Bucky won.
He's got to empathize.
I'm nice of it.
Rogue on bike lane.
She's over.
Yeah, Rogue is behind.
We should walk.
I'm going back then again.
I pulled her a little bit.
Oh, I can't- I'm going in.
Shooting, shooting, shooting.
Shooting Road.
Swimming.
Ha!
Amen!
rogue, rogue, rogue.
Rogue one!
Got him.
Rogue one, rogue one.
The eram is stressing.
Just keep walking me in.
Look at the smag.
Oh my gosh.
Back him inside.
He's running two.
Becky one.
Becky much.
Okay!
Yeah.
Bucky.
Bucky Bucky, Bucky, bucky.
He's done.
He died.
Emma, Emma, Emma.
Emma dies.
Bucky, balk, walk, walk, walk.
I bought you a smag a little.
I won.
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Rocket, rocket, rocket.
They might TP back.
Yeah.
Maybe they're not.
He is.
He is Mago.
I don't know if he TVs.
No TV.
Yeah, they only have mag.
We didn't go fast with silo.
We should.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sure.
They don't have any score.
You guys should go really fast.
Yeah.
I'm here.
Build all.
Let me know, Rixie.
I'm gonna go from left side.
Three, two, one.
Oh my.
I got, I got grab.
I got you.
I'm leaving.
I'm living.
I'm dead.
Rogue dies.
Can he help me?
I'm under Sue.
Sue is low on me.
I have to be invisible.
I can all up to this.
Really close to my out.
Really close.
We can kill through.
Where are you shooting?
I'm looking.
Rocket one.
I'm living.
Rogue is rolling.
Rogue.
I got their I'm TPing behind them.
Okay, okay.
I'm pulling their Bucky in.
Bucky in, Bucky in, Bucky in.
They're walking back at me.
Walk it back, walk it back.
We're walking, we're walking.
I'm 85 to my ult.
I can go soon.
We almost have our Sewell too.
Yeah.
Be patient.
I don't have it.
I'm 97.
I'm 96.
We have it.
I'm walking with my ult.
Everything, everything, everything.
Just walk with me, walk with me.
Oh
That's so hopefully we could get space Yeah That's a little
tank is crazy there zero two two I don't know why we didn't
go triple tank healers.
I feel like if they're not going to allow triple support,
they shouldn't allow triple tank.
Yeah, I agree with that.
I don't know.
It was hard because there were so many.
All good.
I either had to heal tanks or my DPS.
It's kind of like, it's kind of fucked up how they can play
die.
And sorry, I'm echoing really bad.
they can they can play dive and then we can't play triple
support to deny the dive but then we have to ban out dive
and then they can just play triple ping like that doesn't
make sense mm-hmm i agree uh i think we do go to losers
right yeah we do yeah we do yeah like two or three matches i
mean i said that before too yeah i was gonna say like what
the do we do against that would be bad out triple support
sounds good well there was nothing we could do because like
hour it says 6 30.
can we ask to do it earlier it because mrc is it's not yeah
i mean it's not even broadcasted yeah i agree yeah
apparently you can't see triple i was gonna say please don't
i'm just surprised we didn't go we didn't go like also if
they are gonna play triple tank i don't think we play um i
don't think we can play dive deep yes yeah i don't think
that makes sense i think yeah i think we just play like
storm pine or something yeah sure i'm surprised we stuck
with that i think it's gonna i get the one denim or cap okay
i don't know if that would been better they just go for bad
coin we could have probably committed to that i think if
we're gonna stay that dps lineup probably but i i agree with
our i think they said we're funny storm yeah i said they're
uh making the lobby we're doing it earlier so thank god okay
nice guys thank god thank god thank god they're making the
lobby now because it's not broadcast thank the lords
because they didn't think I don't know I guess they thought
that not a lot the teams were gonna play dive you know dive
is meta and this team perfectly select like this team is
very stacked and they also selected all the players that
play heavy dive nobody here really plays dive this team we
have i we all the dive characters we have what is starlord
and and sad lucky i think i'm tired now i'm actually so
tired you don't have to think too much yeah this is like
three tanks a lot of damage made it's that simple i feel
like i feel like they should just make two two two they
should just wear two two two if they're just gonna bad
triple support might as every fucking triple whatever
no every game every game drains my life force every hour
drains me I thought I could take a nap right up because I
had to wake up at fucking 8 30 in the morning I had to wake
up at 8 30 guys it's 2 42 I thought I could have nap time
before the cafe.
No, I don't know.
I don't know.
If we get knocked out, it would be a shame if we get knocked
out.
Okay, so Moxie's team said that their players were told 6.30
EST, so he doesn't know to be able to get back on, but he's
trying.
So either they get back on Or they get back on early Because
or the tournament has to find me a sub Because they promised
me the tournament would end before 4 So The only issue is
Necros just went offline I have to Wait is that on Check out
at 4 No, Necros is it for you Doki It's like 243 And I have
to for sure because I have a contract obligation at four and
they told me that it'll end by four I think it will it's
just this one match surely they can just get on and play it
I gave them 30 I gave 430, but I'm taking it back.
I'm taking the fourth fourth.
I'm taking the 30 minutes back If I didn't have to wait this
long I would have given this that 30 minutes but i'm taking
it back now i'm leaving at four i'm giving them the original
plan yeah ban for legendary not that was my original deal
like it's flexible yeah i gave it yeah like i so if we go in
there like legendary is gonna shut down a firm's revoked i
just didn't think it would be a back-to-back wait
yeah that's just being generous like I've like I agreed for
four we made a deal that is four yeah to buy to a new lobby
okay Vendor D is like a Hulk main yeah he's on yeah and he's
on rogue yeah technically not clocking out early guys it's
not clocking out early because the original plan was for it
was today during the stream i tried to be nice but then like
it's gone she's gone now she's dead i'm dead inside the doki
originally there is god no they don't what the around goslin
removed me they did last map playing oh really she's she's
out of her she said she played the other match yeah she said
she can play no woofos is in she's not in oh oh there you go
never mind yeah I think woofos been playing yeah
this is a 9 to 5 the thing is I have overtime after the
thing is I don't get paid to be here compared to the main
cafe yeah maybe That's the only thing.
I'll get paid to be at the big cafe.
I'll get paid to be here.
Yeah, you're well done, nice shit.
I think, yeah, we need, like, Moon Knight or Storm Pond or
something.
You're right.
It's my second job.
Well, because it's like...
And then I probably should have been low-key, like, as soon
as we are on, like, front to back like that.
Yeah.
That's okay.
We learned.
It's such a cheat.
Yep.
Got it.
going forward they don't have spider-man play at least i
think not allow autofun luna to be replaced with fun are we
are we playing the moxie team yeah i think so there's a new
lobby to get you all in here they uh they were playing like
ultron mantis like with widow when i saw them they're
playing like super pocket dps run around i don't know if i
want to get coffee is coffee okay for your after tooth
extraction widow widow yeah that guy's kind of crazy at
widow i can't lie honestly i might be a mantis ban ingle
because i think mantis is what enables all of that weird
stuff yeah probably like ban hella first then ban mantis
next i think that's actually ideal
do they have a daredevil player uh tarot can play it but he
doesn't like playing it yeah i don't think tarot play it
strategize i'm just i'm like the mascot they called me in
and i just poof in it's like when animations it's like it's
like i swear there's the hell look through their background
assets and we're like we need background characters and he
just pulled me out of the background folder sorry terra and
all right the scene is about to start we gotta fill up this
scene i'm getting information that let them all they were
playing torch let them all do the strategizing yeah that's
pretty crazy we bought an ultron definitely pain killer was
supposed to be for my tooth but i guess this is for my head
now the skin killers from my head down yeah we don't
impeller yeah it's the same person i'm losing it the longer
we wait and i'm not in the lobby the longer i'm gonna freak
out slow the game down fan like mantis i think it was six
hours a back-to-back i don't i don't but if i'm on my six
game six or seven game on my six hour that'd be fine the
fact that i'm on my third i'm waiting for my third game like
i that is yeah he does he plays everything i think that's
where my brain is gone i'm waiting for my third game to be
like i don't want to play this and he won't play it during
the almost six hours
yeah this is only the third game I played the second game we
lost what a game too Cal, you have a super chat thank you,
thank you
it's just poor organization like what can you do it's just
the poor like if it's this is their first tournament they
organized i'd understand ideally they just want like they
just want to funnel all the numbers into one channel that's
that's playing i'm still annoyed that we can't play triple
support
not bad no this is gonna be our third game like uh 50 50.
and then when i found out the first team was not even
brought in that's that's where it broke me that's where it
fucking broke me
no i no i just it changes the game so much my friends is
also like yeah you sure you're gonna you should my manager
sure you should do this i was like it'll be fun it'll be fun
they still definitely be over before then
I mean, not instant, but it's definitely not bad.
I think it's good because they only have two sports behind
them.
They just get reloaded.
It goes until 9pm.
I haven't.
I mean, I had my chicken nuggies, but like that doesn't feel
like it counts.
Honestly, let me check.
It's a long day.
That's why I'm saying it is a really long day for me.
No, I'm not doing this again.
I'm not double booking.
I'm not scheduling a stream and an event at the same time.
I have an event at that time.
I'm fucking, it's that's event day.
I can't do this again.
I can't.
strong enough
yeah lessons were learned I learned my lesson today yeah
sorry 9 30 most likely at 10 it ends at 10 because we went
overtime for yesterday so I'm most likely it'll end at 10
don't worry guys I'll get I might actually have to get
coffee yeah I never had a tournament this fucking delayed
before she
learned no i will i learned this step i learned this step
i'm sorry if it feels like i'm complaining too much i'm
actually so fried right now i just just i just don't like
waiting so long in between games i just i'm sorry guys can
you really blame me i really don't like waiting this
I also said yes because I saw the names in this tournament.
I was like, oh, hey, it's all like, you know, a ton of, you
know, big content creators and pros.
It should be, it should be fine.
You know, you would think it'd be more, like, like, because
they were saying it's going to be like Vogue or Bash.
And I didn't, I was invited for Vogue or Bash.
So I was like, oh, it's going to be like Vogue or Bash
because apparently that was very smoothly read.
the same people from Bougar Bash, but I don't think, now I
don't think, now I don't think it's the same people as
Bougar Bash.
What are you organizers?
I don't know.
It's the European group.
Yeah.
It's, it's, it's officially sponsored by NetE slash Rivals.
It's officially sponsored by them.
Um, but uh uh but it's you know like they're usually hands
off marvel rivals is usually hands off when it comes to
organization of uh tournaments that's why you see a lot of
tournaments that are like all over like you remember the one
i fucking subbed in for the daredevil tournament that i
subbed in for it oh my god that one was a mess
I think it is that the same people for that.
I'm not sure.
It might be the same people.
Hey, make sure you guys are in the new lobby, by the way.
Yeah, I'm going to be missing three.
Oh.
You got an invite?
Yeah.
See, you have to leave that previous lobby that you're in.
I'm in the I'm in my own thing I'm in the main menu Oh word
Let's see if that works Yay Nice That was so weird It was
like bug Like the invite was like hauled out I had to like
right clicky Huh I think Rigsie is half The Rigsie here Wait
what my streamer did The phone Yeah Oh shit.
Classic Twitch.
I just F my stream.
There's not a drop of life in AIG.
There's no more.
I think so.
Yeah, there is.
There's no more life in me.
They siphoned it out.
Every dive they did.
I age 10 years.
I'm literally on my deathbed right now.
Nope.
Get back.
Um, surely.
There's nothing inside me anymore.
I'm stead inside the doki that started the stream.
They got her.
The least dramatic doki.
Just a dry husk of a woman.
the tomato is get the tomatoes riding it's gone now it's
just the skin suit left it's only the skin what's going on
uh potentially they got him too sure one tournament change
the trajectory imagine he's back soon like what the fuck is
this team one above all one above all Celestio one above all
one above all one above all just just type GG's and I'll
head out can I get a one above all substitution can I
this is for substitute me with a one above all play i'll
just like ggs and then i i don't come back like i just
booked i i just turned off stream so shark thank you for the
10 gifts and chips thank you thank you yeah ggs and dip
this has to be the longest i've ever waited this oh yeah i
just played rogue that's what's happened oh this is
definitely the longest i've ever waited like i've actually
here's money to cheer me up and i've had like thank you
thank you i really appreciate it six games where people
throw because i'm on the character this is actually a new
record or i won't give it i would have played at least five
games in apex or then i would go against cypher or cooper
playing triple supports yeah i would have had like five or
six matches
yeah no it's just legit so all the time there's like the the
two people that push for top one just triple supports and if
you don't match it gg unless you have like yeah an entire
good lobby which never happens so gg oh this is basically it
can i just take oh i'm playing against gambit mantis okay
every guys this is a win-win yeah if we win that's cool you
can batting progress we get more money if we lose and people
will still don't have to play day two yeah it's just depends
on the win-win for everyone it's so bad i mean the ultra
yeah just made it worse this patch so yeah so true i don't
even win more money lose i'm free at this point.
It's a win-win.
Not close at all.
Oh, okay.
I'm like close to captain, I think.
Yeah, I'm like close to captain.
But it's so hard to make progress on this character.
She used to stream at least 12 hours straight or rank Apex
in the past.
But the thing is, when I stream 12 hours of Apex, there's no
two hour in between waiting for games.
That's the issue.
I didn't have to wait.
wait.
I queue up.
I have to wait at most 10 minutes and then I get to play.
Are we out here?
They're all screen ready.
Yeah.
You win all the waiting would be worth it.
Do you get bodied by Melio's team again?
Come on, guys.
That's so hot with you.
Yeah, let me download some fucking PC controller program
real quick.
I'm ordering coffee after this, or I'm going downstairs to
get coffee.
Oh!
No, I just think it's so, like, they don't give us a time
frame, too.
When our matches start, I think our captain asked, like, oh,
when's our next match?
And then they weren't even given the time.
frame like the schedule is behind schedule who who would
have thought
not sure coffee is good after two if guys I have nothing
there's nothing else I can do no skin your
dragoons I don't know how you're stronger than me dragoons
you're stronger than me
so I'm just associating right now if I stop talking You know
why.
Stop talking.
You know why.
Are
we still R?
They're asking.
R.
Yes, we get to play.
Yay.
Literally.
30 minutes early.
Thank goodness.
Yeah.
Did we play another game?
I don't remember.
This is the last one.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
All right.
You know that's fucked.
Hello, first band.
You know that.
So you're just like, thank God.
I don't know.
Oh, fuck.
I think we've been that guy's hell.
I think Color is better for us.
Montes.
i think i was i had tears coming i think yeah i think
definitely we still i could actually see the light at the
end of the tunnel joy i was like so it's over no matter
maybe i want gambit um i want gambit yeah yeah i think so
they might properly yeah they might pocket to be fair with
ufus i don't think i've oh that's true They do have a gambit
player, huh?
Okay.
Yeah, they do have a...
I think it's fine.
I think we can mirror their gambit.
I think it's favored for us.
I think we ban Loki.
I think Loki is definitely banned.
Ironically, you don't think you protect DPS instead?
I don't think they even want to ban Gams.
That's up to you.
Yeah, we can.
We can protect.
Go, go, go.
Alright, I've attacked Starland.
That works.
Um, I think we ban...
I always drink ice coffee.
Or caffeine, that's ice.
Because I don't think they're going to ban him.
gonna ban gambit moxie plays loki i don't want to give them
gambit loki that's fine yeah god she's still going i'm
getting ready for my second job guys after this
you can just do another dps or you're gonna tank if you want
i think it's always i just woke up or support over oh wow
okay oh wow my play will trump he got to sleep not jealous
at all yeah not jealous at all huh
could protect yeah phoenix i'm guessing
yeah i'd say phoenix if they protect rocket that sounds good
to me Don't worry, we just woke up.
This is my third game.
Mantis.
Yeah.
Yeah, Mantis.
This is my third game.
Okay.
I'm ready.
Third game!
Yeah, you got it, buddy!
You didn't miss much, yeah.
You didn't miss much around in third game.
that's what they're doing i gotta go punch into that i think
i got angela i can confess both
uh so i think it's i think it's luna doki it could also be
the luna ultra um depending on like what we're doing i'll
try to rock it
i gotta be on rocky right now i'm really tired Okay, okay.
Welcome to the club.
I have a full day of work today.
I think I'm gonna...
I'll try on at the start.
Maybe...
Sure.
Get ready.
No, Luna!
I'm too tired, guys.
No, you don't understand.
I'm too tired to play Luna.
I...
I'm actually...
I'm way too tired.
Yeah, I just played Marco and we just played his game.
We'll jump him down.
We're just playing off of...
Off of captain.
And then we just play off of captain scoops.
Yeah, exactly.
I'll try this, but in my spot.
I don't want to give them outside either.
I'm here.
They're in groups.
I'm going...
Yeah.
I'm gonna avoid the Greech.
Yeah, I'm going point.
I'm not letting Greech start up.
Nels, not dodge.
Sar, Sar, Sar, Sar, Sar, Sar, one.
I need to kill him.
Rook and die, Rook and die.
Look at this.
Three, two, one.
Don't flank him.
Look at Rook, look at Rook.
Look at Rook.
Shooting King, left out.
Their Groot is back.
One.
I'll reload.
I have to reload.
I'll fight him points.
I need help on point.
Oh wow.
Oh.
Good one, good one, good one, good one.
I'm gonna swap.
Okay.
Keybinds aren't right.
Cover for you guys.
Let's surround him.
Let's start broken up.
Yeah, can we walk one side?
Can we?
Yeah, I'm walking with you.
I'm taking left and three, two, one.
Taking left.
I want him back on again.
I'm going to open.
I'm going to go in Gherds.
Ha, oh, but they have a good 12.
R2, good one, good one.
We'll market all here.
Open one.
Rojas have.
Did we break it?
Did I break it?
Did they break it?
Oh, yeah.
Come.
Good swing.
It's men.
We still have Phoenix.
I'll say we have one more.
One, one, one, one, one, one.
Stunt.
He's one.
He's out.
They swapped by the way.
Off group.
Yeah, they're an Angela.
I'm here.
Do I just hold it until they Phoenix ult or just pray that
we shoot it?
You can put it where they put it.
All right, goodbye.
I grabbed them, I grabbed them.
I got the ult off.
I'm alting their back when I got two scores.
Coming with you.
Phoenix round.
Star one, star one, star one.
Coming back.
Shocking my res.
I'm with you.
My res is at point.
Phoenix is on.
Angel can die.
When we do them, Andrew, how?
He is okay.
Yeah, we're good.
We're good.
We won.
Alright.
I'm done, by the way.
I'm not there.
That's okay.
We can play on point.
We're still, we're still down one guys.
Just wait.
Almost back on.
Can we, can we play outside?
I'm gonna play outside.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna get them outside.
I'm on point, I'm on point.
I'm gonna look for a steal soon.
I'm looking for a steal on right side.
Three, two, one.
Look at Angela.
I got Charlotte.
I got Charlotte's out.
Charlotte's out.
I'm on this one.
I can touch you.
I'm touching.
I can kill Rocky.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Rocky died.
I'm gonna die soon.
It's quite a bit.
We have a lot of holes.
Yeah, they used Angela Ultra.
Things are gonna be different this time.
You can get our Ultron and then if I don't point them,
they're taking too much space when they shouldn't be able
to.
I mean, they were taking space while you were coming back
and then they have holes.
Okay.
Oh, there's a starter too.
Oh, I have to get rid of that.
Yeah, I have.
I'm ready whenever a captain.
I'm walking on points.
I'm fighting Roach.
I'm okay.
Roach is half.
I need care.
Can you, can you, can you, can you?
I'm trying.
I'm rising.
I can't give to you, but I'm sure you.
Roach is one, Roach is one.
I'm looking for Steel.
I got Phoenix.
Phoenix, South.
Storm on me, Val.
I got you.
I'm gonna ult him.
Oh, he's okay.
Shoot it, shoot it!
Oh.
Ultron can die.
I'm going for Rafa now.
He's resting.
Trying to help.
I'm on point still.
I'm gonna die soon.
Yeah, I'm dead.
No, I'm dead.
Oh, I'm dead.
Oh, you're down, yeah.
Please Starlord, it feels like it's hard for us to be
versatile without it.
Like where we can go and stuff.
Because I'm always like gonna anchor man.
It seems like I just get like all these angles.
I'm a good guy.
You know, Starlord's just flanking with drones perfectly.
Yeah.
I can't really do anything against them personally.
I think we just need to kill their Ultron.
That's unlucky.
Ultron can barely get you very lucky.
I didn't put it out the moment that we put it at the same
time.
He's always low.
I don't have an angle on this.
No, my mental is just why I'm on Raffia.
I was like, I cannot play it right now.
Or Ultra.
Ultra is way too much brainpower.
Like, it's way too much work.
They're going to have Voltron a lot sooner or sooner soon.
Is that it?
Do you think?
No, they have others.
I don't know.
I'm not really locked in.
They're good.
I think they have start too.
I'll leave those support.
Yeah.
Right here, Angela.
Angela won.
The shoulder is right side.
They have two right side.
Yeah, I'm with you.
Nice.
Phoenix is top left.
Phoenix top left.
with Star Out, okay?
Yeah, they're setting up right side.
I'm going under Star Lord.
I'm on the Out Run.
Yeah, look, they're that.
With you.
Out Run 1.
Dead.
I'm on for Rokion.
Oh, Pippin.
I'm so off on Rokion.
I'm on for Rokion.
Rokin should die.
Okay.
Sorry, one, sorry.
Tawin, Tawin.
He gets Res.
On the open point.
Yeah, I'm not sure.
There's no Res.
Can we kill Rokin?
Rokin die.
Oh, my God.
Rokin.
There's a starlight behind us.
Angela, one draw one.
Star behind, star behind.
He's right here.
I'm with you and starlight.
You guys up.
He'll keep in.
Wait, he's left then.
One.
Nice.
Hold on one.
They still have the revolution.
I might out here.
I want to go early.
I want to go early in the open.
Can we get ready?
How early?
I'm setting up close.
Like, like...
Like, close.
Before choke.
The rockets, man.
Ready, ready?
I'm ready.
Rocket can die.
I'm gonna rocket.
Rocket's done.
Half HP.
Rocket's half.
Rocket's low.
No res, by the way.
I don't have a bar.
Okay, I'm backing.
I saw a little here soon.
We have bongo and DPS out soon.
92.
I can chuck the rest.
We have bongo soon.
Are you able to get it?
We got it.
You're gonna...
I'm on point, I'm on point, I'm on point, I'm on point.
I'm on point, I'm on point.
I tried, I can't.
Can we shoot something?
I'm dead.
They just had their rocket on the clock.
It's okay, they still out.
Star, maybe can die.
Star one, star one.
Star one.
They have star, Angela.
You can die.
Rogue.
Yeah.
I think a quick fight.
I can try and stall the rogue from going in.
I can't really stop anyone else, so.
If I get something, I'll look for it.
Well,
let's have Angela too.
We can play still until we get it.
I'll patch you up.
I'll just go in top.
They're playing on points.
They're beating us on.
Rogue is on.
I don't have my raise out.
Citing.
One star?
Yeah.
No way to go now.
Oh my god.
ADMI up.
Phoenix one Phoenix one
I can't live I don't think Oh, shit.
Okay, I shouldn't do all that I'll just wait till his run is
there no they bad mag They bad We have one more fight fight.
Began, Cumberland went.
We need to be able to kill him.
Let's go back.
Let's walk to main together.
Yes, sir.
I'm walking through main, come, come.
Whoa.
I'm sitting up over Angela.
I'm being tired of it.
Angela, one.
I'm down there, Angelou.
Angelou, how?
There's no cellar.
What is going in?
I'm on the road.
They're pushing me.
They're pushing me out.
I have to look for you.
I'm trying to look for you.
I need to go.
I need to go on there.
I put it in the corner.
Angela low.
Can we shoot that?
They don't rock it all.
Got it.
Phoenix one.
Angela one.
Should have Phoenix all.
They have special or all.
Yeah, that is so.
We need to make sure we play inside.
Everything is mine.
Yeah, we have to make a play.
It's okay.
I mean, we can beat them in the open for kill, so...
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Can you drum me here?
Okay.
Yeah, you have.
Oh, I'm on star.
I'm on star.
I'm looking Angela right now.
Angela's south, bottom right.
Oh my god.
Angela's dead.
Nice.
And she's red.
She's red.
Rogan, Rogan.
I'm with you.
Trying to help.
I will go as soon as they drop that one.
I just have looking for one.
One star.
One star, one star.
I'm on HP!
Fuck.
There's a res coming up.
Touching point.
Eunix one, twix one.
Yeah, welcome.
Brenix me.
I'm dead.
Oh my god.
Roku can die.
Moku can yo.
Thank you so much.
One left.
Someone might need a TP.
I'm on the altrun.
I can't touch them, I can't touch.
Whelp supports looking.
Oh, he's got me.
He's got me.
I'm on point.
I can't hide.
He's so one.
I'm on point.
I can't do anything else.
I can't touch.
I vote.
I'm okay.
You heal me?
Angelus South.
They can beat back.
I almost have up.
I can keep anchoring for a bit.
I'm getting...
I got a shield.
I'm on Ultron 1.
I can set a point for a bit.
I don't know if that portal is gonna...
I'm killing Rose Beacon.
I'm res.
I'm on point.
I need P1 player.
Can we touch?
Yeah, I'm touching.
I'm gonna die.
I have touch.
Oh, we were so close.
So close.
So hard.
Yeah, it's tough.
Like, I'm just getting marked in headshot by Phoenix the
whole fucking batch.
It's hard for me to...
do my job there one more game one more game guys we'll be
free but it's all good one more game just see this yeah
beatable honestly one thing that one thing that you can do
better for me guys you can ask for when you want damage
boost and speed boost yeah that's all I can do yeah one more
game yeah we could have do that it's okay what did they
first been we can just program this next game it's okay i
don't think yeah true they first been i don't think that's
gonna solve it no i don't think that's gonna make a
difference um i think the problem is that tarot just gets to
run around on star and we don't have anything to stop it um
i'm sure yeah i mean it was it was hard it was Phoenix is
just hitting every like left click on me and she has a lot
of damage you can you could leave like hello open if you
wanted to have more options yeah I think so that's what I
was saying like I think Helen no more is actually better for
us what what map do we want any favorable ones anyone's in
mind we could do like you just sell yeah probably you could
surely probably i'm not gonna lie unless you guys have
something in mind for what you guys want to play
no i'm showing
yay yeah well it's because their brain is active and mine
isn't
That's the reason.
Yeah, it's just people would be less tired if the matches go
by faster.
But it's because there's too many intermissions.
So you cool down, like in between.
You cool down in between.
So there's like, there's just way too many intermissions.
Way too many long intermissions.
Yeah, so people are just tired.
Like, I'm usually more fun.
It was just like, pop, pop, pop, pop.
Like, maybe a 20 minute wait.
I can wait 20 or 30 minutes, but, like, I can't wait this
long.
Yeah, the momentum's lost now.
I mean, she's still on.
Yeah!
That's me!
I definitely have a slight headache, though.
From this.
No, you are absolutely losing me.
I think I just...
It's just too much.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
i can't even laugh anymore i well except for that one part
but okay so what are we this is no longer a funny situation
this is no longer funny we could first ban hella again i
think because i kind of play hawkeye in this map i think i
could be like danos um I think Heliband first.
I think Ultron banned second, honestly.
Not gonna lie.
No, I...
Unless you want to do something different.
I mean, we can see, but like, I'm more worried about Mantis
than Ultron.
Yeah, he's gonna be with this map.
True.
But we can just see.
This is a crazy weird map.
Yeah.
That's fine then.
Could be a Mantis.
We'll see what they're doing.
Do you guys want to first pro- We'll stop going in for fan
funds, actually, and soon.
Yeah, it is.
Yeah, that is like...
Because they get like legendary on DPS instead, and that's
like tier 2 DPS, tier 2 support player, right?
So it's kind of fucking cooked.
Yeah.
It's like they got an extra power player.
Yeah, legendary on support was like 10 times more doable
than him on DPS.
Yeah.
Oh, well, we still won.
Let's go.
Yeah, no, we got this.
This is Bunder Crunch.
Best believe.
Okay.
You're able to do something more fun to slow me now.
My hee-haha-oh-shee is no longer hee-haha-ha.
Really pain and suffering.
Bro, I'm tempted to be like, sub me out, get Saipa in here.
At least I'll make the team.
team's fair I just said that I'll be like go sub me out for
site pay right now
to protect them you can keep my money I don't need it yeah
not burst but yeah yeah okay so hello first good with that
everyone yeah that's fine okay hello and then I was going to
first ban Gambit.
If they don't first ban Gambit, we could save Gambit too.
I agree.
Wow.
No, they first ban Gambit.
Yeah, they banned it.
I think you save Sue here.
Alright.
Money, money, money.
It must be funny.
Okay, we save Sue and I think you've found Mantis.
Sounds good.
Mew, meew, meew.
I'm not assuming Mag be better at luck.
Do we lose because of bads?
Not my fault.
Do they play Groot?
Not my problem.
Yeah, they just play it.
They just win for a little bit.
Yeah.
Do we play Groot?
If you don't want to, I can just play Garuda and you can
play Rogue.
Yeah, I think we did that.
Okay.
I would have gone for a second to protect.
Hold on, let them do their thing first.
I can be, I should be able to be like emergency sub.
Get me out.
It looks like they just want to play like super front to
back, no?
yeah yeah bro the tournament game didn't start until yeah
okay 1 p.m we had i think we we had our first game at 11 or
12 p.m i don't know we don't need to yeah i should be able
to tap out i don't want to deal with it i feel like it's
good and uh because i 11 or 12 p.m when we had first game so
i got up early for no you can do a lot of things we can do
ultra we can do starlord that's up to you i think i think
i'll try i think we ran it i think so yeah we've always been
enjoying no channel too much low gremlin enables both the
dps to do too much i think yeah i agree to win this one.
Do you want to rock it again, Dukue?
If it's rock, sure, sure.
Is it rocket two or what?
Yeah, probably.
Actually, I think you play two.
All right.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
You can tell I'm dead inside.
Interacting with my stupid stuff.
I'm like, all right.
The light gone from her eyes.
You can chain the dashes.
You can E and shift up to them or you can shift and then E.
At least we weren't the first team eliminated.
Let's, um, try what they have and we can make it.
guys we are technically better than site bay if they're
playing like we survived longer than site base team guys and
i can just go cap if they do that through venom it's fine
phoenix phoenix they have groups i'm gonna struggle my walls
in three two one stringing
Hawkeye.
I'm breaking Colonial.
I'm walking.
Three, two, one.
Rogue on me.
He's going to big wall.
He's walled.
Nice.
Big walled.
Walking in three, two, one.
I'm walking.
Walking, Lesser.
Good swat.
Half HP.
I'm still walking in big wall.
I'm big walling.
I'm chilling.
They use their big wall.
We can hold the space.
Their Hawkeye is right side.
I'm checking in.
Watch ball, watch ball.
I'm dead.
Wait, there's the Phoenix.
It's got to be separated, separate.
Wow.
They're good swapping, no big one.
I have two tanks on me.
Yeah, we're trying our best.
I have ult for now.
I have my ult.
We can just play to get our Hawkeye off mid-fight.
Yeah, I can use my ult to get their support.
We can have better support ults and better DPS ults later.
Yep.
You out first, okay?
Okay.
Just go for it.
Try and hold it as much as you can.
I'm breaking clone and I'm walking.
He's walking, right?
Grit swap, grit swap, grit swap.
That's big one.
Yeah, fuck guy.
We should be fine, right?
I'm all in for myself.
I'm grabbing them, I'm grabbing them.
It's a pretty good.
Okay.
I'm trying to live.
Chill, chill, chill.
I'm trying to punch.
Oh, you guys are trying to save you?
We can still win.
I couldn't.
I got his shot.
We can still win.
It's both are supportive.
I'm trying to get out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's not stopping TP.
He's gonna be late.
We play fast.
I have a wall.
I'm walking.
I can walk.
Grit's back.
He's big wall and small walls.
Look at her.
Look at the rogue.
The rogue is like trolling.
There's a Hawkeye.
I pulled Hawkeye down, but he's coming.
Yeah.
Rogus and half HP.
Rogus all.
Rog.
I'm blocking.
He's low.
Grit's one.
I'm only heals.
They're low.
Nice.
They're TPing now.
Carry the TP and pipe.
Yeah, we can stay on point and they can't.
They're off the portal three for us.
They don't have time.
Oh my gosh, Rookie.
Nice.
I pushed him off the portal accidentally.
Good job, Rookie.
I'm walking on them here.
I grabbed them.
There's like someone, there's a rope behind us.
There's a rope behind us.
Phoenix is top right.
Yeah, Phoenix is top right.
I'm going to grab them top right.
I grab them.
I grab Phoenix.
It's one, it's one.
I can catch a man.
I need care behind you.
He's right here, right here.
I'm looking at him.
Rogue is still trapped.
Can we chill?
You know what?
I'm chilling.
Yeah, I'm walking.
I'm walking.
Rogue is out.
Rogue is one.
I'm walking a big wall.
Three, two, one.
Thanks for a wall.
Thanks for a wall really hard.
It's a portal that vanish.
Yeah, they copy.
I grab it.
You're in there.
I'm stuck in.
I need help.
I'm done.
I'm dead.
I'm triple tank.
They have no support.
I have mine.
I think we go, we go Stormpun.
or at least like fun yeah i got fun okay okay i wait for you
just wait we can take the corner and then walk hard their
phoenix is gonna be above you guys yeah all right i'm
waiting three seconds i can combo with spark chip i'm
walking in three two one i'm walking i'm walking i got rogan
i can die i'm buying their tanks right now we're up to we're
up to we're up to look at their Emma one.
Emma, Emma here.
Blanch.
Yeah, we can walk in combo now.
They're gonna have both support assists right soon.
They're gonna have road.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can you set up top right so maybe I can go under spawn?
Wait, I wanna go under spawn.
Can you come?
I'm going under spawn.
Three, two, one.
It's big, it's big, it's three people.
Nice.
Three on him.
I need more people on fire.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's coming.
choke i can maybe play fast we need to go with rogue i think
they're we can't let him support we should walk we should
walk into them we should walk into them right now we should
i want to walk into them i'm ready yeah yeah yeah they're
going less they're going less they're going less they're
going less they're going less left they're left i need help
just shoot them just shoot them stuff them hard stuff them
hard it's okay their cap is your cap cap cap one i am on you
i am on you i love you cap cap cap cap cap cap cap cap cap
cap cap cap cap cap cap that phoenix i'm shooting he fucked
that up Look at the rogue inside!
Elvis!
I'm looking up!
Nice, nice, nice.
It's the other one.
You tried all.
I'm dead.
We can win.
We can, we can, we can, we can, we can, we can.
I'm living, I'm living.
Walk here.
Walk here, walk here.
I'm walking, walk here, walk here.
I'm walking, walk here.
I'm walking on us.
Don't let Hawkeye get kills.
We need to stop reset if you can.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm on you guys.
I'm so.
Yeah, I'm trying to live.
I'm trying to live.
I'm grabbing cap cap cap grab these wall these wall these
wall We're back Yeah, we're chilling still we're back here
almost Come on top right Phoenix I don't care I'm walking
hard on point three I'm on one Invis with you Invis with you
I got you I don't know the guy behind us I don't have He's
up left healing everything I go for a walkie soon I'm gonna
die on one Okay, okay, carry Groove I'm going back one I'm
going back one Loki on point, Loki on point, one HP.
Bro, Bro, Bro, Bro, Bro, Bro.
Bro, Bro, Bro, Bro, Bro, Bro, Bro.
I'm shooting their portal.
They're gonna have some portals really soon.
We don't come, they're good.
Yeah, we come.
Damn.
This one.
They're running wolves.
They have a wolf now.
Oh, nope.
Oh, no, they don't.
I'm looking hardly looking for combo.
They have Phoenix, no support.
I'm grabbing top right I'm grabbing top right can you see
we're top left I'm grabbing it's a lot it's a lot it's a lot
I'm breaking mode I'm gonna let you heal no no no I'm not up
it's okay it's okay oh they're one just keep stuffing them
we can walk into them with swill tender and our punish roll
okay just make sure we play aggressive here oh Oh, I healed
you too.
Yeah, you got me.
Maybe a trade?
No, I'm out.
I'm out.
No, no, no.
Wow.
Invisible?
Sweet, sweet.
They have both support.
Phoenix.
Hawkeye.
Do you still want to use aggressively for Sue?
Yeah, they have a lot.
No, not anymore.
Not anymore.
He's going to try to play in the invisible and headshot me.
Okay.
Yeah, we just waited so.
We have Tamu.
Yeah, they're working hard.
They're walking hard.
They push really hard.
We can see.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm actually.
Good, good.
Hawk out on me.
You're by yourself.
It's last fight.
I have to pull some bandwidth.
I'm out.
I'm walking.
Okay.
Good fight.
Only fight.
I'm molling them.
I'm trying to shoot Phoenix.
He's holding.
It's something.
Care the headshot.
That's from Hawk.
Three, two, one.
Miles over.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm dead here.
I'll do B I'm breaking big wall I got Phoenix I got Phoenix
kill Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm saying on point, I'm on point,
I'm on point, I'm on point.
You can do whatever We need Hawkeye going back Watch wall,
watch wall, Spark Jeep, watch wall I can't, yeah, I'm
trying, I'm trying I go for Hawkeye again Hawkeye 1, Hawkeye
1 You can touch, yeah, thank her, you have thank her I'm
off, I'm off I'm on, I'm on Come on, I'm on Come to the
outside
I'm pulling backward through.
I'm Gurutan.
Can you guys walk?
Three, two.
I'm walking.
I got 4 points.
I have kills.
Thanks for world.
Thanks for the world.
Just live.
Just live, live, live, live.
I'm on Enverse.
Yeah, we almost have Rode.
We need to walk with our Rode soon.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
Work, walk, walk, walk, walk!
You rest, you rest, you rest.
I get rest.
Take the wall.
I'm an older.
Go ahead.
Carry the group.
Or the key.
Keep your ult.
Okay, okay.
I'll go in.
Walking, walking, walking.
Rogue, Rogue, Rogue, Rogue, Rogue, Rogue, Rogue.
Rogue one, Rogue one.
I'm living.
Curler, Greer, Greer, Greer, Greer, Greer.
I'm next one.
Yeah, I was...
I'll go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, two.
I have Phoenix, I have Phoenix.
Rogue is one, Rogue is one.
Rogue is one.
Your wall, your wall, your wall.
Chill, chill.
Nice one.
I'm raising my wall.
I'm 80 my old.
Heard, heard, heard.
Don't have lamp for this.
Killing.
I'm dead.
Oh, I think.
Yeah, we couldn't get it.
Come on.
I'm good.
Let's go push.
The current score is 0-0.
Time to switch.
Hey, winner bull.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
We got this.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
Are you okay?
I'm just playing the game, buddy.
I'm just...
I can actually try midnight.
Come on, I think it could be good.
I'm just...
That was a time of attraction.
There's no other thinking.
It's just muscle memory now.
Yeah.
I'm just playing the game.
They talk wide.
Oh, it's because they bad-gabbit.
I'm just doing my volunteer work.
I have heard that your natural abilities have caused you
much strife over here.
It's all reflex.
True enough.
My mutant powers ain't exactly...
When I say that skin, I think it's strange.
It is kind of similar.
I'm going to let them walk a little bit, and then I'm going
to swing on point where the point hits the corner.
Yeah, I'm swinging.
I'm swinging in three, two, one.
I'm under tanks.
Tanks are half.
I'm grabbing Groot.
We walk?
Yeah, I'm walling him.
I'm walling him.
Yeah, he's half.
He's half.
Big wall.
Carry the big wall.
Uh, Kerwals, yeah.
Okay, their turn, their turn.
Watch top left, top left, top guy, top left.
I'm on a stop point, I'm on a stop point.
3, 2, 1.
Source out.
DPS are low, DPS are low.
I need someone at a contest top.
They're walking hard on me.
Oh, you're wild, you're wild, you're wild.
One on the... I got one.
They're really low.
Okay, top.
Can we get TP?
Yeah, I can TP back.
I can TP back.
Okay, okay.
I have all I can just like walk out on car with it.
Okay.
I can talk.
There's three, two, one.
There is a Phoenix on from beside you.
Okay.
Yeah, there's a Phoenix to the right too.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, there's split.
They're split.
Okay.
I have over here.
Can we push the Hawkeye behind us?
Did we go?
There's a Phoenix to the right too.
He's up, he's up.
Okay, okay.
Nice.
I'm luckily Angel or the Rook, Rook Rook Shoot.
Great swelling.
Yeah, yeah, I'm breaking.
You have old first here, I think, rookie.
They're working their way.
Grit half!
He missed them.
I got him.
I got him!
I'm shooting heals him.
Oh yeah, yeah.
I got the Groot.
I got the Groot.44 got the Gold one more.
Group they copy?
They copy.
They copy it too.
He died.
Nice.
Phoenix.
Let's go.
Um, they have Phoenix or Hawkeye, Rogue.
I need to play far and get ready to copy.
Yeah, they have Emma Wolf.
They're gonna hard bully me.
I'm gonna play to bait them.
Just get ready to kill me.
Yeah.
That's their pull.
I'm playing left side of point.
I'll try and let you heal.
Here's the Wolf.
The Wolf is top left.
Woohoo!
I grabbed them.
Grab them on me.
Nice.
He's pushing it.
me they have no diamond no grab i'm walking hard look at
rogue look at rogue rogue is one i'm shielding yeah it's a
wall no passive no passive no passive i have to reload i'm
looking phoenix i'll try to body block i missed
i just got phoenix one shot in my band it's okay all good i
won't disappear We go next point.
Yeah.
I'll stop by Groot.
We can play Ghost here.
Yeah, we should.
We're close.
Roq, Roq, Roq, Roq.
I'm late.
I'm just spawned.
I'm trapped.
I'm dead.
We can start walking slowly.
I can.
I got you.
I'm good.
Yeah, we can walk.
She's wild, she's wild.
I pulled her back.
Rogue one, run one.
We're 98 on ours.
Can you check?
We don't need a match.
Live, live, live, live.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm forward.
I'm walking in three, two, one.
That's okay, that's okay.
We should stuff and play right side of point.
Yeah.
I'm trying to let you hear.
I'm big one on their push.
Three, two, one.
I'm all in their push, I'm all in their push.
Looking at my.
Rogue pulled back, we're going.
I pulled Rogue.
Yeah, I'm grabbing.
Three, two, one.
Nice.
I'm Iona.
I out you guys.
There's a Phoenix behind.
I copy.
They copied him.
He copied him.
Phoenix one.
Fix one.
Nice.
Walk up.
I pulled her back.
I don't want to get headshot though.
He goes.
They don't have support.
They use both support.
They're gonna have Hawkeye Rogue.
Yeah, we need to just stop.
Oh, he swapped the Hawkeye.
He's playing Monet now.
I don't know.
End of playing, Grets.
Just keep stuffing.
Ok, I'm going to wait for their push and then go second
okay.
Good, good, good, good.
Good with you, good with you.
His water.
Oh, I couldn't pull.
You guys good?
He got beer.
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
I am, I am.
Just that point, that point, that point, that point, that
point, that point.
I'm 74.
Yeah, we almost have two olds.
It's okay.
It's clear.
I still need it here.
Stop them!
I don't think we are less so it, I don't think we...
I don't think...
Yeah, we have to go right, yeah.
We can go right so...
They're close to...
They're gonna have both the DPS, okay?
Yeah, they might try to walk out early.
Yeah, we need to walk without them.
I think I...
My next one behind us without.
I'm gonna try and flank, I think.
The rogue is above.
The rogue is looking for something.
I'm walking on the rogue.
The rogue is going up for something.
He's alting, he's alting, he's alting.
Yeah, you got my...
You got my alting.
I can't touch, I can't touch.
I can't touch after you.
I can't do anything.
Yeah, I'm all in for you.
That's Monnet on point.
I'm trying to get the mega right side.
I can't touch.
I can touch it.
Monnet on point.
He's one.
Oh, I can't touch.
We can stop them for a little bit here with my opt.
Yep.
This rogue and Monnet and Phoenix they have copy, probably
double supports and group.
Group midnight.
Copy it.
Rogue's playing close.
You have ult first here.
I'm with you.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
I'm balling.
Luke, Luke, Luke, Luke.
I'm grabbing Rode.
I'm gonna marry this.
I'm marrying it.
I'm waiting for it.
Yeah, yeah, I'm close.
No one's going to grab this left.
I'm grabbing the bluff.
I grabbed for you.
It's big.
So we can see it.
Got one.
I can't see you.
I'm on back lane.
I'm going on point on one point on one point.
Coming back on cap.
I have nothing to copy.
They're gonna come me through.
I can touch, I can touch, I can touch, I can touch, I can
touch, I can touch.
One eight south.
Okay, one.
One eight south, top right.
Clark, nice try.
GG's, GG's, GG's.
GG's, nice try.
NT, NT was fun though.
DGs.
It's okay.
I can nap for one hour.
Oh my god, we're free.
It's okay.
There's no day two.
Oh.
I'm okay with that.
Word of wealth.
Thanks for playing, guys.
Yeah, thanks for the games.
Yes, thank you, thank you.
I'm freed.
I'm free.
I get that for an hour.
Oh my god, that was a seven...
That was almost a seven hour stream.
Oh my god.
We're out.
it's okay yeah oh my god i'm just happy that
i'm just happy that it's it's done because like i'm so tired
i'm actually so tired i did not realize that um i didn't
realize that that like it would go this long i would not
have signed up for it if they would do this now i know now i
know now i know i would not have signed up for it if the
schedule was like this
oh yeah i'm so i'm gonna rest all right guys not much to
talk about i'm just way too tired right now with I need I
need to take a nap for my my second job I need to take a nap
and as always everybody say hydrate pause check get a move
around get that blood flowing you sell for me head to bed
because you deserve it I'll see you guys next time everyone
no stream tomorrow yay I'm sorry I did try I tried my best,
but I'm absolutely exhausted at that point.
I was running on fumes.
I might have been making, like, really bad decisions.
But at that point, I was, I'm pretty sure, like, half the EU
players, I'm pretty sure, like, Riggsie was running on fumes
because he was not talking anymore.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure half the EU players were so fucking
tired.
And, like, I was really tired because I had to wake up so
early, too.
So, no stream.
Yeah, it was just...
My only, my biggest critique is that they should have, they
should have, you know, organized the better.
They really should have, yeah.
Um, um, anyway, I'm going to head off now.
Bye, everyone.
I got, I'm going to take a one hour nap.
Yeah, going on and off adrenaline was not, I think that's
why I have a headache too, because I, lock in and then lock
out and then lock in and lock out yeah there's just way too
much downtime for what they did for how they got the they
got the fucking the the landcasters too they got the fucking
landcasters they got all the like really well-known players
and rivals in both like rivals and content creation but it
this just i don't understand why the downtime is like this i
don't understand like um how they organized it like that
like but it's okay like you live and Learn.
You live and learn.
But if I'm definitely, I don't know if I'll do that again.
All right.
See you guys.
Bye, everyone.
Bye.